Good morning, everyone. We're about to convene the January 13th, 14th, 2021 State Board of
Education meeting. And seeing that board members are now present, Brooks, will you please call
the roll to establish the roll?
Of course, good morning. Member Sun.
Here. Thank you. Member Strauss.
Here. Member Rucker.
Present. Member Rodriguez.
Here. Member Patil-Brownson.
Here. Member Navo.
Here. Member McQuillan.
Here. Member Glover-Woods.
Here. Member Fatah.
Here. President Darling-Hammond.
Here. Member Burr.
Here. Everyone's present and accounted for.
Thank you. I hereby call the January 2021 meeting of the State Board of Education to order at 8.35 a.m.
And I'd like to commence by saluting the flag. Member Rodriguez, will you please lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance?
Absolutely. Please stand.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America, to the Republic for which it stands, one nation under God, with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you.
We are ready to begin.
And item one is our State Board projects and priorities item to take up the annual election of officers only.
The State Board of Education staff recommends that the State Board take up annual election of officers and will now hold an election for the position of President and Vice President for 2021.
The bylaws require that the State Superintendent preside over the election of the President and such other business as the State Board may direct, and I'll turn the gavel over to Tony.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. Good morning, everyone.
Good morning, everyone. And to also to the public, there is opportunity for public comment during any portion of the election.
If you wish to participate in public comment, the number to call will be provided to you on the screen.
We will now, in keeping with Article 5 of the bylaws for the State Board, I'd like to call for nominations for the Office of President.
No member may nominate or second the nomination for him or herself.
Six votes are necessary to elect an officer, and each officer elected shall serve for one year or until his or her successor is elected.
I'll now open the floor for nominations for the Office of President by their nominations.
So I would like to nominate Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond as President of the State Board of Education.
Is there a second to this nomination?
I second it.
We have a nomination and a second for Linda Darling-Hammond. Is there any public comment?
There is none.
There's no public comment.
Bruce, would you please call the roll?
I'm sorry, are there any other nominations? Seeing none, would you please call the roll?
Yes. Member Sun?
Aye.
Member Strauss?
Member Rucker?
Aye.
Member Rodriguez?
Member Patil Bronson?
Yes.
Member Navo?
Aye.
Member McQuillan?
Yes.
Member Glover Woods?
Member Fatah?
Yes.
Member Burr?
Yes. Enthusiastically.
With that unanimous vote, it is my pleasure to announce that Linda Darling-Hammond has been elected President for 2021.
Congratulations, Linda, and thank you again for being willing to serve in this capacity, especially in these very difficult times.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Congratulations, Linda, and thank you again for being willing to serve in this capacity, especially in these very difficult times.
Congratulations.
And it is my pleasure to return the virtual gavel back to you.
Thank you so much.
And thanks, everyone.
I appreciate it.
And it's such a wonderful board to work with.
We've been making such amazing progress over these number of years.
I am privileged to be able to work with you over the coming year.
And at this point, in keeping with Article 4 of the State Board's bylaws, I would like to call for nominations for the Office of Vice President.
No member may nominate or second a nomination for himself or herself.
Six votes are necessary to elect an officer, and each officer elected shall serve for one year or until his or her successor is elected.
I will now open the floor for nominations for the Office of Vice President.
Are there nominations?
Member Rodriguez?
I nominate Eileen Strauss.
Is there a second?
I will second.
Thank you very much.
Eileen Strauss has been nominated to the Office of Vice President.
Are there any other nominations?
Hearing none.
Is there any public comment?
We have one person signed up for public comment.
All right.
Thank you.
Caller, you are unmuted.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
It looks like they just hung up.
So there is no more public comment.
All right.
They probably wanted another item.
Brooks, can you please call the roll?
Let's call the roll.
Member Sun?
Aye.
Member Rucker?
Yes.
Member Rodriguez?
Aye.
Member Patil-Brownson?
Yes.
Member Navo?
Aye.
Member McQuillan?
Yes.
Member Glover-Woods?
Member Fatah?
Aye.
President Darling-Hammond?
Member Burr?
Aye.
Wonderful.
It is my pleasure to enthusiastically announce Eileen Strauss as Vice President for 2021.
Congratulations, Eileen.
Thank you so much.
I look forward to working with everybody this year and just so appreciate the collaboration and the work of our team.
Thank you.
I am glad to be here.
Thank you, Eileen.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, all of you for your hard work and the work you've done.
Thank you.
And thank you, everyone that's been on the line today.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you.
recommendations for appointments to the ACCS.
Item five, state educational agency approval
of the 2020-21 comprehensive support and improvement plans
authorized under the Every Student Succeeds Act,
section 1111D.
Item seven, approval of the fiscal year 2020-21
career technical education incentive grant allocations,
including the allocation formulas,
specific funding amounts, and the number of grant awards,
purposes for grant fund use,
and allowable and non-allowable expenditures.
The proposed waiver consent items are W1 through W4.
The proposed regular consent items are items seven through 14.
There are two items that have been withdrawn
from the agenda by the State Board of Education Office.
Item 17 on charter schools,
approving the commencement of the rulemaking process,
and item one, the portion of the item pertaining
to revisions to the ACCS policy,
and attachments three and four.
In terms of public input, members of the public
wishing to call in for public comment
should view the live stream of the meeting
to know at what time public comment
will occur for each item.
Public comment may be provided by dialing the phone number
that we will put on a slide before each occurrence.
And by entering a participant access code
and following each of the operator's prompts.
Upon dialing in, callers will be added to a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers when it is their turn
to provide public comment.
We will also ask callers to please turn down
the speaker volume on their computers
if they're following the live webcast
to avoid an echoing effect.
Public comment will be limited to one minute
for each speaker.
Item 15 is the general public comment item
during which members of the public may provide comment
on items that are not specifically listed
on the board's agenda.
Board members, please mute your microphones
when not speaking and keep your cameras on at all times
except during the schedule breaks
to ensure that we maintain a quorum
throughout today's virtual meeting.
For each item on the agenda,
there will be an opportunity for you board members
to raise your hand during the Zoom participant window
if you would like to ask a question or make a comment.
So agenda item one is our state board priorities item
and we will only take up the state superintendent's report
and my report at this time
and then we will reopen the item later this afternoon.
I'm now gonna turn it over to Superintendent Tony Thurmond
for his report, Tony.
Thank you, Madam President.
Congratulations again, President Darling-Hammond,
Vice President Strauss.
Thank you both for your steady leadership and stewardship
and it is an honor to continue working with you
and all the members of the board.
To all the members of the board,
this is the first time we're seeing each other this year.
I wanna wish you a happy new year.
I'm hopeful that 2021 is off to a good start.
As you might imagine, our focus continues to be
on how do we keep students and families and educators safe
during the pandemic.
We have continued our conversations
on all phases and all aspects of school reopening.
We've worked closely with the governor
and with President Darling-Hammond
on a number of proposals that will increase COVID testing.
Like everyone, we continue to turn our hope
to seeing the acceleration of the vaccine distribution
so that it reaches our schools.
At least, Constancio and my staff has been serving
on the governor's advisory task force related to vaccines
and also has been serving on the governor's workforce group
to stand up the Valencia lab that will provide COVID testing
for many of our school districts.
We've also just kept our focus
on how do we offset learning gaps
that just are unavoidable
that many students have experienced,
especially students who don't have computers,
students who haven't checked in,
and just students who for whatever reason,
the connection just hasn't been strong enough
if they're not in class with their teachers.
We have literally worked with a number
of our school districts on efforts to engage students
who have not checked in.
That means that a number of our staff
are calling alongside school district staff
to families where students haven't checked in.
We put together webinars for the field
where we work with equity advocates
like Etrus West and PK and families together
to show our schools how to maximize distance learning,
to find ways to support our students in distance learning,
to make sure our families are the most engaged
they can be so that we have ways to offset learning gaps.
We put on a webinar
addressing the mental health needs of our students,
a social emotional learning webinar
with experts who deliver social emotional learning strategies.
More than a thousand educators participating
in that webinar and in that training.
We intend to continue our conversation
with school districts about strategies
that they can use to offset learning gaps
on January 21st at 4.
We'll put on the next webinar
a number of experts,
including our own president Linda Darling-Hammond
to share examples of ways to offset learning gaps,
whether it's through small group or coaching for teachers,
what we do during extended learning time,
what we do during the summer.
We know that there'll be many opportunities
that we must pursue starting right away
to really continue our work to offset learning grants.
And we've repurposed some grants that we've received
to provide more resources to the field.
And we've just announced the grant
that we call the equity grant
that really gives resources to school districts
to do anything that will help them
in offsetting learning grants.
That can be for professional development,
it can be for family engagement work.
And so we announced those grants
and have received more than 470 applicants,
all districts asking for support
so that they can do work to offset equity grants.
We intend to be meeting with the equity staff
of each of our thousand districts.
We've invited them to participate
in what we're calling an equity webinar.
It's really a listening session for us to work together
with many of the folks who are working at the field level
on what they're seeing and hearing
that can allow us to continue our work
to close equity gaps to support students.
And we continue our effort
in the face of mounting violence
that we've seen in the Capitol against our lawmakers,
the actions of white supremacy in our nation's Capitol.
In the backdrop of all these things,
we continue our conversation around
how do we use education to end hate?
And just on yesterday,
we held our third installment in the conversation
where we led a conversation with great partners
about how do we counter Islamophobia in our schools,
recognizing that many of our students are bullied
for their faith, recognizing that even though
our standards are clear on what we teach about religion,
sometimes in schools, our students who practice Islam
experience the wrong things being taught
and things that reinforce stereotypes.
This conversation follows up two other webinars
and in services that we've provided.
One that focuses on what we teach
about Native American history
and to Native American students.
And another that we focus on
how do we counter antisemitism?
We know that in the last few months and years,
we've really seen an increase in acts of hate.
And in many cases, the largest number of acts of hate
that impact our schools have been
in the areas of antisemitism and Islamophobia.
We intend to continue doing more webinars
where we address the issues of racism
in the spirit of Black Lives Matter
and the ongoing racism
that many of our students of color experience.
The focus on how we support LGBTQ students from bullying,
we intend to do this.
And all of this is part and parcel
with a number of grants that we provide
at the school districts to allow them at the local level
to provide their own professional development
to address implicit bias, explicit bias,
and to continue to use education to end hate.
We'll be giving you an email with some press releases
so that you can see the folks that we celebrated
over the course of the last several weeks.
We celebrated the classified employees of the year,
a number of wonderful folks,
custodians, folks in maintenance,
folks who work in the office.
We want to share with you who these wonderful leaders are
who've been doing longstanding service across the state,
like teachers committed and dedicated
to the wellbeing of our students.
We wanna share with you the winners
of the Presidential Awards in excellence.
You'll be receiving copies of that,
as well as the schools that have been selected
for the National Distinguished Schools Awards.
And so you'll be getting copies of all of these.
We wanna, even in these tough times,
continue to celebrate those who bring forward
innovation and commitment
to supporting our students and our schools.
And finally, I wanna share with you some new faces
that you'll see on the CDE team.
Many of you know that we have had some grants
that we've been able to receive during the pandemic,
upwards of $5 million,
and we've turned those grants into opportunities
for us to support schools.
All of these webinars,
all of these, the focus on addressing implicit bias,
the manner in which we try to work with our school districts
on some new things like family engagement,
largely supported by these grants.
Wanna acknowledge that we had our HR director,
Valerie, has retired after serving CDE for 30-some years.
Thank you, Valerie.
And so many of you will,
I'm sure many of you knew her and know her.
We're pleased that you'll now have the opportunity
to work with our new HR director, Shonda Bell,
who comes to us after being in a similar role
at the Department of Motor Vehicles
and has already hit the ground running
and working to help us innovate
a number of our practices in HR.
A big focus for us is how do we create equity in our hiring?
And so Shonda has gone to work on that.
She will be aided by a new deputy superintendent
who we're pleased to bring on,
who will also focus on human resources issues
and strengthening the work that we do with our labor
and management partners at the state level.
She's a former teacher, principal,
and most recently served as the deputy superintendent
for human resources at Contra Costa County.
That's Cheryl Cotton, who will be joining us shortly.
And again, will be someone who will be available to help us
as we work on diversity issues.
We also have brought on another deputy superintendent
who will be helping us with a number of special projects.
Her name is Jenny Carreon,
and she joins us from the healthcare field
working at one of the largest federally qualified FQHCs
in Southern California and brings a health background
that is helping us as we continue to try and steady the work
around helping districts, how they safely open.
She's on board and has been helping us
with our initiatives to address chronic absenteeism
of those students who've not checked in.
In a similar way, we brought on a new director
for family engagement, Lisa Borrego,
who joins us from the district level
where she has focused on family engagement.
She's already organized an incredible campaign
to help us in helping districts
who've seen attendance challenges exacerbated
through the pandemic.
Also, Pamela Kadakia, who's joined us
in working on our equity effort.
She's been leading our webinars on education to end hate,
has done incredible work with our grant series.
And Dr. Michael Ishimoto, who joins us in the capacity
of helping us to expand research
that we can use to benefit districts.
You'll have a chance to meet all of these folks,
but we wanted to let you know
that through a series of grants opportunities,
we've been able to build out the capacity of CDE
to help our districts a bit more.
And so this concludes my report.
As always, I'm happy to take any questions
that you may have.
Thank you so much.
And we welcome all of these new colleagues to the effort.
And I thank you for all of the intensive work
that the department has been undertaking.
And I just wanna underscore that that conversation
that you've been leading against racism and hate
and for mutual understanding and unity
is so very important right now.
We really appreciate it.
These are challenging times for California and our nation.
We're in the midst of a public health crisis,
an economic crisis, a long overdue reckoning
with racial injustice and a crisis of confidence
in our democratic system of government.
And we know that a strong public education system
is critical to addressing all of these crises
and that that's really part of our charge.
The pandemic has, as Superintendent Thurmond noted,
exacerbated the inequities of society and education.
Even before the pandemic,
many schools were struggling
to meet the needs of all learners.
And when learning was disrupted in March,
the vital role that schools play became clear.
Our economy and many households
cannot function without them.
With no time to prepare, educators stepped up
to provide access to remote learning,
to food and to a variety of other services.
And we will need to do still more.
Over the last year,
California lost 1.3 million non-farm jobs.
And those job losses have triggered
for many of our students.
Housing insecurity, greater food insecurity
and other challenges that have a devastating impact
on the physical and mental health of family members,
including children.
We're going to need to wrap around them
with social and emotional as well as academic resources
and with social services that connect their families
to secure havens and supports.
That's why it's so important
that the governor proposed the largest investment ever
in TK through 12 public education last week.
At $85 billion, nearly $15 billion more than last year.
This budget also includes more than $300 million
for student mental health and community schools
that provide wraparound services,
as well as school climate surveys
to help us keep track of and respond
to what students are experiencing.
We know that community schools can play a huge role
in reducing the impacts of the pandemic
by connecting families to needed services,
by keeping a very personalized eye
on the welfare of each child,
by ensuring that they're connected to and engaged in school
and the capacity to expand that way of working with
children and families is going to be very important for us
coming through the pandemic with families and children
intact and engaged in school.
As we see that COVID levels will eventually recede
and vaccinations are beginning to roll out,
we will find ourselves at a crossroads.
One of the things that we need to think about
as we take up issues here at the state board
and in the department is whether we will revert
to the system as we've known it,
or will we take steps to transform the system
in ways that will improve education
for students in California.
California has an opportunity to use the disruption
created by the pandemic to turn a new way forward,
to make schools more equitable, more socially responsive
and more academically engaging
than some of them may have been before.
We must use the next few months to prepare to move forward.
And this means rethinking the way in which we use
the school day and the school year to support
and educate students to maximum advantage,
creating conditions for more humane, more caring,
more equitable teaching and learning.
It is the time for us to move beyond the assumptions
of the agrarian school calendar
that is no longer really relevant to today's economy,
to move beyond the notion that schooling
is a standardized march through fixed content
that's the same for every child,
whether or not it meets their needs.
The governor's budget also includes $4.6 billion in funds
for targeted academic supports and interventions
that are personalized to the needs of students
and for expanding education into the summer
through extended school year or summer school,
a variety of vehicles.
These types of interventions will be critically important
to accelerating learning,
especially for our youngest learners,
but really for all of our learners.
We also know that beyond adding time,
students only thrive in a rich learning environment
in which they feel valued and purposeful
and they're engaged in meaningful learning
and extra support and tutoring
are only part of the solution.
We need to continue to support educators
to provide deeper learning experiences
that are relevant, exciting and connected to students lives
while they continue to redesign schools
that are centered on relationships.
And across our state,
educators have been inventing a variety of ways
to be connecting one-on-one with students, with families,
to be creating the kind of engaging learning experiences
that make students want to be learning on their own
as well as together.
And we need to figure out ways to capture those inventions
to allow for and support
educator to educator learning opportunities
that are proliferating across the state
and to enable strong relationships to be catalytic
for engaging previously disconnected students.
So the budget does include $250 million
for professional learning opportunities
that will include the supports for teaching
to accelerate learning in the content areas
as well as for social emotional learning
and restorative practices, implicit bias training,
ethnic studies and other tools
to ensure that students see themselves in school
and feel connected to and engaged in what's going on there.
It is also why our efforts to provide guidance
for remote learning, which you'll hear about later today,
focus on making the curriculum more meaningful
and motivating as well as well supported
with innovative uses of technologies
that we should bring back with us
into brick and mortar settings.
Of course, the pandemic is not the only major challenge
that our society is facing right now.
Our entire democracy was challenged last week
with the insurrection at the Capitol in Washington.
The dire need for a commitment to civic education
could not have been clearer.
And we need to rebuild the nation's common ground
and its commitment to a democratic way of life.
Our recent actions to adopt criteria
for the state seal of civic engagement
and to stimulate civic learning and engagement
throughout our schools from TK all the way up to high school
are more important than ever.
This effort to bring civics knowledge and commitment
to our core values alive is needed to create
the common understandings that hold our people together.
This week, the California history
social science subject matter project
invited all educators in California to join with us
to discuss what we can do to help students
make sense of this moment and to empower them
to advocate for democracy, justice,
and end to racism and hate
and build a better future for all of us.
That really does sum up our charge
to help our schools build a better future for all of us.
And the new administration arriving next week in Washington
is equally committed to that goal.
So even though we are still in the throes of this pandemic,
there is a new day dawning.
It is in these moments of crisis
that great transformations are possible.
And I urge us to seize this moment
to continue.
Linda, I apologize.
I think you're on mute.
Was I on mute for that entire conversation?
After seize the moment.
Okay, I went on mute.
So what did I say?
To seize the moment to continue our work
to transform our public education system
to one that is more equitable and empowering
for all of our children.
Thank you.
And with that, we'll move to agenda item number two,
which is the distance learning curriculum
and instructional guidance project update,
which I actually was just referencing.
This is not an action item.
It is being presented for information only,
and it will be presented by Shanine Coates of the CDE,
along with Nancy Harada and Dave Gordon
of Sacramento County Office of Education,
Joe Bowler of Stanford University,
Hallie Yopp of California State University of Fullerton,
Richard Culotta of the International Society
for Technology and Education.
So Shanine and Hallie, please, yeah.
Good morning, Board President Darling-Hammond,
Vice President Strauss, and esteemed members of the Board.
I'm Shanine Coates, Director of the Curriculum Frameworks
and Instructional Resources Division,
and I am joined by my colleagues to provide an update
on the distance learning guidance project
that was authorized as part of Senate Bill 98.
Next slide, please.
I'll just give a moment.
Thank you.
Educators will never forget March 2020
when the world began responding to COVID-19,
including physical school closures and social distancing.
Educators, schools, and districts, communities, families,
and students went into problem-solving mode
to rise to the occasion of how to provide high quality
first instruction in a remote setting.
For many districts and schools,
the pandemic served as the impetus
to shift to one-to-one devices.
What we've seen in the field of education
over the last year is the ultimate display
of heartening resilience in a time of extreme change.
Now that we are moving towards more schools reopening,
distance learning guidance is still very relevant.
Even with the vaccine, some students will remain
and continue in remote learning or hybrid learning settings.
Despite its devastation,
and even in light of the inequities
that have been highlighted,
COVID-19 brought us to the brink of a unique opportunity
to set the foundation for the future of education
based on what we've learned.
We as educators are at a pivotal moment in time.
We hold the potential to change our trajectory,
to identify evidence-based policies
to inform a sustainable learning model
that allows for flexibility,
where digital learning serves as a key component
for how we build student-centered learning opportunities
and create spaces that cultivate support
and inspire lifelong learners.
This guidance will assist teachers
as they continue to integrate technology into the classroom,
even in what we hope to be a post-COVID world.
Section 121 of Senate Bill 98 appropriated funding
to the Sacramento County Office of Education
to develop a draft distance learning curriculum
and instructional guidance for mathematics,
English language arts, English language development,
including guidance around social emotional learning
and assessments.
This guidance will come before you,
the state board, in May 2021.
Today, we would like to provide an update on this work,
as well as receive your input.
Next slide, please.
I am joined by several members of the project's leadership
and content development team.
At this time, I would like to turn it over
to the Sacramento County Office of Education
Superintendent, David Gordon,
to introduce the leadership team.
Superintendent Gordon.
Thank you very much, Shanee.
Am I on camera?
I do not see you on camera, sir.
Okay, I guess I'm not on camera, but thank you.
Thank you, Shanee.
I'm Dave Gordon,
Sacramento County Superintendent of Schools,
and I want to congratulate President Darling-Hammond
and Vice President Strauss on your election.
And between you and Superintendent Thurmond,
we are so grateful for the strong leadership
and the leadership that you have.
For the strong leadership that you provided
and continue to provide.
It's much appreciated.
SCOE has convened a strong team
to develop the distance learning curriculum
and instructional guidance.
We have contracted with the International Society
for Technology in Education, known as ITSE,
to serve as the lead organization,
coordinate the writing team, and draft the final product.
We're also working with computer using educators,
known as Q, that has extensive technology expertise
working with educators, specifically in California.
An important component of the work includes
the identification of critical standards in mathematics
and English language arts, English language development.
And we're very pleased to have convened a team
of nationally recognized experts for these content areas
that includes, for ELA, ELD, Dr. Halley Yopp,
Nancy Brindleson, Dr. Douglas Fisher, and Dr. Nancy Frye.
For mathematics, Dr. Joe Bowler and Cathy Ann Williams.
And for distance learning, Dr. Catherine Kennedy from ISTE.
And now I'm pleased to turn it over to Dr. Nancy Gerota,
our Deputy Superintendent at SCOE,
to provide an overview of the project.
Thank you, Superintendent Gordon.
If you can switch to the next slide.
Thank you.
So what I'd like to do is to begin
with providing a broad overview of the content areas
that will be included in this guide.
I will then describe the structures and the processes
that we have put in place to gather input
in the development of this guide.
And then we will move into these sections
that are currently under development.
So as you can see on the slide, Senate Bill 98 calls
for the development of a distance learning curriculum
and instructional guidance for mathematics,
English language arts, and English language development.
This guidance document will include a framework
for addressing critical standards in the area of mathematics,
English language arts, and English language development.
This document will also include guidance
in the area of formative and diagnostic assessment,
and will provide recommendations for aggregating time
for instruction and independent work by grade span.
Another key component of this document
will be the inclusion of strategies to support
social emotional learning for our students
in an early learning department,
in a distance learning environment.
And I think it's important to note here
that we are coordinating our efforts with the team at CDE
who is leading the state's social emotional learning team.
And here at the Sacramento County Office of Education,
we have our assistant superintendent, Brent Mallicoat,
who serves on the state SEL team.
So we are ensuring that we are aligning our efforts.
This guidance resource will also include
the importance of approaches
to meet the needs of all students.
So there will be sections focused on meeting the needs
of students with disabilities, English learners,
as well as other vulnerable groups.
We will also be addressing strategies to accelerate learning
to address the mitigation of learning loss.
And we are working with partners
to identify high quality online interactive materials
that will be embedded throughout the document.
This provides an overview of the organizational structure
that we have developed to move forward with this work.
And we're very, very pleased with the strong infrastructure
that we have put in place.
We are working, as you can see, with both ISTE and Q,
their leadership and expertise in the area
of the use of technology and education
are recognized at the international, national,
and state level.
And we are just so pleased to be working
with both organizations to help lead this effort.
As Superintendent Gordon highlighted,
we also have nationally recognized experts
in the areas of mathematics and ELA, ELD.
And for the area of mathematics,
Dr. Jo Buller is the lead writer for this section.
And not only is she a nationally recognized expert,
but what's important to note is that she's also part
of the committee convened by the CDE
that is working on the revisions to the math framework.
So that connection was critically important in our work.
For the ELA, ELD section, Dr. Halley Yopp
and Nancy Bernelson were key authors
of the ELA, ELD framework.
And so their contributions are ensuring
that this document is completely aligned
with our existing resource.
And then of course, Dr. Douglas Fisher and Dr. Fry
have currently developed a variety of resources
around distance learning.
So we're very pleased to be able to tap in
to their expertise.
I will be describing later the structure
that we have put in place to develop and gather input
from the distance learning advisory committee.
And we've also put in place an ongoing structure
for stakeholder input.
So at this time, I would like to turn it over
to Richard Culotta, who is the chief executive officer
for the International Society for Technology and Education.
Good morning, Dr. Rota.
Thank you for giving me a minute here
and Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond
and all of the board members.
It's a pleasure to join you for a few minutes virtually here.
I just wanted to take a second to share a little bit
about what our role is as ISTE
and also to mention quickly what we do
for those of you who may not be familiar with us.
So we're thrilled to be joining SCOE and Q
and the other great members of this team
to help pull together this guide,
this vision that will both help serve the schools
in California, but also we believe really be a model
for other states to follow as this is exactly the work
that needs to happen at the moment.
So our role in ISTE, what we're doing is really helping
to make sure we're informing all of this work
with solid research, right?
Educational research, what we're learning
from learning sciences and make sure
that it's really grounded in solid principles.
We'll also be working on leading the writing
of the guides, right?
That you'll see.
But one of the parts that I'm most excited about
is the way that Dr. Rota and the team have envisioned this
is really leveraging a variety of experts,
both in California and also nationally, internationally
to really make sure we're getting the best thinking
and best ideas.
And that's part of what we do.
ISTE as an international organization,
we work very closely with all states,
we work very closely with experts in this area.
And so we're pulling together a variety of ideas
and really best practices that we can pull from
to be able to show examples of what these solid research
based practices look like.
We feel it's very important not to just throw out
a bunch of sort of principles,
even if they're really solid principles,
we feel like it's important that they also are accompanied
by tangible practical examples
of what this looks like in practice.
So that's what we'll do.
The last part you see on there, the last two bullets,
we'll work on the design and publishing of the final guide
and developing some digital supplemental content.
This is important because we're making a guide here
that's talking about what the future of learning looks like
and how to leverage technology
and think about things in new and different ways.
And so it's a little awkward
if we talk about all the possibilities
and present a kind of stale looking text document, right?
So what we will do is have, yes, some guides,
but they will be very accessible.
They'll have lots of examples built in
and some digital content, some video examples,
some other things so that it really practices
what we preach a bit here as well.
One final thing that I'll just share
before handing the mic back to Dr. Rota
is that if for those who have not worked with ISTE
or aren't familiar with what we do,
our organization, we're a large nonprofit organization
and our focus is on helping think about
how do we use technology and innovative approaches
to solve tough problems in education.
So we focus a lot on looking at how do we use technology
to close equity gaps.
We internally call it Techquity.
We look at using technology to help make sure teachers
are prepared to really thrive in new environments
to make sure students are prepared for a future world
that looks very different.
And we do that through a whole variety of work streams,
both research that we conduct through partners
like Q and others, but also in providing
and working very closely with teachers and schools
to understand their needs and be able to capture that
in tangible ways.
We do that with a number of districts
across the state of California.
In fact, we have a large event that we do every year.
We bring about 25,000 education innovators together
in person and we were planning on having that
in Anaheim this year, but for reasons that you all know,
that had to be postponed.
So we're very excited to work on this together
with the team and to end with what President Darling Hammond
said, we have an opportunity here.
There's an opportunity to use this moment.
We never would have asked for this COVID moment,
but we got it and the worst thing that we could do
is not take advantage of it in order to really rethink
and reset some of our expectations.
And we are excited to work with SCOE to help create
this guide to do just that.
Back to you, Dr. Arrota, thank you.
Thank you.
So the next slide highlights the important role Q
and it was important to bring Q into this leadership role
because of their extensive experience
working with California educators.
So Q and ISTE are working very closely together
in the development of this resource and what Q has done
thus far is to conduct a survey of California educators
to identify research-based best practices and to begin
to identify high quality interactive resources
that will be embedded throughout this guide.
They are also helping to develop and identify key educators
to include in these vignettes that will help bring life
to the content and document best practices
within the distance learning environment
or a hybrid environment or a classroom setting
using technology as was mentioned.
They are also curating a list of high quality
interactive online materials and will be the key entity
vetting those resources.
Next slide.
As in the initial phase of our work,
we knew that it was important to gather input
from a broad range of stakeholders.
So we began with a letter that was sent on behalf
of state superintendent, Tony Thurman, our board president,
Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond and our county superintendent.
And this letter was sent out back in August
to extend the invitation to be part
of a distance learning coalition.
So the letter was sent to 58 county offices of education,
all districts here in California
and a number of advocacy groups and other organizations.
As you can see, we have the respondents
that include 18 county offices of education,
13 school districts and five advocacy groups,
but do know that we have reached out beyond these respondents
and we have developed a broader coalition
to support this work.
We have and will continue to conduct outreach sessions
to continue to solicit feedback
on the development of this guide.
And the important component of this outreach
is that it includes representation from not only educators,
but parents, other experts,
and we are moving into a process to gather,
conduct empathy interviews with students as well.
Next slide.
So this is the ambitious,
I refer to this as the ambitious timeline
that we have in place to develop this guidance document.
So again, we began in September of 2020
and in the initial part of this work,
we began by gathering initial input
from our advisory committee members
to gather input on the development of the outline
and then we held a subsequent session with our advisory
to review the draft outline that was developed
and we will continue to work with our advisory
to gather input as sections of this document
is being developed.
We are currently working with ISTE, Q
and all of the content writers
in developing this draft guidance document.
And the goal is to present this draft document
at the May state board meeting for final approval.
And then once we've received the feedback at the May meeting,
we will work again very closely with ISTE
and other contributors to develop the final document,
which again, as Richard mentioned, will be an online,
it will be both a PDF as well as an online digital resource
to make it easily accessible and user-friendly for educators.
Next slide.
So I shared with you the stakeholder groups
that were identified to support this project
and from that stakeholder coalition list,
we identified key members to serve on our advisory committee
and the advisory committee, their role is to provide guidance
throughout the course of this project
and provide input in the development of this resource.
They have also begun to help identify
interactive online materials as well as other resources
to support distance learning.
And they are helping to identify examples
of success stories and other illustrative examples
of districts or classroom examples
that we'll be able to incorporate into this guide
as either vignettes or videos.
Next slide.
So this is a broad overview of the committee members
who represent a variety of areas.
We have not only content experts
and I would like to point out
that in the area of content expertise,
we are working with Brian Lindeman,
who is the writing team lead
for the mathematics framework revision work.
We have members of the California subject matter project
serving on our advisory committee
as well as Californians together.
And as you can see, we have representation
from both school districts and county offices of education.
Professional organizations and associations
that serve on our advisory committee
include teacher associations, such as CTA and CFT.
We are also working
with the California parent teachers association,
California charter schools association,
PACE and Ed Trust West.
So moving forward, what we would like to do
is to share with you highlights
of the current draft document
that is currently under development.
Following the forward and the introduction,
there will be three sections.
And the first section will focus
on research-based distance learning guidance,
distance learning principles and practices.
And to develop this section,
ISTE conducted initially a literature review
to identify research-based best practices
for educators and distance learning.
And this formal literature review process
included meta-analysis and systematic reviews
with a particular focus on K-12 distance learning
for online learning.
The part A, the subsection part A
will cover research-based instructional strategies
in online learning.
And in this section,
they will include the national standards
for quality online courses.
There will be a section
focused on incorporating universal design
for learning framework,
as well as other resources to inform this section.
We are also working with Dr. Douglas Frye,
Dr. Douglas Fisher and Nancy Frye
in developing the assessment section.
And this section will provide guidance
in the area of both formative and diagnostic assessment,
and most importantly,
how to analyze and utilize this data
to differentiate instruction.
The section will also include strategies
to accelerate learning, to mitigate learning loss.
And then the final section, part C of section one,
will focus on fostering healthy,
equitable and inclusive digital communities.
And this is the section where the focus
on social-emotional supports for students
will be incorporated that include, again,
many of the resources that have been released
through the California Department of Education
so that we are ensuring that the content in this section
is aligned with other CBE resources.
So at this time, I am going to turn it over to Dr. Bowler,
who again is the lead writer
for the mathematics section, section two.
Good morning, State Board and members of the public.
My name is Jo Bowler.
We're going to talk about maths for a bit.
I'm a professor of mathematics education at Stanford
and co-founder of U-Cubed.
I'm also one of the five writers, as Nancy said,
of the new California maths framework.
So I thought I'd give you an overview
of the approach of that new framework
before we go into this project.
By showing you this visual,
we are emphasising in the new framework
that mathematics work for students
shouldn't be about practising through endless short questions,
but should be about investigating ideas.
And we've also communicated that teachers think about content
not as small disconnected methods,
but as bigger ideas that students can connect
and investigate with.
So we have set out four big content ideas
that you see at the bottom of that document
that apply across all of K-12,
which helps us give a progression through the grades.
So you may be able to see that communicating stories
with data, exploring changing quantities,
taking holes apart and putting parts together,
something we do a lot in mathematics,
and discovering shape and space.
These should always be integrated
with the mathematical practises
that you see on the vertical axis.
And then the cross-cutting themes,
which are new to the framework,
are meant to be encouraging purpose
for students' investigations.
We're saying that maths work should always have a purpose,
whether it's making sense of the world,
predicting what might happen, or impacting the future.
And these ideas apply to all the content and practises.
So that's the background for this work.
And if we can look at the next slide,
we can, myself and Cathy Williams, come to this work
having written a K-8 book series,
and that is organised also around big ideas.
And you see that in that network map.
And as we looked carefully at the standards
to think about ways of making them more manageable
to teachers for this project,
we decided that it wasn't really helpful to cut standards
as nearly all the ideas are needed later on,
but to make them into bigger ideas.
We're organising them under the content connections
of the new framework.
We're integrating them with the ELD framework,
and we plan to make connected maps like these
to show teachers the connected nature of the content.
So the next two slides, and we can look at the next slide,
give you an example from grade three.
If you read the wording of the standards,
you'll see that many of them are very narrow,
which we think leads publishers into making short questions
that target these narrow ideas.
If we just look at that, a little bit of the first one,
represent a fraction one over B on a number line diagram
by defining the interval from zero to one as the whole
and partitioning it into B equal parts,
recognise that each part has size one over B,
and that the end point of the part based at zero
locates the number one over B on the number line.
They're often written in ways that aren't very inspiring
for third grade teachers, we think.
And so we're taking this very detailed content
and we're raising it to a bigger level.
So if we could look at the next slide,
we're saying all of this
could actually be communicated in this way.
Compare unit fractions using different visual models,
including linear models like number lines,
tape measures, and area models, such as shape diagrams,
and encourage student justification with visual models.
We think this is much more meaningful for teachers,
and we see it really as a big step forward
for teachers and students in making maths more meaningful,
not only during this distance learning time,
but going forward into the future.
So just one note about high school before I leave you.
If we look at the next slide,
the high school standards
have a lot of prescribed methods in them
that were really written in the days
before we had good technology.
And this has led to students spending many hours
in algebra, for example,
factoring expressions that nobody will do by hand
when they enter the workplace.
And there's really broad agreement
from people in different sectors
that what's really powerful for high school students
is when they learn to take a problem, set up a model,
use a computer or a calculator
to perform the computational part,
and then make sense of the results.
And we now have wonderful free tools
that innovative teachers are using regularly,
such as Desmas or War from Alpha,
that enable this mathematical power.
So in high school,
we're also recommending the big ideas of the content,
but we're adding that students can do some of the methods
work with technology,
and that will be a better experience for them.
It will also free up time for students and teachers
to do that more important mathematical work.
So we're very carefully recommending technology
that's free.
Most teachers are actually using this technology already.
So one final thought,
it seems that the approach of the two teams,
maths and English are very similar
and compatible with each other.
And I'm now going to turn over to Dr. Halley Yopp,
who will address English language arts.
Thank you very much, Joe,
my colleague, Nancy,
and I are pleased to have this opportunity
to work on the distance learning guidance,
especially on the heels several years ago
of working on the ELA ELD framework.
So I'm sharing here the circles of implementation graphic
that captures the big picture of implementation
of ELA and ELD instruction
as described in that framework.
And in a nutshell, in the outer ring,
you see the overarching goals of ELA ELD instruction.
And those are by the time
California students complete high school,
they have developed the readiness
for college careers and civic life,
attained the capacities of literate individuals,
acquired the skills for living and learning
in the 21st century.
And those include technological competence
as well as global competencies.
And they have become broadly literate.
In the center of this graphic are grade level standards,
the year by year pathway
toward achieving those overarching goals.
And embedded within the ELA slash literacy standards
are the California ELD standards,
which were designed to amplify
areas of English language development
that are crucial for academic learning.
Circling the standards
are the cross-cutting themes of the standards.
These themes highlight the interconnections
among reading, writing, listening, speaking and language.
They represent the bigger ideas,
the cross-cutting themes of the standards.
They're meaning making,
because the course meaning is central
to reading, writing, speaking, listening and language.
They're language development,
because reading, writing, listening and speaking
are all language processes.
They are also effective expression,
which I could define at length here,
but I'm not going to.
Content knowledge and foundational skills.
These are the five overarching key cross-cutting themes
of ELA and ELD instruction as conceived in the framework
and duplicated here in this project.
The white field in the graphic
represents the context in which instruction occurs.
We call for instruction that is integrated,
motivating and engaging, respectful
and intellectually challenging
for all students at all grade levels.
The graphic, particularly those cross-cutting themes
provides the framework and organizing structure
for our discussion of the ELA slash literacy standards.
They are the big ideas in the ELA, ELD framework
and they are now the big ideas here
in this distance learning guide.
Next slide, please.
And here we see how this section of the guide is organized.
There are those five themes.
There will be a chart for each of those five themes
across the grade levels.
You see the heading and then below that
are critical standards.
These are clusters of standards
or in a few cases, individual standards
that address very closely that theme.
Each theme heading then is followed by several cells
or rows containing critical standards.
Next slide, please.
Within those cells, you will find
that closely related standards are placed in the same cell.
You'll find that there are supporting ELD standards
that are identified and that we include bullets
and shortly you'll see an example.
Bulleted comments that clarify, contextualize
or emphasize some aspect of the standard
or clusters of standards and provide instructional guidance
or that tie in closely with issues of SEL
or issues of equity.
And finally, the ELA standards that are repeated
across themes appear in the same color.
That repetition draws attention to the interrelationship
among these ideas.
Next slide, please.
Here we have an example from kindergarten.
This is the chart that displays critical standards
for teaching the language arts as meaning making processes,
one of those five key themes.
Now due to space constraints,
we don't have the actual boxes and borders around these,
but I'd like you to think about this.
The slide has actually two cells of four
that are in our current draft,
meaning that two of the four clusters of critical standards.
Border lines, as I said,
have been omitted here due to space constraints,
but you might imagine this as a table with rows
that we are calling cells.
In the first, you see a green critical standard.
The fact that it is green tells us that this same standard
appears in another theme chart for this grade level.
More on that shortly.
Here the standard is paired with a supporting ELD standard.
The standards are followed by, in this case, two bullets
that highlight important instructional considerations,
that is guidance for teachers
as they are thinking about implementation of this standard.
The purple text, remember this color,
is the start of a second cell.
This purple critical standard is actually three standards
that have been clustered or merged,
writing standards one, two, and three.
The ELD standard is provided,
and the bullets highlight the fact
that children use writing to communicate,
they work to express opinions, information, stories,
use the written language.
We teach writing as a meaning-making process.
It is not simply printing letters or copying a sentence.
So with just these two cells in the meaning-making chart,
we see that reading and writing are both thought of,
taught as, and emphasized as meaning-making processes
here in kindergarten and throughout the grade levels.
Next slide, please.
This is a different chart within kindergarten.
This attaches to the theme of foundational skills,
as teachers work to build students' abilities
in the foundational skills.
On this slide, we see two of the critical standards
in the foundational skills theme.
The first is in the color brown,
which signals to us that this same standard
appears in another one of those five themes
for this grade level.
The next standard is in purple.
You may recall that the previous slide
had a purple standard.
It was the same standard,
the cluster of writing standards one through three.
At a glance, teachers can see that the purple standard
is important for supporting understanding
that writing is a meaning-making process.
Yes, we use it to communicate, as we saw in the last slide,
and it's crucial for developing foundational skills,
which we see here in the foundational skills theme chart.
Children are using writing to express ideas,
yes, to share meaning,
and they also are using their emerging understanding
of the alphabetic principle of foundational skill
as they work to translate their ideas
into written language.
The final document includes these charts
of the five themes or big ideas,
clusters of standards at each grade level.
Thank you, and back to Nancy.
Sorry, Nancy, you're muted.
Okay, I'm on.
As you heard from both Dr. Bowler and Dr. Yopp,
the team, they have identified the organization
and standards that are used in the grade level
and the education and structure of how to identify
these critical standards organized around these themes
and these big ideas.
What I wanted to convey in this slide is that
in these sections, we will also be working
with the ISTE team and with Q
to infuse social-emotional learning components
and considerations.
These are the sections that will also include vignettes
and other examples, illustrative examples
from California educators,
which will also include videos.
And these are the sections that will include resources,
digital access to high-quality instructional materials.
Next slide.
So the conclusion of this document will focus
on addressing a vision for the future
of teaching and learning in the state of California
and will provide recommendations for leaders
to move forward with this vision.
What I do want to emphasize as we close
is to reiterate what was shared by Shinning Codes,
which is this is a document that we believe will live
and is being designed to live
beyond the life of this pandemic.
It will be a salient and relevant resource,
whether we are in a distance learning environment,
in a hybrid environment, or back in the classroom
where this will be a resource to support teachers
on the effective use of technology in the classroom.
So again, we appreciate this opportunity as a team
to provide an update to the state board
about where we are in the development of this resource.
And I, at this time, I will turn it back over
to President Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond.
Thank you so much.
I want to open the phone line now for public comment.
And there we go.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so by calling the number on the screen
and entering the access code noted there.
While we're waiting for the members of the public
to call in, I will ask board members
if they want to ask any clarifying questions
of the presenters who've just presented.
And I will try to be able to watch for your hands.
If you, I see that member Navo has a hand up.
Thank you.
That was very informative and so exciting
to see the experts in the field
that are contributing to this work.
Nancy, I really appreciate the presentation
and the heavy lift that's being done through SCOE.
One of the questions I do have is you had mentioned
that there were sections
that addressed vulnerable student groups.
And oftentimes we may hear that
and maybe that section is just a paragraph
and they call it a section.
Can you elaborate a little bit more
on what that might look like for ELs,
students with disabilities, vulnerable groups?
Yes, so thank you for the question.
We are working with not only our county office partners,
but other CDE departments to ensure
that we are developing a comprehensive,
that we are addressing these areas comprehensively.
So not only are we specifically including a section
on strategies to address students with special needs,
we are working with our Californians together.
We are planning to also work with CABE.
They're leading other efforts statewide
to address the needs of English learners
that include the support for English learners
in a distance learning environment.
We had just yesterday a call with CDE
to discuss the need to address the importance
of the outreach and the engagement of our foster youth,
our students experiencing homelessness.
So these are very important conversations
that we are engaging in with not only our writing team,
but with our CDE and SBE partners.
Thank you, Nancy, I appreciate that.
Member Rucker.
Thank you.
First of all, along with Board Member Novel,
and I'm sure my other colleagues on the Board,
I was really gladdened and very excited
to see the work that's being done
and the team that has come together
to put this document and this guidance out.
I remain concerned, especially given the comments
by our Board President, Dr. Darling-Hammond,
about the need to pay attention
to educating the whole child.
There's also a need to make sure that we're focused on
and looking at how to deliver the whole curriculum.
So I think this guidance is a good start.
To do the work on developing and implementing guidance
and instruction for reading language arts and mathematics
is very important, but I fear without continuing the work
to also provide guidance on appropriate good instruction
in science and the other subject areas,
that it will lead to a continuing emphasis
that we're already seeing on the subjects that are tested
or focused on for accountability purposes
to the detriment of the student experience
in those other subject areas.
So I hope that as this guidance goes forward
and the work continues to develop
on providing this very excellent tool,
that there's some consideration on what it means,
not just to provide instructional support
for the whole child in reading language arts
and mathematics, but what it means
to provide instructional support
for the whole curriculum as well.
Does anyone want to respond to that from the group?
I can share that, again, during our call with SBE and CDE
just yesterday or Monday in our planning call,
we did have discussions about the importance
of integration across all content areas,
the exact approach and how we will include this,
our items that we are in discussion,
but certainly this has been raised
by our writing team as well.
So we will continue to refine our efforts
and we are very mindful of the importance
of the integration of all content areas.
So we have a very highly, a team of experts
and I'm very confident
that we'll be able to pull this together.
Thank you very much.
I am mindful that we're getting into a bit of discussion
and we still have people queued up
from the public comment queues.
So I'm gonna ask member Patil Brownson
if we can come back to you
after we've heard from the public comment, is that okay?
Okay, so let's see if there we have any public comment.
It looks like we have three people signed up
for public comment.
I will open the phone lines now.
Okay.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Jessica Saco, representing Children Now.
I'd like to congratulate Drs. Linda Darling-Hammond
and I mean Strauss on their reelection
as president and vice president respectively.
We look forward to continuing our work
with you in the coming year.
The resources under development
that were presented with this item
are welcome and necessary.
While many of us have an eye towards
a return to in-person instruction by September 2021
when this resource will be available,
we see the potential of the resource for use
in case of future emergencies
and with the sharing of lessons learned
during the development and implementation process
to inform the re-envisioning
of teaching and learning in California.
We share member Rucker's call that science, STEM,
history, social science, the arts and other subjects
which have been shown time and time again
as the essential and core components
of the 21st century whole child approach to education
also need to be supported.
These subjects increase student engagement and enthusiasm
and deepen understanding and mastery of all subjects
including math, language arts and language development.
Thank you.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Caller, are you there?
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Hello, it's Eric Premack
with the Charter Schools Development Center.
We're very pleased to see that the state
is starting to think more seriously about these issues
and we commend Dr. Darling-Hammond for leading on this
and for the conversation.
And for leading on this and for the comments she made
during the governor's budget announcement.
We are though a little disheartened to see
that there's a very narrow focus here.
And we think that the primary focus
before you get into the curriculum and instructional issues
is you really need to look at the kind of stultifying mass
of red tape and the education code that is for decades
been a major barrier to innovation
and instructional methods and makes it very difficult
for the many schools and many of my member schools
that have been trying to innovate
in these areas for decades.
Many have been able to do so with relative success
but are definitely have their hands tied behind their backs.
We would urge you to expand the group that's here
and the focus to primarily or at least initially focus
on the many difficult statutory and regulatory barriers
to innovation in addition to the important instructional ones
that the speakers brought up.
Thank you.
Good morning, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Good morning.
This is Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
I'm speaking for the LCFF Equity Coalition as well.
While we think this is still necessary and important,
our families and communities
will have already experienced distance learning as it is
in all its various forms statewide.
This seems late in coming for this particular pandemic
but we know and it sounds like
you're going to consider its utility
to study the challenges and lessons learned
as a foundation for future emergencies.
The board should require
that there be a frank discussion
of where the distance learning struggle really was
and continues to be.
Appreciate that there is a focus on math
and English language arts
since we see the initial evidence that those big areas
for focus, old child should also be considered.
Thank you.
Good morning, caller.
Would you state your name and affiliation for the record?
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Good morning, caller.
Oh, it looks like we lost her.
That concludes public comment for item number two.
Thank you very much.
So getting back to the queue,
I have member Patio Bronson, member Glover Woods
and member Strauss.
So Kim, why don't you get us going?
Great.
Thank you.
So I offer gratitude for the approach
that our panelists offered in terms of thinking
about the pandemic that we're facing right now
but also with an eye towards the future
and also reflect that even with the September release date
there is ongoing possibility
of a staggered learning structure in the fall
that is not likely to go back to business as usual
with full loading standards,
especially given that the vaccination schedule
for young children especially is going to be delayed
given that there hasn't actually been vaccine trials
for children under 12.
So the continued salience of this conversation
I think will be quite acute still in the fall.
The question that I had for our panel, however,
has to do with young children
and their ability to engage in online learning.
I think by the governor's budget proposal
that was released last Friday,
the emphasis on TK to two and the unique challenges
that young children have with both navigating
the electronic tools and also just taking up the content
that is otherwise just a lot of physical activity
in a physical classroom is something
that is not gonna go away as a challenge.
And wanted to know first,
how has stakeholder input been influenced
in terms of are you pulling focus groups?
How are you outreaching to interact with this segment
of teachers who teach TK to two
as well as parents and families
who can bring this challenge to life?
And then also how it all will recommendations be carved out
to address the unique challenges of the younger age group.
I can address the question.
So formally, I'm currently the deputy superintendent
here at SCOE, but I was also the early learning director
and led a number of statewide efforts
focused on early learning.
So here at SCOE, we have a very extensive team
that works very closely
with the California Department of Education to develop.
In fact, we wrote the transitional kindergarten
implementation guide.
So we are taking the expertise of our team,
but recognizing that in this distance learning environment,
this is a very different environment that we've never faced.
So we are looking closely at NAEYC recommendations
that have been released.
Head Start has developed resources
and we are working closely
with the California Department of Education's
early learning division to ensure the coordination again
of these resources and the guidance
that is being developed by CDE
so that we are integrating all of these resources
at the national and state level.
In terms of the outreach, you ask a very good question.
We do have some representation
among our early learning colleagues,
but we know and we have heard
through these stakeholder input sessions
that there does need to be additional input.
So I appreciate your comments
and we will certainly in our next series
of stakeholder input sessions
where we begin to share draft documents,
we will ensure that we include very specifically
those representatives from early learning.
I do wanna, before we move on to others
with their hands raised,
we have member Glover Woods and member Strauss.
I'm looking to see if there's anyone else.
I just wanna put a little more context on this.
This project was defined by the legislature
and a set of requirements that were passed
in the end of the summer, early fall.
And so while there is a lot that might be done beyond this,
the particular parameters of the project were defined
in that piece of legislation.
Meanwhile, as you know,
the governor has proposed supports as it is safe
for getting the youngest children back in classrooms
as soon as is healthfully and safely possible
while we're also engaged in this other project,
which we hope will have to do with as much
with how technologies may be used in supportive ways
when we get back to brick and mortar classrooms
as well as how they may be used in supporting.
So just to kind of give a framework for the fact that,
you know, none of these things are in lieu of the other.
They are all kind of happening simultaneously.
And I think this resource of identifying
the critical standards in a way
that makes them more powerful for teaching
because they are integrated and teachers can say,
here's the big idea I'm working on
rather than trying to find all the little pieces
sprinkled about the standards
will be a very big support at all grade levels.
Even after everything, everyone is back in classrooms.
Next on the queue I think is a member Glover Woods.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond
and I will probably echo a couple of the comments
that you have just previously made.
First and foremost, I would like to say thank you so much
to Sacramento County Office of Education
and all the partners that are working with them
to develop this very important guide.
And while we do anticipate at some point in time
that students will be returning for in-person instruction,
I think it is important for us in that lens
of reimagining and re-envisioning
what education will look like post the pandemic
to see how this type of resource
can really be a companion to in-person instruction
and support student learning
outside of the brick and mortar classroom.
Just as I would say a re-emphasis on some areas to look at
and Dr. Herroda has addressed some of these
along with the comments from my fellow board members,
ensuring that embedded and interwoven throughout the guide
is guidance related to the cultural relevancy
of pedagogy, strategies and or resources
that would be very important as well as that integration
across many curriculum areas
that we know are so important for student learning.
One additional piece I would add just for consideration
is how might we embed support that allow for teachers
to look at how to utilize the home environment
and family and community in relation to the big ideas
that are captured in this guide.
Just the very nature of distance learning
lets us know that students would be engaging
in learning away from the classroom
and families and community members
are such a huge support in that particular environment.
So if there is a way to integrate
what that might look like into the guide,
I think it could be very beneficial for students.
Thank you.
Perfect, thank you.
Member Strauss and then member Fattah.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
So first let me thank Chloe and the entire team
for the coordinated work.
It's wonderful to see some of our writers
that help guide our framework development
connected to this entire project
and the overall perspective on looking at an entire project
that will guide the field,
I think as we look to re-imagining
and really resetting our whole approach.
There's a lot of documents out there
and I know all of our school leaders and teachers
are working so hard with so many resources.
So I see this particularly valuable
as a coordinated document that puts it all together
and just to support member Rucker's comment
about integrating all the different curricular areas
I think is so important.
So we've learned a lot along the way of developing
that you can be teaching literacy through science.
We know that a lot of our, there are a lot of areas,
but I just think people are doing the very best they can
and this creates a really wonderful opportunity,
particularly as the Deputy Superintendent said,
they're looking at vignettes and videos
and I think we found through the frameworks
that those vignettes are actually quite helpful
in illustrating actually how some of these documents
come to life in a classroom.
And what I think about as we move forward on this
is that this is likely to be ready this fall
and that we ought to be really connecting
with say teacher education as we prepare future educators
to have a guidance document to make sense
of all the resources out there.
This is sort of an overarching document
and then obviously through our county offices
and our curriculum divisions helping to look,
because we know from the time that we developed frameworks
and guidance documents,
it's years till it's fully implemented
and people often depend on what they have
because they're driving the train
as they're looking at new materials.
So I think we ought to think thoughtfully
about implementation with the professional development money
in the governor's budget,
how we might look to training and support for teachers
to learn some of these materials,
but overall just a tremendous amount of support
to Superintendent Gordon and the entire team
for a coordinated visionary document
that has the pieces connected
and to all the wonderful writers
that are willing to stay with the process
and connect the work I can think with,
all the ELA, ELD work that we did
and I'm still talking to districts
who don't quite remember some of the things
that are in that document.
And so I see a potential down the line
of using this as a training document
for a pre-service and teachers in service
in different stages of their career.
This would be a wonderful overall guidance document.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I think that says it well.
Member Fatah and then member Rodriguez.
Thank you, President Darling-Cammond
and I just like to share the gratitude
that my colleagues have all shared on the board
regarding the amazing work that you guys have been doing
in tandem with following SB 98.
And I really, I liked a component that you touched on.
You mentioned how there have been so far
18 counties of education have responded,
13 districts, five advocacy groups
and how you guys were kind of moving
in a direction of looking at empathy interviews
with the students.
And I really think that it's incredibly important
for us to be listening to students.
I think that the student voice is incredibly important
amidst this pandemic and informing
the curriculum development.
And so I'd encourage you to really listen
to the student voices when it comes to these issues
and when it comes to the perspective that they have
regarding the curriculum development
and to try as best as possible
to not tokenize their voices.
Terrific, thank you.
Member Rodriguez.
Thank you.
And I just wanna echo everything that's already been said
from integrating and not leaving out important subjects
is the arts.
I like the way the ELD themes were incorporated in this.
And I think that that would be a very natural application
to go into the integration, to use those themes.
And also what Member Fatah just said,
I would really like to get students' perspective
and teachers' perspective on how this would land with us.
And finally, I wanna make sure that we don't sacrifice
depth for shiny technology,
because I think that sometimes we can get so caught up
in the apps and in this and in that,
that going deep into especially things like civics
and things that we really need to develop
deep understanding and deeper learning for our students
that it doesn't get lost in the technology.
So I just really want to point that out.
And thank you so much for your excellent thought
and the incredible team that was brought together
to start this work.
And I think that says it well.
Member Patia Brunson, your hand is still up,
but I'm assuming that that was maybe leftover from before.
Okay, so that concludes our discussion.
And I wanna add my thanks.
This is really an all-star team
that has been working on this
with a very coherent big vision.
Thanks to Dave Gordon and Nancy Giroda
at the county office for just amazing work on this.
And then all of the members of the writing team,
Joe Bowler and Hallie Yopp are bringing that coherence
from the frameworks that they have worked on,
which is really going to help this become
a very useful tool for us.
And I just want to thank all of the members of the team
and all of the other members of the team.
Really very, very grateful for this work.
And with that, we will conclude this information item.
Thank you, Shanine and everyone else who presented.
And given that we have a long assessment item coming up,
I think we should take our 10-minute break now.
So you'll be ready to engage fully in the next discussion.
We should be back by 10-18.
I think we need to mute ourselves.
I think you, let's see,
you have to turn off your microphone and your camera,
and then we'll turn the cameras back on when we come back.
See you at 10-18.
All right, so I'm gonna ask Brooks to call the roll
to reestablish a quorum.
Member Sun.
Vice President Strauss.
Here.
Member Rucker.
Member Rodriguez.
Here.
Member Patil Brownson.
Member Navo.
Here.
Member McQuillin.
Member Glover Woods.
Here.
Member Fatah.
President Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Member Burr.
Great.
We have a quorum.
I'm gonna start then on agenda item three,
which is the California assessment
of student performance and progress system
and the English language proficiency assessments
for California.
We're going to be listening to the request for approval
of proposed goals and priorities
to be included in the California assessment system
request for qualifications, stage three,
which is the formal written submission
and an update of program activities.
And the item will be presented by Mal Vang of the CDE.
Mal, please begin.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond
and board members.
As mentioned, I'm Mal Vang.
I'm the director for the assessment development
and administration division
at the California Department of Education.
The item before you today is an action item
and an information item.
Alex, it's not scrolling.
Okay.
Excuse me.
Thank you.
The presentation will include the following topics.
We will begin with an introduction by Rachel Maves,
who is our deputy superintendent
of the instruction and measurement branch
and an overview of the program.
And then we'll move on to the next item,
which is the final item,
the instruction and measurement branch
and an overview of the California Department of Education's
recommendation for approval.
We'll visit the LPAC Fall Administration Reflections
and then go over the 2020-2021 timelines,
test administration options and considerations.
And then we'll end with the CASP update
or the California assessment
for Student Performance and Progress updates.
And I will stop talking here
and introduce Rachel to begin.
Thank you, Dr. Vang.
Hello everyone, I'm President Darlene Hammond,
Vice President Strauss and State Board members.
As we come before you with this item on assessments,
I would like to once again situate our discussion
in the current context.
At our last meeting, as we requested approval
for a reduced blueprint to the ELA and math assessments,
I noted there were many unknowns.
We were uncertain what COVID cases would look like
as the testing window opened.
We were uncertain how many districts
would be able to move forward with bringing students back
to in-person instruction this month,
and how many would remain in distance learning.
And while all those answers are clear now,
yesterday the Sacramento region moved into the purple tier,
allowing once again a slow reopen.
Each day, each week brings a new set of circumstances
that require adjustment and flexibility,
and it is admittedly exhausting.
There is nothing about our current situation that is easy.
Transitioning 6.2 million students to distance learning
in a matter of months has not been easy.
Moving instruction to a virtual setting
while simultaneously building staff capacity
around new instructional strategies
in what for many has been a foreign technological world
has not been easy.
Trying to engage students through a computer screen
instead of in your classroom
where you can get down on their level,
look them in the eye and express your care and concern
has not been easy.
Planning for in-person instruction, then hybrid,
then distance learning, then hybrid again,
has not been easy.
And juggling the pressure of full-time jobs
with kids at home has not been easy.
None of this is easy.
And yet we continue one foot in front of the other
because at the heart of all of this chaos are our children.
Over the last few months,
CDE has explored various options
to try to ease some of the burden felt by districts
while still meeting federal and state requirements,
which as I continue to learn, again, is not easy.
At the November board meeting,
we proposed an adjusted blueprint
that would shorten the ELA and math test.
Over the course of the last few months,
we have worked tirelessly with stakeholders, contractors,
and various LEA staff across the state
to provide multiple options for test administration
that address the safety of our staff and students.
Today and a later item,
we will take the first step
to decouple accountability from assessments
by participating in a streamlined waiver offered by ED,
which pushes the identification of CSI schools
out in additional years.
And clearly, we still have more work to do.
As federal and state requirements allow,
we are committed to finding solutions
that provide relief and support
to our partners in this field.
It is my hope that as we continue to navigate a year
that relentlessly tests our strength and fortitude,
we model collaboration, partnership, innovation, and unity.
And with that, I will turn this item back over to Dr. Boehme.
Thank you, Rachel.
Thank you.
So today, the California Department of Education
is seeking approval on the proposed goals and priorities
to be included in the written submission
from potential contractors for our next assessment contract.
I will go over the proposed goals and priorities
and background on our procurement process.
And we are in stage three.
So this first topic here, again,
will cover the proposed goals and priorities.
Just to give some background,
this slide provides or displays all the assessments
in our California assessment system,
which includes both the California Assessment
of Student Performance and Progress, or CAST,
and the English Language Proficiency Assessments
for California, or LPAC.
Under the requirements of the Every Student Succeeds Act,
or ESSA, enacted on December 10th, 2015,
which reauthorized the Elementary
and Secondary Education Act of 1965,
all states accepting title funds for use
by local educational agencies
must assess all eligible students on these assessments.
So on one side, we have the CAST,
which consists of our English Language Arts,
Mathematics, and Science tests.
Our alternate assessments for English Language Arts,
Mathematics, and Science, and the primary language,
which is assessment, which we have
the California Spanish Assessment, or CSA.
On the other side, we have the LPAC,
which consists of the initial LPAC, the summative LPAC,
and both the initial and summative alternate LPAC.
So the CAST and LPAC contracts
were competitively procured separately in 2015.
And at that time, the CAST contract
encompassed the technology infrastructure.
Then in 2018, the LPAC was integrated
into the CAST contract, which included
the development and administration
of both the CAST and the LPAC
through the 2021-2022 school year.
So the current contract will expand
at the end of the school year.
So the current contract will expire
at the end of December 2022.
The next contract is projected to begin on July 1, 2022.
The California Department of Education has implemented,
or is in the process of implementing
a four-stage request for qualification procurement process.
And the goals of this process is to,
one of the goals is to identify an assessment contractor
with the capacity and expertise
to successfully implement the California assessment system.
And the process is competitive and open,
utilizing standardized scoring criteria
in an effort to determine whether potential contractors
are qualified to provide the critical components
of our assessment programs.
So the four stages include qualifications,
the mandatory demonstrations,
the formal written submission, and negotiations.
So the two contractors or potential contractors
that passed stage one in June 2020
and stage two in November 2020
are Educational Testing Service, or ETS,
and National Computer Systems, or NCS Pearson, Incorporated.
The goals, the proposed goals and priorities
to be included in stage three are
enhance the development and administration
of high quality assessments
of the California assessment system
through the 2020-2027 school years.
Examples of assessments to include
are all the summative, interim, and formative assessments.
And continue to improve the assessment system
to ensure efficient, effective, and accurate results
with enhancements to support multiple administration modes,
explore and advance technology solutions
that meet system capacity, performance, and usability
to the greatest extent possible.
I will recap the recommendation
and proposed goals and priorities
toward the end of this presentation
while I cover program updates.
California, in the fall,
well, for preparation for this school year,
California has been working to prepare
for all the administration of assessments.
But given the uncertainty of local conditions
as a result of the pandemic,
we know that administering assessments
has been challenging as we reflect
on the fall administrations of the ALPAC.
So the 2020-21 State Wives Testing Plan
was to begin with the initial ALPAC on July 1
with a paper pencil version
and transition to the computer-based version
starting on August 20,
at which time the paper-based version would be discontinued.
The initial ALPAC is used to determine, just to recap,
it is used to determine
the English language proficiency of students
whose home language survey indicates a language
other than English
and entering California public schools for the first time
so that we can get the students the help
in learning English
and support that they may need in school.
However, due to the impact and challenges of the pandemic,
we continue to provide both options of paper pencil
and computer-based for the duration of this year.
So as you know,
all summative testing was suspended last spring
and based on guidance from the federal government
to states in early May 2020,
it allowed states to extend their
spring English language proficiency assessments
through the fall
and our legislature approved trailer bill language
section 103 of Senate Bill 98,
which did extend the 2019-2020 summative ALPAC testing window
from August 20 through October 30, 2020.
In addition, LEAs were greatly concerned about the,
or local educational agencies for LEAs,
were greatly concerned about the inability
to administer the summative ALPAC,
which provides results to determine those students
who met English language proficiency requirement
of the reclassification criteria.
So in this case,
students who would have potentially reclassified
would have to wait another year
to take the summative ALPAC in spring 2021.
So although the window was extended by the legislation,
LEAs were unable to open doors for in-person instruction
due to the COVID restrictions,
and therefore the CDE identifies
several test administration options,
including in-person and remote for both initial
and the optional summative ALPAC fall administrations,
since most were completed in the fall.
So through our efforts in the fall,
some lessons were learned, and I will cover that.
Lessons learned from test administration,
from the test administration options
is that providing flexibility and options
in a timely manner is essential.
The CDE and our contractor, ETS,
has worked quickly to determine feasible
test administration options
and develop physically distancing guidelines
for local educational agencies to use.
These test administration options, as I mentioned,
are in-person co-located with the suggested guidelines
for physically distancing test administrations.
The second option was
remote computer-based test administration,
which provided the test examiner and students
secure access to the test session
through their own digital devices.
The third option was remote paper pencil,
which required the local educational agency
to securely mail the paper pencil test
to the student's home with clear directions
that it should be open, should not be open
until the student is connected
with the test examiner by video.
Another set of lessons learned came from the guidance
and resources that were developed.
Along with these, the guidelines,
many more resources were developed
to provide LEAs additional guidance.
And this included detailed instructions
for how to administer the LPAC
in each of the three test administration options.
There was a parent acknowledgement form for remote testing
which outlined what parents can do
to support remote testing at home
and what they cannot do to ensure the security
and validity of the assessment.
However, the requirement of a signature
or approval through an electronic means like a survey
was difficult to secure for the acknowledgement
from parents and guardians,
and it really did delay testing in some cases.
So there are guides for test examiners,
videos for administering the domains,
and detailed technology requirements
for a successful administration.
And all of these materials are posted on the LPAC website
which is the LPAC.org.
Additional lessons learned revolved
around training and support.
Virtual training for local educational agencies
such as LPAC coordinators or their designated trainer
was provided through the Moodle training site.
And regional county offices also supported
local educational agencies in various ways.
In addition, the Educational Testing Service
hosted virtual question and answer sessions
that provided participants an opportunity to ask questions
and receive answers live as well as a technology webcast
that provided information about a variety of topics
associated with the remote testing sessions and options.
So in our preliminary analysis in December,
it indicated that the summative LPAC
or the optional summative LPAC that we administer
in the fall was administered to 40,767 students.
There are still some paper tests being received
by our contractor and that number may change in the future,
but I think that we're wrapping that one up.
So this administration,
along with the test administration options
that were also made available
to local educational agencies on August 20
for the initial LPAC resulted
in the California Department of Education
and the Contractor Educational Testing Service
gathering information on improvements
that could be made to the test administration guidelines
in preparation for all the summative testing in spring 2021.
Another lesson learned was regarding
the test administration itself or preparation for it.
Test examiners were reluctant to sign
the test security affidavit for remote administration
due to fear of being held accountable
for anything that happens in the students' homes.
So we need to implement some changes there.
And for students, one of the things
is during test administration for group session,
four students per remote group test session
was not sufficient and the test delivery system
should be configured to increase
the number per session for spring.
And also coordinating the delivery
of secure K-2 student writing answer books
for remote administration was difficult
and not cost effective,
so we need to provide additional options
to be more efficient and supportive of the field.
As a result of that,
there was an improvement made for LPAC specifically,
and that is we can make revisions
to the directions for test examiners
to transcribe the K-2 student writing responses
during remote administration
to support the coordination of materials
and reduce LEA costs.
Another improvement for,
or other improvements that will benefit
both LPAC and CAS
are to provide guidance on the test security affidavit
and updated directions for test examiners
in our test administration manuals.
Regarding lessons learned for training,
we've streamlined the content of our online training modules
to provide comprehensive and efficient
remote test administration training resources for educators
in the distance learning context based on feedback
that we've collected from educators.
Training videos have been created
to enhance online training content,
and educators are now able to practice
remote test administration
by administering the practice tests
using the new secure browser remotely.
Although there are no limit to the number of students
who can be part of a remote testing session,
the CDE and ETS is recommending testing
a maximum of 20 students per session
to ensure test security,
and this would enable our test examiners
and test administrators to manage the remote session,
monitor students,
and address any questions that might arise.
Now, some of the key lessons learned
did also help us learn that the parents
have many questions and concerns
regarding remote administration option.
So to assist and support parents,
a website has been created to help parents
and guardians stay informed about remote testing.
The website includes video tutorials and other resources
to help parents understand the remote testing procedures
and to highlight the importance of spring administrations.
Furthermore, the parent consent acknowledgement form
has been replaced with a parent remote testing
informational letter to streamline the process
of notifying parents or guardians for remote testing
where a signature is not required
by providing a contact for parents and guardians
to reach out to if their child cannot participate
through remote administration
since many did encounter some challenges
with that process during the fall administration,
which can cause delays in testing.
So we are planning some additional support for spring
by offering a series of office hours
in later in January and February,
and the coffee sessions to provide ongoing support
and allow for local educational agency staff
to ask questions and answers.
So in terms of preparing for the spring administrations,
next I will go over the 2020, 2021 testing timelines,
test administration options and considerations for spring.
So this slide provides the initial
and summative assessments timelines.
The statewide testing windows are how we typically,
typically launch our assessment programs.
One change this year is the CASP,
a Smarter Balanced summative assessments
for English language arts and mathematics
in order to change to the adjusted blueprints
approved by the State Board of Education
during the November meeting.
These assessments will not launch until February 22nd.
As provided in this table, our assessment operates,
our assessment system really operates year round
with minimal down times.
Local educational agencies do select
their own testing window within the available test,
statewide testing window based on their instructional year
or what has been determined.
So all California, also although we understand
that although California has been preparing, adjusting
and learning how to administer assessments
during this pandemic, we know that there are
varying circumstances around the state
and for some it will be very difficult
to administer assessments if it is not safe
to do so in person.
So since September, the U.S. Department of Education
has indicated that it will not approve
statewide assessment waivers for the 2021 school year.
So the CDE has been working to provide
test administration options that allow
local educational agencies flexibility
to meet the testing requirements according
to the needs of their local contacts.
So for the Smarter Balanced summative assessments
for English Language Arts, Literacy and Mathematics,
the California Science Test,
the California Spanish Assessment
and the summative ALPAC,
the California Department of Education recommends
the following test administration options for spring.
Any person adhering to state, county
and local health and safety requirements
and remote using monitoring tools, cameras, speakers
or chats during the test session.
Of course, for the students with the most significant
cognitive disabilities identify as eligible
to participate in the California alternate assessments
which includes the California alternate assessments
for English Language Arts, Maths, Science
or the alternate ALPAC operational field tests.
Additional considerations are made or are being made
since the California alternates are administered one-on-one
by test examiners who are familiar with the student,
including their preferred communication mode,
their need for specialized accessibility resources
such as manipulatives and assistive technology supports
related to identify medical and health issues.
So after a careful review of the necessary requirements
for the delivery of the California alternate assessments
for the English Language Arts, Mathematics and Science,
the California Department of Education
recommends in-person test administration,
a hearing to state, county and local health
and safety requirements,
including the California Department of Education
Industrial Relations Division of Occupational Safety
and Health COVID-19 Emergency Temporary Standards
and any local collectively bargain safety protocols.
Remote administration is not recommended.
The assistive technology supports are not conducive
to a remote testing environment
and require support from a test examiner.
And also parents or guardians should not be asked
to administer the assessment
as our testing regulations do not allow
for their participation.
As for continuing on with considerations
for alternate assessments.
In addition, given the concerns regarding the administration
of our alternate assessments,
the CDE is postponing the alternate
LPAC operational field tests
until the 2021-2022 school year.
Local educational agencies for this school year,
the 2020-2021 school year,
local educational agencies will continue
to administer their locally determined alternate assessments,
again, following state, county,
local health and safety requirements.
And the testing window there is from February 1st
through May 31st.
So in fall 2020,
the CDE recommended that local educational agencies
administer the LPAC assessments in person
were safe to do so,
and that they use remote administration
as a second option when necessary.
So with the recent resurgence of COVID-19,
it is possible that the primary mode of administration
may become remote.
So among the challenges that have surfaced
for stakeholders in this shift in context
are issues with bandwidth and internet access,
lack of local resources to install secure browsers
on devices used by students in remote environments.
And during the fall LPAC administrations,
we saw firsthand that challenges and difficulties,
as previously mentioned, were there.
And due to these challenges,
questions have come about regarding the use
of assessment data and the comparability of data
to past years.
So the challenges identified for summative assessments
are really not unique.
With all the unknowns this year,
we may not be able to fully implement summative assessments.
As I stated in the November meeting,
these multiple options can put us on the path
to be able to collect as much information as possible
during this very difficult year.
So the summative testing window opened yesterday
for some CASP assessments.
CDE will monitor the data.
From the summative assessments
throughout the statewide testing window.
And we do not know at this time what data would be available
and would be cautious with any data interpretation or usage.
And I want to remind us that the importance
of having a comprehensive data collection system
that includes assessments,
along with multiple measures collected locally
can be used to inform decisions.
Now I will give you some quick updates
on the CASP assessments,
specifically the science tests,
along with others that have updates.
So first off, we will talk a little bit
about the 2021 CASP administration.
And the CDE will continue to use
the November 2017 SBE approved blueprint.
And as a reminder, the CASP is aligned
with the California Next Generation Science Standards
or California NGSS.
It is administered to all eligible students
in grades five, eight, and once in high school.
Some additional updates that we were,
along the way we have been providing you
some updates on the science resources.
During two workshops in April and June of 2020,
the CDE and the Sacramento County Office of Education
worked on collaboration with the California science teachers
and educational coaches from across the state
to develop the 38 science formative assessment resources
for elementary grades K through five.
And during these workshops,
the participants did collaborate
using a peer review process to create resources
that included instructional differentiation
by incorporating formative assessments
and accessibility strategies.
And there are 16 science resources
that are currently available in the Tools for Teachers
that California educators can access.
And we are making plans to continue its work
with the California science educators
during the school year to develop additional
science formative assessment resources
for inclusion in the Tools for Teachers.
So the CDE and Educational Testing Service
will continue the development and work
on the California Alternate Assessment for Science.
As part of these efforts in March, 2021,
the CDE will convene and our contractor will convene
a virtual range achievement level descriptor meeting
with California educators to review and provide feedback
on the California Alternate Assessment for Science
grade level range achievement level descriptors
in preparation for the August, 2021
California Alternate Assessment for Science
standard setting meeting.
So the range achievement level descriptors
describe what students know and can do in science
in each of the three achievement levels.
Level one is really, level one is limited understanding,
level two is foundational understanding,
and level three is understanding of the science standards.
So following the standard setting in August, 2021,
the CDE will seek the approval of the recommended
California Alternate Assessment for Science
threshold scores from the State Board of Education
in November.
So to assist parents and guardians in understanding
their child's California Alternate Assessment for Science,
there's some additions to our starting smarter site.
The CDE has made available the starting smarter webpage,
which can be found on our CASP starting smarter website.
And these family focus webpages provide resources
to empower parents to become involved in their children's
educational progress and parents and guardians
can visit the websites to review a sample
student score report, or SSR,
to review examples of test questions
and to obtain a downloadable guide with suggestions
on how to prepare for parent teacher conferences,
as well as access other helpful resources
to support their child's learning at home.
Another update is with the interim assessment
hand scoring workshops.
And these involve the Smarter Balanced
interim assessment items.
They continue to be available.
These workshops begin in December
and will be offered through April 2021
to local educational agency staff free of charge.
There are 20 sessions being offered
10 focusing on the hand scoring of English language
arts items and 10 focusing on mathematics.
To accommodate different teacher schedules
to format options are being offered
in this four hour workshop.
Half of the workshops are offered
in a single four hour session
and half of the workshops will be offered
over three shorter sessions of teachers
can attend after school hours.
Each workshop can accommodate up to 50 educators per session
with a total of 1000 educators for the series.
These workshops engage educators and activities
that promote understanding the process of hand scoring
the Smarter Balanced assessment items
for a deeper understanding of the content standards
and strengthening the evaluation of student work
and the quality of the content.
These workshops will be available
for strengthening the evaluation of student work
and promoting the use of student results
in informed teaching and learning.
So the LEA staff, if anybody would like to register
for these workshops, there is a link provided
in this month's board item.
In addition, I'd like to share with you
that in November 2020,
the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium
released a new web application
called the Smarter Annotated Response Tool.
And this new tool is designed
to help educators better understand the rubrics
that are used to score students written responses
to Smarter Balanced constructive response items
and performance tasks for English language arts.
Because all the items in this tool
are practice and sample items,
this web application is publicly available.
The Smarter Annotated Response Tool
makes hand scoring training more efficient
and have the examples of student writing,
scoring annotations and rubrics all in one place online.
And it helps educators understand what to look for
when reviewing student responses
and where to provide support to students
and provides a professional learning resource
that educators can use as they work to standardize
and calibrate their scoring of student writing samples.
So CDE staff, along with the staff
from the consortium member states
participated in a steering committee
to provide feedback and conduct system testing
during the development of this new web application.
We anticipate that future enhancements to this tool
will include the addition of sample student responses
for mathematics and the Smarter Annotated Response Tool
is available through the CDE and ATS CASP web pages
and is being advertised in our correspondences
to the local educational agencies and in trainings.
So that sums up the updates for our assessment programs.
I have the recommendation recap here.
Again, the California Department of Education
seeks approval on the proposed goals and priorities
to be included in the California assessment system
request for qualifications,
stage three written formal submission
for the next assessment contract.
And the proposed goals and priorities for stage three are here.
And I will stop talking.
And that takes me to the end of our presentation.
Thank you so much, Mal.
And thanks for all of the amazing work
that you and your team have done
in all of these different areas of the assessment process.
It's really quite extraordinary.
And we are in these extraordinary times.
I know there will be comments
that board members will want to make
about what we are looking at for assessment coming up.
We also will have public comment
and just to put a little framework on it,
the current status as Rachel laid out at the beginning
is that, of course, while we have all kinds of questions
about what will happen with schools
as COVID rates are soaring again,
and as districts are trying to figure out
how to calibrate their plans
to bring people back in person,
vaccinations are going out,
there's all kinds of variables
that could make a difference
in our ability to move forward this spring.
The current administration, just as a reminder,
had offered the possibility of some flexibilities
in tying assessments to decisions
about intervention and support status, CSI or TSI,
but not with respect to assessments themselves.
On January 20th, a new administration
will take over the reins in Washington,
which may or may not result in some changes
in the flexibilities that may be considered
in the assessment delivery context.
We have already taken action
to shorten the Smarter Balanced assessments
in reading and math so that they can be more easily given
if we're able to move ahead with that
in remote form, in person form.
And we've been developing progress
towards our growth model for assessment,
but we also have to be very cognizant
of the moment that we're in.
So what I'd like to do is restrict any questions right now
to MAL, to technical issues or clarifications
about what technical issues that we need to vote on,
go to public comment, and then come back to the board
and enable everyone to have an opportunity
to share your thoughts about the assessment questions
that will be ahead of us.
We cannot act on anything having to do with the waivers
at this moment that might be asked about down the road.
We need to wait for the new administration to arrive.
So we will have to hear from people, take stock,
and then perhaps even at some point,
shortly reconvene if there are any changes
to our current course of action.
So just wanted to give everyone a framework
for what we're working with here is a complicated moment
with a complicated item.
So with that said, are there any clarification questions
that you need to ask MAL
about the technical aspects of her presentation?
And I'm not seeing any emerging.
So if that is the case,
I want to be sure that we can get queued up
for public comment.
Members of the public,
do we have the slide up for public comment?
Can we put that up?
Alex, I think this is stuck.
I can't move the slide anymore.
Oh, okay.
I'll try some other.
The issues with technology,
which we all experience,
which are part of the challenge that we are discussing.
So I'm gonna note that members of the public
wishing to provide comment on this item may do so
by calling 712-432-0075.
Is it coming up?
There we go.
Call the number on the slide
and use the public access code that is there.
And then while we're waiting for members of the public
to call in, I'll ask member Sun
if she has some initial comments.
We'll hear from the public
and then we'll come back for more discussion.
Member Sun?
Yes, thank you.
Yeah, I had no clarifying questions,
but I did want to just say that,
I appreciate President Darling-Hammond's comments
that we are working with many, many variables
and I appreciate Deputy Superintendent Maves
and Director Mao for their work in this area
and trying to provide as much support
as possible for the field.
At the same time, as a school administrator,
my anxiety just rises when I start hearing
about administering these assessments
over this next few months.
So I just wanna make sure that the field understands
that we are not tone deaf.
We are working with many, many variables
and so we have to kind of work through this
based on what we have right now.
But I just wanted to assure that we are moving forward
with the best intent possible
and understanding what the field is going through
and the logistics of administering assessments
in these very unprecedented times.
Great, and with that, we'll turn to public comment.
Do we have any public commenters?
Yes, we do.
We have quite a few people in the queue for public comment
and this is for item number three.
I will open up the phone lines now.
Good morning, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Good morning, this is Andrea Ball
on behalf of the Central Valley Education Coalition.
Really appreciate the CDE's presentation
and Board Member Sun, your comments
and President Darling-Hammond.
We sent a letter outlining some very practical concerns
about going forward with the CAS
as well as challenges with the LPAC.
The Central Valley Education Coalition represents
school districts, county superintendents
in six Central Valley counties,
over 400,000 students, 128 local agencies.
Most of them have been closed.
They have very high rates, most of them, of COVID-19.
So I think the administration of the CAS and the LPAC
just present concerns about the administration
as Director Vang outlined.
There's very disparate concerns
about the Internet connectivity in the Central Valley.
Also, accommodations for students are very challenging
and really worried about the utility of the information.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute and your time starts now.
Good morning, State Board members.
My name is Lorraine Richards.
I'm a classroom teacher
representing the California Teachers Association.
CTA appreciates the CDE's efforts to update the field
regarding their activities and efforts on statewide testing
and greatly appreciates the hard work of Malvang
and her staff for engaging with CTA
and incorporating our feedback within this item.
The devastating impact of COVID-19
has been felt by the entire state of California
in this item.
The devastating impact of the pandemic
continues to ravage so many communities across our state,
especially our low income communities.
And there is no way to safely administer the assessments.
Our state's focus must be on supporting
our most vulnerable students
and not forcing assessments
that will be a logistical nightmare
and provide data that is not valid nor reliable.
Our educators continue to go above and beyond
in supporting our students
and almost 15,000 have signed a petition
to request a waiver.
We ask the state board to join the educators
that have signed our petition to request a waiver
from the U.S. Department of Education.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, this is Jessica Sacco on behalf of Children Now.
We support CDE's proposed direction on this item
regarding the goals and priorities
for future assessment contracts.
We also have a couple of suggestions
as the process moves forward.
We urge the board to consider in the coming years
how to prioritize and incorporate sufficient capacity
for the contractor to support the work
of developing the student growth model,
particularly capacity for analysis of the data,
development of tools and resources
to communicate about the growth model
and inform educators and the public
about this new accountability tool.
Also, we would like to applaud CDE
for their work to develop
science formative assessment tools for teachers,
including the focus on K-5 resources,
the integration of the three dimensions
of the next generation science standards,
and the integration of science with other subject areas.
Thank you.
Good morning, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
This is Sarah Lilas,
Executive Director for Teach Plus California.
We appreciate the update from Dr. Vang
around the spring administration.
I think I may have to watch that video a few times
to gather all of the updates,
but we're encouraged by many of the steps taken
around communication,
because our teachers believe communication to students
and families and educators is essential
to ensuring equitable testing.
On the issue of a scope of work
for the next assessment contract,
our teacher leaders want to recommend
that the state board provide more specific guidance
for the expectations under enhancing development
of high quality assessments, specifically around math.
As you heard the discussion of the new math framework
and the emphasis on big idea standards in math practice,
we don't see that reflected in the assessment,
and we hope in future iterations that it is.
We also concur with the recommendations
of the equity coalition that the board include
in its goals and priorities sufficient capacity
for the contractor to support the work
of developing the growth model,
including analysis of the data and communication tools.
Thank you.
Good morning, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
Edgar Salsueta on behalf of the Association
of California School Administrators.
We want to echo the appreciation to CDE and the state board
for some of the flexibility that's already been provided
through previous actions.
With that said, we do remain concerned about the validity
and the use of any data that we might obtain this year,
and we don't believe that any of that data should be used
for the purposes of accountability.
Not to mention the concern we have about the inequities
that students face right now with internet access
or testing environment and the hurdles
that our administrators are gonna face
in administering these tests.
So this has been echoed by many.
We asked the administration to consider taking this
to the federal government, the new administration,
and asking for a waiver of assistance this year.
Thank you for your consideration.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
This is Mary Perry from the California State PTA,
and we want to first echo the appreciation
for all the work that the department has done
to adapt the CAS testing system to the current situation
and provide the other assessment resources
to support teaching and learning.
We also want to support the plan
to conduct some kinds of assessments
despite the challenges involved.
The information gained from accountability
should not, from assessment,
should not be used for accountability,
but we have a lot of potential to provide leaders
both locally and in the state
with some understanding of the impact this year
has had on student learning
and what needs to be done to address that impact.
That's vital understanding for students,
families, and educators going forward.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz,
representing the California Association
for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
Now that the board is reviewing the scope of work
from potential contractors
for the next assessment contract,
we believe it is perfect timing
to enhance the California Spanish assessment
and make it a priority as well.
We recommend including constructed response writing items.
These items will demonstrate EL's writing proficiency
in their strongest language
while developing proficiency in English.
Develop the CSA so it parallels English language arts.
There are four proficiency levels for the ELA assessment
and only three for the CSA,
which diminishes the opportunities to show growth by EL's.
And lastly, enhance the number of test items
to parallel Californians language arts.
There are fewer items on the CSA,
therefore doesn't allow for comparison of proficiency
in English and Spanish
for students developing bi-literary skills.
We believe these recommendations
will strengthen the CSA
and serve as a model primary language assessment
for other states.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
This is Liz Guillen with Public Advocates,
also for the LCFS Equity Coalition.
We support the direction
that the department is going on these contracts.
We have two goals and priorities we'd like to recommend.
One is to expand the California Spanish assessment
so that it includes performance tasks
and provide support.
We know that performance tasks contribute
to our understanding of what students can do.
So we believe that the state's goals around bi-literacy
also deserve a similar focus on the depth of understanding
and performance tasks should be part of the contract.
The other recommendation is to ensure
that the contractor can and will support the work
of developing a growth model
that includes analysis of the data
and tools to communicate and educate the public
about the growth model.
Time.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Anne Runge, San Diego Unified School District.
Good morning and thank you for the honor to speak
on behalf of San Diego Unified School District.
We wish to extend our congratulations
to our newly elected board president and vice president.
I'm speaking today on behalf of Erica Simmons,
the director of assessment services,
who's unable to make today's meeting.
For our fall 2020 initial LPAC,
San Diego Unified chose to administer assessments remotely
to our 3,100 identified students.
We are excited to announce that we were able to achieve
a 97% completion rate,
which is among the top in the state
for a large urban school district.
The remote process is allowing San Diego Unified
to practice safety measures
in relation to the COVID-19 pandemic.
Teachers, staff, and students are afforded the opportunity
to test remotely and only when truly necessary.
Arrangements are made to test in-person
following strict COVID-19 protocols.
The support of our office.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
I'm Martha Hernandez, representing Californians Together,
and we are respectfully asking for the scope of work
to include the augmentation
of the California Spanish assessment
to develop a robust assessment measure
comparable to our English assessments.
Also, after meeting with district
English learner coordinators this week,
they are reporting that administration
at the summit of LPAC is very challenging
for a variety of reasons.
Parents are having problems downloading the secure browser.
The district iOS systems need to be updated
to handle the LPAC.
iPads need to be reconfigured
to be able to handle the LPAC,
requiring students to return all the devices
in order to reconfigure.
So we endorse any and all efforts
to encourage the next administration
to waive the administration of the summative LPAC for 2021.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Okay, it looks like that concludes public comment
for item number three.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
I heard a number of comments
about both the nature of improvements
and the assessments that some people would like to see.
Math and the Spanish language test were particularly mentioned.
Then I heard other comments
about the administration of tests this spring.
So we have kind of two buckets of areas to discuss.
Only the first of those is associated with an action.
And we will come back to take action.
With respect to the,
just getting input about views
regarding administration of assessments this year,
just to classify the various kinds of decisions
that might be eventually on the table.
There are decisions about how to give assessments,
decisions about whether to give assessments.
We heard some comments on that.
Decisions about how to give assessments,
remote, in-person, if students are already in school,
in-person if they are not in physical school,
use of diagnostic or interim assessments,
the use of assessments for accountability decisions
such as CSI or TSI determinations.
And then there may also be questions
about accountability for participation rates that come up.
All of those are sort of classes of decisions.
We're glad to hear from each board member.
I'd like to ask you,
because there's so much to say,
if we can go around to each person
and to hear your views in either or both of those buckets,
that would be a way to proceed
in a relatively orderly fashion.
We all stand between ourselves and lunch.
So I'll ask you to be succinct in making your views known.
And I see member Burr, member Strauss,
I thought I saw member Rucker,
and then member Rodriguez.
Member Burr, can you begin?
Yes.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
So a couple of things.
I do have a comment on the proposal before us,
and especially as it relates to the growth model,
I'd like to hear a little bit more about that,
because my understanding is in the past,
and we've been able to get to a place
where we've explored growth models for quite a long time.
And I believe we did that under our prior contract with ETS.
So I'd just like to have Mao or Rachel comment on that,
whether that's part of the proposal going forward.
That's my first question.
The second one is more to your,
I think, second bucket, Linda,
that I'll just state my preferred option here,
that I think that as a state policymaking body,
we should do everything possible
to ease the burden of LEAs related to assessment
in a time when those LEAs are seriously,
or those assessments are seriously in question
related to validity and reliability and comparability.
So I hope that we can explore any option
that is available to us,
while at the same time encouraging LEAs
to use local assessments,
just as Mao did on one of her slides,
for purposes of determining students' needs
and helping to guide instruction.
So I'd just like to suggest,
and for your consideration, especially Linda,
that we get on record as the state policymaking body
that, I don't want to overstate this,
but I sort of feel this way,
that it would be education malpractice
to require LEAs to provide results of assessments
that really are seriously in jeopardy
of being valid as we go forward.
And I understand that we're changing federal administrations,
but I think it's really important
to make a very strong statement
about how we feel about that.
Thank you.
Next I have member Rucker.
Thank you very much.
I'm glad that we had the opportunity
to have this conversation today.
Mao, I appreciate always when we get to this assessment item
because I do learn a lot from your team
and from your presentation.
And I do have a couple of questions.
First, I just want to just do a reality check.
With this start of the new calendar year,
is it, am I correct in my belief
that there are a number of school districts
that are going to soon be entering their assessment window
or that the assessment window
has actually opened up at this moment?
That's right.
And let me just, the question of assessment window,
if I could just make the point
that our statewide assessment window goes until July 15th,
but right now is within the formal school year
of any given district.
Some schools do go on a year round schedule.
One of the things we can also be thinking about
is extending the timeline.
So just to go ahead with that thought,
go ahead, member Rucker.
And you actually read my mind
that was going to be something I was going to ask about,
especially given the information that was presented
concerning some of the technology challenges,
it might be worthwhile to consider doing that extension.
I had the opportunity to listen in
on a couple of different school board meetings
that were cast virtually
as we're doing our state board meeting.
And some of them did raise concerns
both by their assessment coordinators,
but also by their district EL coordinators,
that there really are some problems
with the LPAC technology.
And some districts actually do need to update their systems
and their iPads as was pointed out
by the speaker from Californians together.
And that's some of those logistical nuts and bolts
that are going to take time to figure out
that's going to interfere with the timelines
that they're up against.
So I think that's something worth considering.
And I don't believe that's actually something
that requires action from the board to do,
but rather work the department can undertake
in the work that they're doing with districts already.
So I would just like to ask you to consider how to do that.
And then to the point that Dr. Darling-Hammond made
in her opening remarks,
that we need to take this opportunity
that we're in in the midst of this pandemic
and in the midst of looking at the work
that schools are attempting to do.
I think there's an opportunity
that's probably being missed in our conversations
about accountability, about assessment and testing
in the COVID era.
While it's important for us to think about the term
and the concerns about learning loss,
I think the message frame can be improved
not only to think about learning loss
or disengaged students,
but also to think about what are the indicators
of accountability that we need to be rethinking about
or reframing.
Because we understand the achievement gap
and the purpose of our statewide assessments
for documenting the performance of students
on getting to those targeted goals.
I really appreciated when we talked
about the distance learning guide,
when the English language arts frame was presented
and those targeted goals were identified.
The COVID era has really pointed out
that there's more to look at and talk about
in this COVID era than just thinking
about the disparities in achievement
among students subgroups.
I think this is an opportunity for us to take a look
at what else our accountability dashboard is telling us
in the indicators about disparities
beyond disparities in academic readiness.
Because we can also get information about engagement
in what's told to us about attendance and absenteeism.
You get information about the performance of students
in their coursework and what those disparities are,
the success they're having in gaining access
to their classes and using the technology successfully
and accumulating credits, whether the credits are graded
or not graded, the disparities in the performance
on teacher made or course assessments.
We have to think about also what are the disparities
in access and enrollment to coursework?
That's the reason why I made the point
that the focus of the guidance on English language arts
and math often means particularly for students of color
that there's a loss of focus for the balance of curriculum.
So there's an opportunity for us to also look
at accountability in regard to disparities and access.
So if we had take this opportunity to think about
what we're looking for as we go forward to implement
and think about our accountability system,
whether there's a waiver or not,
there's an opportunity to expand or reframe
the conversation about accountability
to look at the other indicators of achievement
as well as the other indicators of gaps in performance,
particularly to put the focus on what the root causes
of those disparities are and to try to look at ways
to document that.
Thank you.
I'll just note I've been leading the transition team
and one of the, for president-elect Biden
and one of the opportunities is to hear from a lot of groups
and what you just said,
member Rucker has come up quite a bit.
How do we think about accountability also
in terms of opportunity to learn resources available?
So I would just echo that that's been an important theme.
I have on my list, I have member Strauss,
member Rodriguez, member Patio Brownson,
member Glover Woods, member Sun and member Navo.
If you haven't heard your name called,
that might be two of you, I think,
feel free to raise your hand.
Next is member Strauss.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
So first, Deputy Superintendent Mays,
thank you so much for setting the context
of what we are talking about today
and to be clear about the challenges that students
and teachers and leaders are facing
in these really unprecedented times.
In LA County right now, every minute,
10 people are identified positive for COVID-19
and every eight minutes we're losing somebody.
These are terrible, terrible times
and I think as member Patio Brownson said,
it's not likely that we're gonna be back anytime soon
until these numbers go down
and until things are safe for students and for teachers.
And so the likelihood of looking at remote assessment
is a reality under this current guidelines
and I just wanna say to Dr. Vang,
I think you and your team did an amazing job
exploring all the issues around remote assessment
and as you bring up issues of parents signing affidavits,
a browser's not being secure of the number of students
that have to be assessed and then overall,
the reality of whether these assessments
will be valid and reliable at all anyway,
the chance of us getting to 95%
are the current guidelines is completely unrealistic.
So when I think about that,
I think about districts who had to do
a learning continuity plan right away, they had to do it.
They had to identify how they were gonna look
at students learning loss and what they were gonna do
to remediate and intervene to support students.
So districts are doing that using local assessments,
some are using our interim assessments
but right now we know which students are not connected
and which students are struggling.
So this assessment is not likely to give us that information,
any valid reliable information.
So I just wanna say I support the three goals for stage three,
I think we need to continue to develop
a variety of assessment options within our assessment system
and I actually think we need to continue
to encourage the use for the interim assessments
which are aligned to our state standards and our guidelines.
To me, that's a really important tool
and to continue to improve the system
within multiple administration modes
and to continue to look at technology
which we're gonna have to look at in the future
as we hopefully redesign how we deliver education.
But when I think about what the challenges
are going forward, let me say,
while I support these goals for stage three
which is the only item right now,
I believe we as a Board must signal as member Burr said,
that we want to go forward with a waiver given options
as the administration begins to change after January 20th.
And I think the issue is around when we assess,
how we assess the percentage of participation
but the reality is for this spring,
I would rather see district continue
with their learning continuity plan,
continue with the assessments they're using
and provide intervention for students who are struggling.
I appreciate the governor's proposal
for additional extended school year and additional time
which we know we're going to need.
But I don't think that we're going to have
other than an exercise of futility.
And this, I don't think spring administration
with remote learning is going to be an effective tool
other than in frustration.
And I believe as a Board, we should guide
and support the work we're doing now
and look once we're back in person learning,
first connecting with students social emotionally
and reconnecting with them,
they haven't been in school in a year
and then to think about assessment.
So I would support the goals for this item
but I would also support when possible
a future discussion and motion to pursue a waiver
at the federal level for the spring assessment process.
Thank you.
Next I have member Rodriguez.
Thank you, good morning.
And I would like to echo what has just been said
exactly in those words assessments.
You know, I believe for information
and right now a lot of the information
that we already know is that
our students are experiencing loss
for the reasons that member Rucker mentioned, right?
A lot of it is socioeconomic and access.
The information that we could garner
from any assessments that are given,
whether it's at a district level
would be about how we can intervene
and support our students
now that we're learning digitally
or when we're back in person.
As of this morning, Imperial County where I'm seated
has a 39% COVID positivity rate.
And you know, it's a very small county
but the numbers are very similar to Los Angeles County.
And so we're having a devastating effect on our students,
our students' social and emotional wellbeing.
And teachers in my district in particular
have reached out to me about this item
because they are concerned like many members of CTA,
many teachers in the classroom
about the administration of the test
and the effect that it would have on our students.
And I have said, if we can get information that we can use
so that we can support our students
when we're back in the classroom,
then that would be wonderful.
But like everybody else, I'm in support of a waiver
in pursuing that route.
And then of course, if we don't get the waiver
to make sure that the assessment results
are used for information, perhaps for funding
so that we can support our students
once we return to class.
And I also spoke to students and I asked them
what they thought about testing
and the thought was just so overwhelming to them.
So, hearing from a lot of our different stakeholders,
people have reached out to me
and I've contacted colleagues that I feel comfortable
getting the honest truth from them.
So that's one thing on the testing.
Again, I'll just reiterate that I'm in support
of a waiver from the federal government
if that can happen.
And then with regard to the second bucket
or which may have been the first bucket,
I want to also acknowledge Kaltog's letter
and some of the comments made regarding the CSA
and how much I would like as a person
who's bilingual and biliterate
and completely support these efforts for the CSA
to make sure that when we contract with somebody
who will be creating the new contractor
for these assessments,
that there are the constructed response writing items
and that it mirrors the English language arts assessment.
I think that's something that's very important
for us to move forward with.
Thank you.
Member Patia Bronson.
I also want to join in thanks to Dr. Vang and Dr. Maves
for providing the context
and also some of the updates
as to what some of the training opportunities
and resources that have been made available online
and through virtual formats to help people get up to speed
with remote testing procedures,
which as board member Strauss was saying,
I think is a very, very much the highest likelihood
of what would happen certainly in LA County in the future,
but many other counties that are in the purple right now.
I am really, I think,
struck by the data that we saw
from some of the parent polls in the fall.
And I'm thinking of the Ed Trust West poll of parents
around the state.
And it's more than two thirds of students' parents
around the state that are saying
that they still want the data
about how their children are performing.
And also wanting to know whether their kids
are meeting the expectations that we have set out for them.
I don't think that has changed.
And although there are stressors,
there are also mechanisms by which some of this testing
actually can be very centering and focusing for students.
We heard a lot of accounts here in Los Angeles
around the idea that when there was guaranteed grades
to be held harmless,
a lot of students were less motivated
and were not as focused on it.
And as the return to grades in the more normal format
came back, students actually focused in a different way.
I think some of the comments around this idea
that we already know that there's learning loss,
I think it is true.
And what the specter of testing offers
is to give us a much clearer view
of the degree to which learning loss is not consistent.
It is not uniform.
And to know where it is most acute
and be able to have the capacity to pinpoint that
and address it in the future,
I think is a valuable tool that we should not give up on.
I'm also, I think, encouraged to hear about the potential
for an extended testing timeline
as we're looking at the July 15th timeframe.
And if the state budget goes forward
with this idea of an extended school year,
that also creates additional flexibility
to be able to make sure that
we're not making any sweeping generalizations
about the degree to which learning loss is uniform
and a California-wide problem,
and also sweeping up the carpet,
the degree to which it's much more acute
in some neighborhoods, in some schools,
in some communities, and our policymakers
need to know that exactly
in order to actually be able to solve for it in the future.
Thank you.
Member Glover-Woods.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond,
and I'll be very succinct in my comments.
I agree with all of the comments
that have been made by my fellow Board members.
First, in regards to the item that's in front of us
for action, I do support those proposed goals
that have been outlined.
I would just encourage that as exploration is being done,
that we make sure that we are emphasizing
really the further development of all aspects
of our California assessment system,
inclusive of our California Spanish assessment,
to ensure that there is the same robust type of information
and opportunities for students to perform their knowledge
on that assessment as is on some of the others.
As it relates to test administration for the spring,
I can, again, just say ditto, ditto, ditto.
I'm in full support of moving forward for a waiver
when it is the time to do so.
The reality in the field is that bringing students back
on campus in many of our districts across the state
is just not a doable thing.
We've already heard a lot of the issues
around trying to deliver the assessment remotely.
That could be an opportunity for some,
but again, might be extremely challenging in other areas.
So what I would, again, strongly encourage us to do
is to seek a waiver and to look at,
as some of the Board members have mentioned,
other ways that accountability can be looked at,
other indicators of learning
and also other indicators that will help us know
exactly where the gaps are and to be able to communicate
that to the parents and families that need the information.
So really working with districts or charters
at the local level so that, again,
we're able to communicate and they are able to communicate
to their families and to their students
how students have performed and where they are
at the end of this year,
so that there is a clear starting place
for the new school year.
Thank you.
Member Sun.
Yeah, I'm going to be parroting
some of what my colleagues have said.
I agree it would be untenable to administer
a statewide assessment this spring,
irrespective of all the reliability questions that we have.
So I would also support seeking a waiver
when and if that option comes before us.
At the same time, I have to tell you,
I feel a sense that I feel like it would be irresponsible
of us not to have some sort of a baseline,
a sense of how our students are doing
coming out of this pandemic and going into next year.
And inspired by the words of President Darling-Hammond,
at the beginning of this meeting
about how we can look at things differently,
I wonder if there may be a way
that we do some kind of administration
without accountability and just to get a sense of baseline
in the fall of the next school year.
And if that might be something that we can be worked in
where we have some consistency.
And while I know we have the interim assessments
and we have the schools and districts
are using local assessments for these diagnostics,
I feel that we have a responsibility to get a pulse,
statewide pulse on what is happening with learning
and where students are right now.
And so, and I can't imagine us not waiting
until the following spring, until spring of next year.
So looking at being creative,
not always just doing things that we've always had,
we've never done any kind of a baseline in a fall,
but perhaps that might be something we want to consider
and look into or explore.
Thank you, thank you.
Member Navarro.
Yeah, I just appreciate my fellow board members
and their thoughtful comments.
And to the extent that I can offer something
for food for thought here, I will.
On the first item, Mal and Rachel,
I really appreciate the hard work that you have done.
And I agree with our fellow comments
around the growth model and the CSA opportunities
should they be at the extent that they exist.
I think those might be very beneficial to pursue.
On the second item, regarding whether or not we test
to the extent we're talking about something
we actually can control here,
it seems to me that it's one of three options.
One is you request the waiver and you go without tests
and you have run the risk of the Ed saying no,
at which point districts will hold back,
hoping for the waiver.
Option two, to the extent that we can get some flexibilities
around testing things like the 95% participation rate,
because I think we were assuming that to a large degree
that parents are gonna come into this.
And I know we've heard that there are a lot of parents
that do anticipate and desire this.
I think there's a lot of parents that won't be willing
to add the stress level to the remote learning
that has already existed.
To the extent that we can extend
the performance task window would be helpful.
And we've done this before.
When we transitioned from state standards to Common Core,
we actually went two years without testing it.
And we relied on local achievement data
and we have asked our districts to identify
those local assessments in their LCPs.
So the extent that we give them one year of hiatus
under unprecedented times to me,
the wheels aren't gonna fall off when we did it before,
certainly under different circumstances.
But we have asked local educators in the past
to go without testing results
and to rely on local assessments
to determine the needs of their students.
And the third option is we grin and bear it,
the reality that we have to test.
And we ask local educators to do the best they can.
My preference and my opinion is that we rely on option one.
I don't think we have a choice.
I don't think we can say in one breath,
there's a pandemic and juniors,
you can't come in and take your PSAT.
And in the same breath,
encourage them to come and take their aspect.
I don't think that we have a choice
other than to demonstrate that we were gonna walk the talk
and that has been the priority of safety
of students and staff.
And so I think we have to prioritize the waiver request
and to the extent that we can get anything,
minimally flexibility,
because I am sensitive to the districts like San Diego
and there are others who are well-equipped
and able to use the assessment to gain results.
Thank you.
Okay, I see member Fatah has raised his hand.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
And I'd just like to take a moment to thank Dr. Vang
and the team for exploring all the issues
and ideas that you mentioned in your presentation.
And I'd also like to take the moment to really echo
and place emphasis on the words of my colleagues,
board members Navo and Sun.
I think that they really share a valuable perspective
when they say that, particularly board member Navo,
when he just brought up that we were kind of telling juniors
to, I guess, stand by, not take the PSAT.
And so now we're gonna kind of encourage them
to come in and take state testing.
And I also am starting to really recognize the problem
with the fact that we're jeopardizing
the legitimacy of the exam if we were to deliver it remotely.
And I'm also the problem that kind of arises
when we bring students on campus to take the testing
because of the COVID-19 pandemic.
So I just like to say that I share the same sentiments
as board members Strauss
and numerous of my other fellow board members.
And I support the three goals before us,
but I also support the federal waiver
for the spring assessments.
And I really like the idea
that board member Sun just brought up
that because of the learning loss
and the fact that we risk a lot of learning loss,
it would be kind of a nice idea for us
to get a heartbeat in the fall
and see where we're kind of out in terms of learning loss
by doing some kind of assessment of some sort.
So that's my perspective.
Thank you.
Appreciate that.
Member McQuillin, did you wanna add your two cents
to the conversation?
You're the only one we have not yet heard from.
Last but not least, thank you for asking.
I appreciate all the work from the staff on this item also.
It is very complicated.
And thinking through all the comments
and I echo a lot of what's been said.
I think of all our North State counties
who are struggling right now
and the disparity in devices and connectivity.
And we have so many students that are missing in action
up here in the North State who are missing school,
a large attendance problem.
So when I think of assessments this spring,
anything we can do to offer flexibility for our districts
and LEAs in terms of extending the year
or extending the window of assessment, those are all great.
And I would support the idea of a waiver also
if that comes to be.
So thank you all for the comments and the work.
Thank you.
I'm gonna take a moment to sort of sum up
and see if we can move towards our motion.
What I hear in common across the board
is a concern for safety and a concern for focusing
on student needs and knowing what our students
know and can do.
Even if that means we rely on formative
and diagnostic tools in some cases
or move the assessment window out further
such that we actually wait till it's safe
to have students in school and bring them back
perhaps even in the fall.
There are some states that, and I think of Connecticut
where our incoming secretaries from used to do
their assessments in the fall for the purpose
of knowing how kids are doing before the full year begins.
So there are ways to think about the options
both in terms of the nature of the assessments.
We did ask in our continuity plans
for everyone to do diagnostic or formative assessments
and that may give the information to parents
and district and teachers that helps them move forward.
It's actually the only way we can measure learning loss
right now because we didn't give
the summative assessment last year.
So the summative assessment won't tell us much
about learning loss, formative and diagnostic tools may.
So we may need to think flexibly
about the kinds of assessment while wanting to focus
on student needs and safety at the same time.
We may need to think flexibly
about the timelines for assessment.
And I hear a resounding view that we should be cognizant
of the situation that we're in right now
and the high levels of COVID rates
in many parts of the state and be mindful
that we not conduct business as usual in this context
even while we're looking at flexibilities
that may allow us to know how our students are doing.
And so I think we're gonna have to take stock
of all of that and what the incoming administration invites
in terms of waivers.
There is already an invitation
to disconnect accountability decisions for CSI and TSA
from any assessments of the current administration
has made that clear that that's a requestable waiver.
So I hear a lot of support for that
and then we will see what the other possibilities may be.
And so I want to now focus us on the item
that we need to vote on.
What we need to vote on is the CDE recommendation
that's still up on Director Vang's slide
around the Enhancing the Development
and Administration of High Quality Assessments,
some of the Interim Informative,
Improve the Robust Assessment System
and Explore and Advance Technology Solutions.
I think we heard a lot of statements
about how the board's view of improving assessments
includes performance tests and instructor response items
that really give a sense of how kids are thinking
and performing and includes following the work
that we're doing to get at things like big ideas
and mathematics and so on.
So I think we got a sense of the board's views
about what improvement might consist of.
Do we have a motion for the recommendations?
I'm happy to move the CDE's recommendation
on the proposed goals and priorities for stage three.
All right, and do we have a second?
Second.
Thank you very much.
Is there any further discussion?
All right, I think we need to take a roll call vote.
Brooks, can you call our roll?
Number son.
Aye.
Vice President Strauss.
Member Rucker.
Yes, absolutely.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Patil Brownson.
Member Navo.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Glover Woods.
Yes.
Member Fatah.
President Darling-Hammond.
Yes.
Member Burr.
Aye.
The motion passes unanimously.
Thank you, and thank you, Mao, for all of the good work,
the good presentation, and for your stamina.
And coming up on the noon hours.
So I think what we ought to do is take our break for lunch
from now till 1230.
I will let you know that we are a little behind
where we thought we might be at this point,
so we're going to try to be very efficient this afternoon
so we can catch up toward our goal.
All right, very good.
We'll see you back at 1230.
Please turn your microphone and your camera off,
but do not leave the room, the virtual room.
You can leave your actual room.
Thank you.
We are up to item four.
Item four is the update to the California
Every Student Succeeds Act state plan,
approval of amendments to the state plan
and COVID-19 state plan addendum
to the U.S. Department of Education.
The CDE recommends that we approve the amendments
to the consolidated state plan
and COVID-19 state plan addendum for submission
to the Department of Education,
pending the State Board of Education
Executive Director approval of final revisions
requested by SBE and correction of any typographical errors
or non-substantive clarifying edits,
and the item will be presented by Joe Sines
and Cindy Kazanis of the CDE.
So Joe and Cindy, please begin.
Thank you so much.
Good afternoon, State Board members.
My name is Joe Sines, for those of you who don't know me,
and I'm the Federal Policy Liaison
for the California Department of Education.
Today, myself, along with Cindy Kazanis,
Director of the Analysis, Measurement,
and Accountability Reporting Division,
will be presenting item four,
the update to the California's
Every Student Succeeds Act state plan,
approval of the amendments to the state plan,
and COVID-19 state plan addendum
to the U.S. Department of Education.
Next slide, please.
And the topics we will be covering
in our presentation today
will be in order to provide background
on the Every Student Succeeds Act,
also known as the ESSA,
and update you on the amendment status
of California's consolidated state plan.
Also, we will be covering proposed amendments
to the state plan.
And lastly, this presentation will update the group
on the 2020-21 school year COVID-19 state plan addendum
that has been offered by the U.S. Department of Education.
Next slide, please.
The CDE recommends that the State Board
approve the amendments to California's
ESSA consolidated state plan
and COVID-19 state plan addendum
for submission to the U.S. Department of Education.
This would be pending
the SBE Executive Director approval
of final revisions requested by the State Board,
correction of any typographical errors,
and necessary non-substantive clarifying edits.
I'd also like to recognize that the last item
had a robust discussion
regarding the waiving of assessments.
This item doesn't really contemplate that.
We look to the direction of the State Board
and the superintendent for any issues
relating to that discussion.
Next slide, please.
Now we'll go through the ESSA and updates
on the status of the latest amendments.
Next slide, please.
So as many of you know, give you some background.
The ESSA was signed into law by President Barack Obama
in December 2015.
It was a reauthorization of the Elementary
and Secondary Education Act, or ESEA.
It replaces the No Child Left Behind Act.
It ensures educational equity and opportunity
for disadvantaged and high-need students,
and it's access supplement to state programs.
Next slide, please.
In January of 2020, the State Board approved
the adoption of the following amendments
to the ESSA State Plan,
which reflect the Board's action in 2019
and technical edits to the plan.
This includes the following, updating the long-term goal
and revised status cut scores
for the graduation rate indicator,
approve the methodology for using
the English Learner Progress Indicator, or LP,
for school identification.
Next slide, please.
Additionally, it approved status cut scores for the LP,
clarified the definitions of ineffective teacher
and out-of-field teacher,
it raised the low graduation threshold to below 68%,
it refined a combined, also known as an extended rate,
four- and five-year graduation rate
for the graduation rate indicator,
and reinserted the academic indicator state-level data
by student group tables.
So now I will pass the presentation to Cindy
to talk more about the State Plan amendments and timeline.
Thanks, Joe.
So the next slide is good news.
We were approved for all of the items
that Joe discovered on December 4th
as we were preparing this board item for your consideration.
Additionally, in that letter,
the U.S. Department of Education approved additional time
for the CDE to provide data related to educator equity
for California's ESSA Consolidated State Plan.
That data is due to the U.S. Department of Education
by March of 2021.
And just as an aside, the CDE continues to work actively
with our partners and our CalPAT staff internally
for the collection of this data as we currently speak.
So in doing that, we are actually providing
technical assistance very actively to the field,
and there's been an enormous response.
We've had or plan to have over 4,000 participants
in technical assistance webinars around this data collection
for the current school year.
So many hats off to Barbara Murchison and her staff,
as well as Jerry Winkler and his team in the CalPATs
off in the field to make sure that this data collection
continues to be robust and of high quality.
Additionally, we received a letter
from the U.S. Department of Education back in October,
going backwards, which is unrelated to the amendments
that were approved, but rather really delved
into our dashboard alternative school status.
And you all heard a lot about that program
this past board meeting in November,
where we had some robust conversations
about the value added that we've done in California
for our accountability system
for our most high-need students,
our alternative school students.
What the U.S. Department of Education told California
was that that program or that we're using
to calculate state indicators
for the dashboard alternative school status.
Schools is not permissible under ESSA,
and that we cannot establish different cut scores
for the academic indicator
or use a one-year graduation rate.
We've asked for additional time,
and the next couple of slides,
I'm gonna walk you through the amendments
that we're proposing.
So there are four different attachments to this item.
The first attachment and the third attachment
relate to the ESSA Consolidated State Plan
proposed amendments.
So specifically, as you saw in the abbreviated version
for attachment one for the dashboard alternative
school status, we are asking for permission
to use this indicator.
We have not in the past formally placed this
in our ESSA state plan,
and so this now puts it in the ESSA state plan.
We also are asking not only
for the academic indicator modified methods
to be approved,
but the graduation rate indicator
modified methods to be approved as well.
So you'll see those edits in attachment three
in that 166 page document
that we have to place and track changes
to send to the US Department of Education
as the amendments are submitted.
Additionally, as you're gonna hear
in the next couple of slides
about the COVID state plan addendum,
we are required which we are moving forward with
and asking for relief from identification of schools.
This piece, unlike the other piece
that you're gonna hear about
related to the college crew indicator
has to be updated or you have to submit
an updated state plan to them.
So we are trying to sort of deal with both issues at once
and in doing the amendment to the state plan,
you'll also see the language in there
that describes our timeline changes
for school identification
as part of that COVID-19 state plan addendum process.
And with that, I'm gonna turn it back over to Joe.
Oh, sorry, this is still my part.
So in working, walking through,
actually, Joe, you're picking this up, right?
Yeah, I got.
Sorry about that.
Thank you, Cindy.
The next part of this item will cover
the 2020-21 school year COVID-19 state plan addendum.
Next slide, please.
So as you know, in March of 2020,
in response to the COVID-19 pandemic,
ED invited states to request a streamlined assessment
and accountability waiver.
Through this, states would not need
to administer statewide assessments to all students
to make annual accountability determinations
to identify schools for support and improvement
or to provide data on a state and local report cards
for assessment and accountability information.
We worked to get this submitted.
So on March 26, Superintendent Thurmond
and State Board President Darling-Hammond
submitted on behalf of the CDE and SBE
the assessment and accountability waiver.
This was also approved retroactively
by the State Board on May 7th, 2020.
And I think we just lost Cindy.
So just a moment.
No worries, I can.
Alex, do you have the PowerPoint by chance?
Thank you.
Okay, perfect.
So in response to the COVID-19 waivers approved in March,
U.S. Department of Education in October of 2020
released information to provide responses
to questions state education agencies,
local education agencies and schools may have
regarding implementation of the COVID-19 waivers
and the impact of COVID-19 on accountability systems
for the 2020-21 school year.
Next slide, please.
So as found in the attachment,
specifically U.S. Department of Education
posted the following documents related to COVID-19 waivers
on the ED Consolidated State Plans webpage.
This was the State Plan Addendum template for 2020-2021
and also a draft of FAQs titled Impact of COVID-19
on Accountability System required under the ESEA.
So the deadline for this State Plan Addendum
is February 1st, 2021.
And so I think this was, let me see real quickly,
this was Cindy's part actually.
So let me just, as anyone,
did she get in touch with you, Alex, by chance?
She is having technology problems at her house
and they're trying to fix those.
Okay.
But we've read the item.
And so if you wanna just kind of walk us through the slides,
I think that would be-
Yeah, yeah, that's fine.
I can do that.
I just wanted to give her a chance.
You know, these technology-
She pops back in.
Yeah, I was less worried about her following off
than my dog barking or something like that.
So I can keep going.
So the revisions to the State Plan
that can be submitted through the streamlined COVID process.
So the state indicators that are impacted
by not having this data
will only impact the Accountability System
for the 2020-21 school year
and or accountability terminations
and or school identifications in fall of 2021.
So we do intend to submit this
for the College Career Indicator.
So it's important to note too,
we're only taking advantage of a portion
of this addendum.
Next slide, please.
So looking at the school dashboard
and reporting of the College Career Indicator.
So we recommend that the CCI
not be reported on the 2021 dashboard.
This is because our graduates will not have
the grade 11 California Assessment
of Student Performance and Progress
results due to the suspension of testing in March of 2020.
One of the key measures of the CCI.
Since all indicators are equally weighted in the dashboard,
no other changes are proposed as a result.
And this is a one-time change
and only applies for the 2021 school year.
And I think Cindy might be back.
Hello.
Just to add a couple of notes
to what I think Jess already covered.
For the College Career Indicator,
while we may not be able to,
let me turn on the video,
while we may not be able to report out on it
this coming year, we are contemplating
and we are committed to exploring
how we can report on some of the measures
that I think as Member Rucker mentioned
in the prior item, that districts have been spending
a lot of time investing in.
Like what kind of access to courses,
to completion of courses, certain courses
that students have completion
or successful taking of an AP exam.
So those are some pieces that we're trying to get creative on
in absence of being able to report out on a formal measure,
being able to put on the pieces
that make up that particular indicator.
So I wanted to mention that piece.
Next slide.
So as far as the revision timeline,
or rather the timeline revisions for the state plan,
we are proposing to take advantage
of the ability to not identify new schools
for comprehensive support and improvement
or additional targeted support improvement.
And again, for all our states,
this has been sort of on a three-year basis,
but for California, we've been identifying every year
because we've been deemed a high-risk state
and it's been a condition of that piece on our grant.
This does not contemplate
or rather the streamlined labor does not provide us
the option to not identify schools
under targeted support and improvement.
So that is something I know President Darling-Hammond
mentioned was at the forefront
of the new administration coming in next week
to Washington, D.C. for consideration.
So what this waiver would do
is provide CSI schools an extra year
to meet the statewide exit criteria
before implementing more rigorous state-termined action
as well as for ATSI schools an extra year
to meet statewide exit criteria
before identifying for CSI.
So they'd have additional time,
we'd see a freeze for those two programs
for a second year in a row.
Next slide, and just to further that information,
the timeline then would move schools and CSI
to the fall of, I don't think that's accurate.
We would move schools and CSI to the fall of 2025
for looking at it again.
We propose that no new schools be identified for CSI
or KTSI for this coming school year.
So we typically identify in January,
so it'd be January 2022,
but I think it's helpful just to keep in mind
this would be based on 2021 dashboard results,
which of course we're suggesting
that we be waived from that identification.
And ATSI schools would be provided an extra year
to meet statewide exit criteria
before being identified for CSI,
which was again, something in our waiver
when we looked down the road about schools
that continue to be in ATSI.
So to summarize our recommendation on the next slide
is that the State Board of Education,
okay,
send them for submission to the US Department of Education
pending the State Board of Education Executive Director
approval of final revisions requested by the FDE
and corrections of any typographical errors
and necessary non-substitutive clarifying edits.
And with that, I think we have a slide for public comments.
Excellent, thank you so much.
So we will now open the phone line for public comment queue
and members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so by calling the phone number
and using the access code shown there.
And while we're waiting for members of the public to call in,
I want to ask member Burr and then Vice President Strauss
if they have any initial comments on this item
and then we will get to public comment
and then come back for board discussion.
So member Burr, do you want to start us off?
Sure, I don't think I have any additional comments.
Both Cindy and Joe did an excellent job
describing the action requested
and be happy to hear public comment
and then be available to make a motion as needed.
All right, Vice President Strauss,
do you have any framing comments?
Yeah, so let me just say,
I think we've worked really hard to align
the federal requirements for ESSA with our state plan.
And as we've done thoughtful work,
sometimes ED says it doesn't quite fit.
So then we ask for a waiver and we try to make the system fit
and I think it really is aligned
to what we identify in California
and what our stakeholder input has agreed to.
I agree with not identifying any new schools at this point.
I don't think that's necessary based on how we identify them
and then we went into remote learning pretty soon after.
And I do believe that member Rucker's comments
about the other components of college and career
are essential to look at in addition to the state
to smarter balance assessments for 11th grade.
So I agree with that.
And I just, again, I just support us aligning the process
and then when we can asking for a waiver
so that we may stay the path that we've identified
and I support these recommendations.
Thank you.
Great.
Are there any clarifying questions
just about the content of what we heard?
All right, let's go to public comment if we have any.
Yes, we do.
It looks like we have a few people in the queue.
I will open the phone line up for item number four.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Okay, we'll broadcast.
My name is Dr. Micah Studer,
Executive Director of Equity and Support Services
for the Yolo County Office of Education.
And I come before you as a representative
of the California County Superintendents
Educations Association Student Programs
and Services Steering Committee.
We are concerned that the United States
Department of Education's decision to reject
California's modified methodology
for alternative education programs
will disproportionately harm our students.
For a dashboard alternative,
the status school serving students across the state,
the modified method of collecting data
are critical for our schools and student groups
for two key reasons.
Firstly, are crucial in measuring student progress.
Many students in DAS schools report to our campus
with significant learning loss
and a desperate need of learning acceleration.
With over 93% of our students being very low or low,
negative students arts and 96% being very low or low in math,
we need a way to more accurately measure
student learning and academic progress.
Second, these metrics support DAS schools
in measuring school interventions and supports.
Especially when examining the graduation rate,
our DAS schools will be misrepresented.
Educational programs for our students
are individualized by design,
with students typically not spending four years
or more in our programs.
And as such, a cohort model does not apply.
In summary, we need a way to meaningfully measure,
analyze, and support our DAS schools and staff
by recognizing their unique charge
in supporting our MOSAP Promise Students.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Thank you.
Jessica Sacco on behalf of Children Now.
I'm affirming our alignment with the concerns
and requests that were outlined
in the LCFF Equity Coalition letter on this item.
One question I'm hoping the board can address
is when the SLEA report cards will be released.
They were due last June and still have not been released.
The report cards must include for the first time
data on school site per pupil expenditures
and data on the distribution of under-qualified teachers.
Relative to low-income and minority students
being served at disproportionate rates
by ineffective teachers,
the reporting of that information
and actions that need to take place to comply with law,
Children Now encourages the board
to establish objective state standards
for fully credentialed and misassigned teachers
and ensure LEAs publish updated teacher equity plans
as part of their local ESSA obligations
in which they outline the steps they will take
to ensure low-income and minority students
are not served at disproportionate rates
by ineffective teachers.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
It's John Athelt from Public Advocates
and also on behalf of the Equity Coalition.
We wanna congratulate President Darling Hammond
and Vice President Strauss for your reelection today.
On this day when we have a president being impeached
for the second time,
it's good to know we have a president in California
that we can believe and believe in.
The teacher equity obligation under ESSA
is not just a local LEA data collection exercise.
It's also incumbent on the SEA here
to ensure that the local teacher equity plans
are actually in good shape
and working to ensure that students have equal access
to effective and prepared and in-field teachers.
Likewise, this state board needs to take its own actions
to ensure teacher equity is being addressed
and we hope to see the priority one indicator
addressed this year for the December dashboard.
Thank you.
Teacher equity, thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, this is Leticia Garcia
on behalf of Riverside County Superintendent of Schools.
We'd like to thank the board and the SPI
for your continued support during this crisis.
We also appreciate the board's recent approval
of the shortened assessments
to give LEAs more options
to assess students during distance learning.
However, we're concerned that LEAs will be unable
to meet the 95% participation rate as required by ESEA.
As you recognize in the prior item,
local conditions make it difficult
to offer in-person assessments
and in some cases CD guidance prevents remote assessments
such as with the California alternate assessments.
This will disproportionately impact
the special education student group
and the academic indicator making it difficult
to accurately identify districts
for differentiated assistance.
Based on how the waiver request plays out,
we ask that CDE analyze the impact
of the participation rate requirements
for accountability purposes.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
It's Eric Premack with the Charter Schools
Development Center again.
Briefly wanna thank the Department of Ed
for its vigorous defense of the DOS
Dashboard Alternative System
and hope that you'll continue to do so
and hope that the new administration
will be more reasonable in its receptivity to that.
We also ask that the dashboard respect
the ongoing credentialing flexibility
that's afforded to charter schools
and that charter schools not be punished
for using that flexibility in the dashboard rankings.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for item number four.
Thanks very much.
Make sure I'm off of mute.
So at this point, we will open up for board discussion.
Do we have any hands raised?
I don't see any yet.
And if this seems straightforward,
we can go to a motion.
I am not seeing any questions or comments from the board.
Is there a motion on behalf of the recommendations?
Yes, I've moved the department's recommendation
on this item.
Right, we have a second.
I second it.
All right, is there any further discussion?
Hearing none, we'll take a roll call vote.
Number son.
Aye.
Vice President Strauss.
Yes.
Member Rucker.
Member Rodriguez.
Aye.
Thank you, member Rucker.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes, yes.
Member Patil Brownson.
Yes.
Member Navo.
Member McQuillin.
Aye.
Member Glover Woods.
Yes.
Member Fatah.
President Darling-Hammond.
Yes.
Member Burr.
Aye.
Terrific, thank you.
And before we thank you and excuse you, Joe and Cindy,
I do want to just ask for clarification on a question
that a couple of the public commenters asked
about when the data on expenditures and teachers
will be made available.
Linda, I'm happy to take that question.
Thank you.
So the expenditure reports were collected
for the first time for our LARPs,
which is our local educational accountability report cards.
And that is something that we expect to be out
in the next couple of weeks.
In fact, we have ready for you an information memoranda
about that information and how it's new
and how it was collected.
So you'll be receiving that information
through a formal board memo in February.
In regard to the teacher equity data,
I know that Barb Murchison is on the call
if we need additional assistance,
but we are still working with our partners
at the Commission on Teacher Credentialing
to match the data set that they've now processed
for the first time in their new data system, CalSAS.
So we are anxiously awaiting that data file.
So I don't yet have access to that data.
I'm hoping in the next couple of weeks we will have access
and then we'll do our best to, again,
report that information out to the builders
as soon as we are able.
Terrific, we will anxiously await it.
And thank you so much, Joe and Cindy
for that great presentation.
Thank you.
And we're gonna forge right on ahead to item number five,
which is the State Educational Agency approval
of the 2020-21 Comprehensive Support and Improvement Plans
authorized under the Every Student Succeeds Act,
Section 1111D.
The CDE recommends that we take action
to approve those plans.
And this item will be presented by Lindsay Tomator
from the CDE with Laura Traian
from the Marin County Office of Education
with Tyler Graff from the San Rafael School District
and Stephen Green and Patricia Carlin
of the San Diego County Office of Education.
A group project.
Lindsay, would you like to begin?
Thank you.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond,
Vice President Strauss, and members of the Board
and happy new year.
My name is Lindsay Tornatore
and I am the Director of the Student Achievement
and Support Division here at the Department of Education.
I am joined by my esteemed colleagues from Marin
and San Diego County Office of Education
who will be joining me a little later on
during this presentation to share some stories
of their work in their counties.
As President Darling-Hammond stated,
this is an action item that the CDE is requesting
the State Board of Education
to approve the comprehensive support
and improvement plans for the 2020-21 school year.
As many of you will recall,
this is not the first time that you have taken action
to approve California CSI school plans.
In fact, it was just one year ago in January of 2020
that all of you approved the CSI plans
for the 2019-2020 school year for cohort one.
And it was during the discussion of that item
that the Board expressed some concern
about the CSI plan review and approval process
and while the plan review and approval process
is still the same this year as it was last year,
I do hope that this presentation is able to address
some of the concerns and questions that were raised.
Specifically, this item will provide
a comprehensive overview of the state
and federal requirements that guide the development,
implementation, monitoring, and evaluation
of CSI plans and activities.
Before we dive into the item,
I would like to walk us through
some of the significant events
that got us to where we are today.
In December of 2015, President Obama
signed the Every Student Succeeds Act into law.
In July of 2018, California's ESSA State Plan
was first approved by the U.S. Department of Education.
Then in September of 2018, AB 716 was signed into law
to allow for the School Plan for Student Achievement,
or SIPSA, to meet ESSA CSI planning requirements.
In January of 2019, the State Board adopted
the current CSI plan review and approval process,
which included the adoption
of a revised LCAP plan summary section
that includes three CSI summary prompts.
2020, the board approved the CSI plans
for the first cohort of CSI schools,
which were identified using the 2018 dashboard.
And that brings us to today.
Again, the request is for an action item
to approve the 2020-21 school year CSI plans.
Before we request your action,
I will provide the overview
of the CSI plan approval process.
And of course, in 2019, when the process was adopted,
none of us imagined where we would be in 2020
with the current state of our educational landscape.
So therefore, I will also be sure
to point out some modifications
that we had to make this year
within the review approval process
in light of the COVID-19 pandemic.
And the final part of this item,
and arguably the best part,
is to share two stories from the field
that show how in Marin and San Diego County,
the County Office of Education and the LEA
are working together to surround their CSI schools
with support that guides them
through their continuous improvement journeys.
So the first and most important question, of course,
is who is being approved?
As mentioned, the second cohort of CSI schools
using the 2019 California School Dashboard,
these plans have been developed by LEAs
in collaboration with their schools and stakeholders.
Attachment one and the addendum of this item
include the list of LEAs with approved responses
to the 2020-21 CSI prompt.
So the second question of what is being approved
or what should we expect to be in the CSI plans
can be addressed by reviewing
what the ESSA statute requires LEAs
and their CSI schools to do when developing,
implementing, monitoring, and evaluating their CSI plans.
ESSA statute requires that CSI plans are developed
to include evidence-based interventions,
strategies, and activities
that match the reason for identification
and with the strongest evidence
to improve outcomes for each student
and sustain those improvements over time.
ESSA statute also requires that the LEA shall,
for each identified school
and in partnership with stakeholders,
develop and implement a CSI plan
for the school to improve that,
is informed by all state indicators,
includes evidence-based interventions,
is based on a school-level needs assessment,
and identifies resource inequities,
which may include a review of LEA
and school-level budgeting
to be addressed by the implementation of the CSI plan.
So in addition to the ESSA requirement for LEAs
in partnership with stakeholders and their CSI schools
to develop and implement the CSI plan,
also ESSA statute requires that CSI plans
must be approved by the school,
the LEA, and the state educational agency.
So in our ESSA state plan,
California has and continues to amend and write
based on the commitment that we have
to align state and federal educational policies
to the greatest extent possible
to develop an integrated local, state,
and federal accountability
and continuous improvement system
that is grounded in the LCFF.
In our original plan,
California did not have a state-level
plan, California did commit to review
and approve initial CSI plans,
including a review of how the LEAs
will address identified resource inequities.
Of course, it has always been California's goal
to fit the federal accountability system
into the state accountability system.
And so the process that was adopted in 2019
leverages two key pieces of our state accountability system,
which are the CPSA and the LCAP.
The CPSA, which has a template with instructions
that meet all CSI planning requirements
as per ESSA is posted,
and the school site council requirements
associated with the CPSA also meet
the ESSA stakeholder engagement requirements.
An approved CPSA serves as the school CSI plan.
The LCAP includes three CSI prompts
that once the school has an approved CPSA or CSI plan,
then the LEA summarizes these plans in those prompts.
The purpose of the prompts in the LCAP
is to report how the LEA has supported
each of its identified CSI schools
in the development, monitoring, and evaluation
of the implementation and effectiveness of their CSI plans.
So the three prompts that are currently
in the LCAP summary section are identify the schools
within the LEA that have been identified for CSI,
describe how the LEA supported the identified schools
in developing CSI plans that included
a school level needs assessment and the identification
of any resource inequities to be addressed
through the implementation of the CSI plan.
And third, describe how the LEA will monitor
and evaluate the implementation and effectiveness
of the CSI plan to support student and school improvement.
So to give a visual of the current review
and approval process, we'll start at the top
in the orange box.
The LEA in partnership with stakeholders
and their school site council develops the CPSA,
which of course, as mentioned,
includes all of the CSI planning requirements.
Then the LEA governing board approves the CSI plan.
The LEA then summarizes its support of identified schools
through the CSI planning prompts in the LCAP plan summary.
The county office approves the LEA's LCAP,
which includes the CSI summary plan.
And then the CDE brings the list of LEAs
with approved CSI prompts to the board for approval.
So of course, this year was a unique year,
hopefully the only unique year that we will experience.
And so in light of that, of our current landscape,
we had to make a slight modification.
So when Senate Bill 98 waived the requirement for LEAs
to complete an LCAP for the 2020-21 school year,
and the learning continuity plan replaced the LCAP,
the learning continuity plan does not,
did not include the three CSI summary prompts.
So therefore the CDE created a standalone template
for LEAs to complete the required CSI prompts.
This template and instructions to complete the prompts
were posted on the CDE website in September of 2020.
Our CDE team hosted a webinar for LEAs and COEs
that in September 2020 to walk through the template
and the instructions, which had approximately 770 attendees.
And then the CSI prompts were due from the LEA
to their COE or to the CDE if applicable by October 31st.
We want to emphasize that the final step
in the CSI plan and approval process
is that the LEAs are required
to post their COE approved 2020-21 CSI prompts
to the same webpage that they post
their learning continuity plan,
LCAP federal addendum, CSI plan,
and any other planning documents.
And I would like to just really quickly point out too
that this is an extra step, right?
That typically our LEAs do not need to do
because when they typically post their LCAPs,
their CSI prompts are included in it.
So we made sure to provide some guidance on this point.
The CSI plan approval process begins during the development
through the meaningful stakeholder engagement
and approval of the local governing boards.
Once the plan is approved,
implementation of the plan can begin.
The LEA and school work together
to continuously monitor and evaluate the implementation
and effectiveness of the plan.
This sample timeline is an example of the guidance
that the CDE has provided to the field
to help map out when CSI activities could be happening.
So I have talked a lot about the roles and responsibilities
of the counties and LEAs to support their CSI schools
as continuous improvement process.
The CDE also plays a critical role in leadership
to our county offices and LEAs.
So the school improvement and support office,
which is in our division and led by my colleague,
Lori Marshall is the key connection point
for all CSI schools, LEAs and county offices.
This is a small sample of the high quality coaching
and professional learning developments offerings
that are constantly being produced
and shared with the field.
And a more comprehensive list of their activities
is included in attachment two of this item
and shameless plug,
I encourage anyone who is watching this
to visit our CSI CDE webpage
and click on the technical assistance tab
to see a comprehensive list of resources and support.
And now I'd like to turn this over to our co-presenters.
So California's educational system is founded on the belief
that the LEA is the primary unit of change
and plays the central role in supporting schools
to implement and sustain improvement efforts.
California's diversity requires
a more than a one size fits all solution
to help LEAs and schools successfully implement
continuous improvement efforts
and meet the needs of all learners,
particularly those students most in need.
Although they will be differentiated to meet local needs
to the greatest extent possible,
all of California's supports and interventions
for schools and districts will be implemented
within the larger context
of our statewide system of support.
So it is my pleasure to now turn this presentation
over to our co-presenters.
First, we will hear a presentation from Laura Trahan,
Director of Education Services
from Marin County Office of Education,
and Tyler Graff, Director of Secondary Education
at San Rafael City Schools.
And then we will hear from San Diego County
Office of Education,
Steven Green, Senior Director of Assessment,
Accountability and Evaluation,
and Patricia Carlin,
Coordinator of State and Federal Programs.
And then we will hand it over to Laura and Tyler.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond and board members.
Thank you very much for having us today.
Tyler and I are pretty excited about this,
helping support this item,
and then also sort of showcasing the work
that our county does.
Lindsay, you're driving, correct?
Great, go ahead, forward to the next slide.
Just a little bit about Marin County.
We have approximately 35,000 plus students
across 18 districts
with a total of about four charter schools.
We have everything from a one-room schoolhouse
to a few K-8s to a larger
or a medium-sized unified school district.
So we have quite a variety in there.
What you're looking at here are the demographics
of our county.
San Rafael Schools is one of our larger districts
as compared to the rest of our districts.
It's actually two districts combined.
So we have an elementary district
and a high school district
that operate as San Rafael City Schools
for a little over 7,000 students
with eight elementary schools, three high schools,
and one of those high schools is an alternative school.
That's Madrone, and that's the campus
that we'll be talking about today.
The demographics of our county are listed here.
San Rafael Elementary and high school districts,
they follow a similar pattern as the county,
but they have a slightly higher percentage
of Hispanic and Latino students
in comparison to their white students.
Next slide.
So what you're looking at here is a graphic
or a schematic that, excuse me, that we created.
And it really just sort of encompasses everything
that our county office is trying to do
as a system of support based upon what was established
with the Department of Education.
So you'll see the level one,
level two, level three supports over there.
And then we sort of just established a way
in which we try and meet and greet those
as we work with the district.
So everything we do right now is built upon relationships.
Our teams that we put together for all of our work
are multidisciplinary as much as possible.
So, excuse me, they'll frequently include curriculum
and instruction, business, special education as appropriate,
and also sometimes our self-elites as well.
So as Lindsay mentioned, we have Tyler here today,
and he's gonna co-present and give us a little bit
of insight on what it feels like, I guess,
to be the recipient of a support.
I think as a county office, our responsibility
is to use the metaphors to teach them how to fish
so that our role is extended
and I guess work ourselves out of a job to a certain extent
as it pertains to allowing them to be independent
and doing their work.
They know their kids, they know their districts.
Our job is just to be there to support
and provide additional wheels on their wagon, if you will.
So as it's listed here, we have heavy reliance
on district collaboration.
We plan everything together in our comprehensive support
as well as in our differentiated assistance cycle.
We are, again, a provision of additional support
and we try as much as possible to use existing structures
for any work that we do together,
not adding additional meetings, et cetera.
Okay, next slide, Tyler.
All right, good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond
and board members.
It's an absolute pleasure to be here
to talk a little bit about our collaboration
with Marin County Office of Education.
On this side, you can kind of see that,
you know, there's two district model.
We have one board that kind of oversees
and one district office that oversees
both of these districts and you can see
that both the elementary and high school districts
had qualified for differentiated assistance in 2018, 2019.
And then the elementary district kind of worked itself
out of differentiated assistance in that 19-20 year
where the high school districts still had some work to do.
Just for context, that elementary district is really,
it's a K-8 district and, you know, that's part of,
they weren't deep into differentiated assistance there.
So to get them out wasn't quite as a big of a lift
as the high school district was.
Next slide.
But just really quickly, if I could add,
the whole point of starting you
with differentiated assistance is,
in order for you to really get an understanding
about the CSI work, we had to pull way back up
because this is not siloed work.
This is about looking deep at a system
and the order to look deep at a system,
we really had to go all the way back and look,
wow, we have some things that are definitely showing up.
I almost added a slide on this particular item,
which was their dashboard slide,
where you're definitely seeing
why they were in differentiated assistance
and what you're not seeing are the edges
of why they were in differentiated assistance.
So there's some strong orange markers, if you will,
to use the color terminology.
So we wanted to just make sure
we gave you a really clear picture,
not only about our work,
but about the need to look at this systemically.
Okay, next slide.
Great, and that's kind of where I was gonna talk here,
the CSI and ATSI.
You can see that CSI was really for our alternative program
and then ATSI for Davidson in that 18-19 year,
which is our middle school,
and then our two comprehensive high schools in 19-20.
And kind of to build on what Laura just said,
Madrone is a unique school
because it's only 11th and 12th grade,
and our system creates that school, right?
So the outcomes that our system is gonna produce
will manifest itself at Madrone High School.
So when we look at Madrone High School
and we see a disproportionate number of Latinx students,
we have to take a look at the whole system,
not just Madrone High School.
We have to take a look at
what our comprehensive high schools are doing,
and all the way down to our pre-K and TK programs.
How are we, what early intervention programs
are we getting in front of our smallest students
so they're not long-term English learners,
feel disaffected with school,
and end up at a school like Madrone
where we have to give additional support there.
Laura, you wanna add anything to that one?
Thank you.
Okay.
And then this slide just kind of talks a little bit about
the collaboration and the roles here.
Let's see here.
So we have, we tried to use the existing structure,
so we didn't wanna have additional meetings,
and we know a number of districts
are strapped for time as it is,
so we wanted to do that as cohesively as possible.
One of the things our board and our superintendent
really value stakeholder engagement,
so we did lots of equity interviews with our students.
We brought in our DLAC parents.
We had a lot of our CBOs from San Rafael City
just kind of come in and give us feedback.
And then obviously having quite a bit of support from MCOE
as well.
Just to add, we combined the district
and to do the DA process and deliberately
the superintendent and Tyler and his amazing staff
insisted on the Madrone staff,
as well as the high school staff
being part of the differentiated assistance team,
knowing that this was all going to cycle into work
that was gonna be at the school site.
Great, and here's a little bit about the roles
and responsibilities.
Obviously, it's a collaborative experience
working with Marin County Office of Education,
and there's kind of distinct roles
that each of one of us plays.
So I think from a district perspective,
a couple of things that were a big highlight
was that I was able to kind of collaborate
with an MCOE support person
to design the agendas for the meetings.
So that helped us with stakeholder engagement,
helped us with needs assessments.
So we were kind of doing the driving,
but MCOE was helping on the front end
for designing some of those meetings
and then on the back end for reflection.
It was really helpful to learn more about
kind of from a third party,
what we could have done better in those meetings.
Yeah, and we used really a strong science
and improvement backbone through all of that.
So while each district or school that we work with
is unique, the system or the process that we follow
to get them to the areas they need to go to
is fairly consistent.
But the district really embraced this work deeply.
And then this is just a broader context
of where the school district is.
So we have differentiated systems going on,
we have CSI going on.
But then our newer superintendent
is actually taking us through a together 2023 process,
which is kind of a revisioning of the school,
a new strategic plan for the school or for the district.
And a big part of that is an equity audit
that we did with Ed Trust West,
just taking a look at how students
are getting access to AP courses,
how are we getting students out of EL programs
when they have been able to qualify
to join the general ed program.
And all of that is kind of weaving into the LCAP.
And one of the highlights for me is that
through the Ed Trust West equity audit
and our together 2023 process,
we've had extensive stakeholder input
and essentially have a draft of what will be our LCAP
for the next three years.
So when we get to the LCAP writing process,
we kind of have most of it done, which is really nice.
Okay, slide 10 is really about
the plan for Madrone High School.
And when we took a look at the data,
what we found is that a school like Madrone
where it's an alternative program,
really school has been the traumatizer in a lot of ways.
So it's not necessarily the home life.
Sometimes these students come to school
and that's where they're experiencing trauma.
So we wanted to focus on culture and climate.
A lot of the data that we saw around engagement,
around attendance and graduation really highlighted
that kids needed to feel loved and cared for
in a school climate.
So that was a huge part of the kind of focus there.
So things like restorative practices,
capturing kids' hearts was another big initiative
that the principal focused on.
We got a school to career liaison
to kind of help kids connect to post-graduate
or post-graduation type work.
The school also did a really nice three-day workshop
to kind of re-envision the school
talk a little bit more about how students engage
with the curriculum,
really focusing in on that instructional core,
how kids feel when they walk into the building.
That was all really important.
And then there was another thing that they focus on.
They noticed that there were about 14 kids
at the end of last year that were not on path to graduate.
And we did a really nice targeted summer school program.
They got nine of those 14 kids to graduate.
And that resulted in actually our alternative school
being the only school,
only high school that increased its graduation rate
last year.
So this really targeted approach was very helpful.
And then the superintendent was really helpful
in kind of loosening some strings
in order to change staffing around.
What we know about good teaching and learning
is that a high quality teacher matters a lot.
And if we don't have our highest quality teachers
in front of our most needy students,
we need to make changes.
And our superintendent was bold enough
to be able to make some of those changes.
Okay.
Excellent.
So again, our whole process in summary,
this is kind of a summary slide here,
is really that this is a system support process
that looked at engagement at all levels.
It's fully encompassing.
And everything that we need to do is all,
I hate to use the word equity lens
because that implies that it's just kind of like this,
it's more like a blanket, if you will.
We really had to look at every single child
with the district.
They were fortunate enough
to have all of those really great equity audit.
And a lot of the slides you saw
were the actual data sessions that they held with us,
with educators, with kids.
And really, honestly, I think one of the biggest pieces
they got out of this process is number one,
they're addressing the needs on the day to day,
despite COVID with Madrone,
but they got to see that this is a process,
and this is not necessarily a process that ends.
It's a process that continues to circle on itself.
And they're having to use,
because of the size of the school,
but also because of the time that they're in,
they're having to use kind of alternative means
to measure their success.
So they can't necessarily rely upon
standardized test scores, et cetera.
So it's a nice time for educators
to really look at being flexible
and really look at what student needs are.
The only thing I'd add there, Laura,
is it was a little unfortunate
that we focused on culture and climate,
and then a handful of months later told kids
you can't come back to school,
because you can't really focus on culture and climate
when there aren't students in the building.
So that was one of the things
we're really eager to get students back.
Our district is right on the precipice of having an MOU
with our high school district
to get those students back into school.
And we're really hoping that we can refocus on that
and continue to use those equity interviews
that we did with students to understand better
where we're winning and improving the school culture
and where the adults need to shift
to make it a more welcoming environment for those kids.
Yeah, and you're scoring the equity interviews
with the students.
That's a startling process to go through.
It's quite lovely and interesting.
Okay, again, this is our system of support structure
that we established and we're in.
And thank you very much for having us.
It's been a pleasure to support this presentation.
Thank you, Lindsay, for having us.
Terrific.
And Lindsay, do you have anything else before we go?
We're gonna now pass on to Stephen Green and Patty Carlin
from San Diego County Office of Education.
Good afternoon, President.
I'm Darling Hammond and members of the board.
Thank you for this opportunity for us to share
how we are supporting our local LEAs
and eligible schools in San Diego County.
I'm Stephen Green, Senior Director
for our Assessment, Accountability,
and Program Evaluation Team.
And with me today is Patricia Carlin,
who is our Coordinator of State and Federal Programs.
We will co-present and give you a high-level overview
of our process in supporting our CSI schools
and the districts as part of our system of support.
I also wanted to shout out to Antonio Mora,
who's our District Advisor,
who's a key component of our team
but not joining us today in this presentation.
So with that, I'm gonna hand off to Patty,
or excuse me, not quite yet, I apologize.
I'm gonna do this slide real quickly.
This is just a high-level overview of the process
and the key point I wanna make here is
once the districts and schools are identified
and we know who is eligible for support,
we mobilize pretty quickly around two levels
of intervention, if you will, that we provide.
One is what we consider foundational support or tier one,
which is support for all eligible schools and their LEAs.
And that's really the technical assistance component.
Patty will break that down in a moment
and go into more specificity.
And then there's another level, a higher level of support,
which is deeper learning and work,
similar to what you heard from the San Rafael team
and Marin County Office of Ed,
which is the deeper learning and the ongoing improvement
in implementation work.
And I'll be speaking to that in more detail after Patty.
So with that, I'm gonna hand off to Patty
and she'll talk about our timeline
and how we engage our LEAs.
Thank you, Steve, and good afternoon,
President Darling-Hammond and members of the board.
So what you can see in front of you is this timeline
of really how we rolled things out
with the 2019 eligibility determination for CSI schools,
which did happen with that fall dashboard
that we had in the November, December of 2019.
And then once the schools were officially announced
and then kind of the grant process started,
then we would work in with our orientation workshops,
usually around February or so.
And then we have a four series workshop series,
sorry, series that we put together for the 29 LEAs
that we do have in San Diego County.
What we're trying to do is build that capacity
of those LEAs to support their schools.
Of those LEAs, 16 are districts and 13 are charters.
Additionally, just kind of on a funny aside,
our very first workshop that we were going
to be doing face to face again was on March 13th.
And so that became the first ever Zoom workshop,
I think that we produced for San Diego County Office
of Education during this time.
So on the next slide, I will be talking
about just the overall of our foundational support model.
And as Lindsay had mentioned, there are the areas
that are required within the CSI plan,
but you're talking about needs assessment,
data analysis, your cause analysis,
the use of evidence-based interventions,
monitoring and evaluation of the plan.
Those are all actually requirements
within Title I plans in general.
And when we think about that,
that's just good strategic planning.
But those are the main core pieces of the requirements
for the CSI planning.
In addition to that, then there would be the identification
of resource inequities.
So we put our workshop series together,
this was originally put together kind of that building
the plane as we're flying it analogy in 2019
when this first all rolled out.
But one of the things, a couple of the things that we do
beyond let's say just those requirements within the plan
is talking about how districts and schools and charters
would do that alignment of their plan.
So the CPSA aligning back up to the LCAP at the time
or this year we pivoted and we helped align it to their LCP.
So making sure that there is a strong alignment
between the plans that guide schools
and the plans that guide the districts.
And then we pushed further from that
with the first steps in implementation.
And when Steve picks up on the next slide,
he'll talk a little bit further about that.
But one of the things that we did after all of this
was then we gave specialized trainings
maybe around schools like councils
for maybe for charter schools or alternative schools
that had not had school set councils before.
We gave more in depth LCP alignment workshops.
And additionally, as part of the system of support
in our region and with our Southern California region
including Riverside, San Bernardino,
Imperial and Orange counties,
we've been working together all of our counties
over the past year in supporting CSI schools
and then providing workshops just for,
let's say schools that are in an alternative setting
to see how to make these plans and CSI work in their world.
So we really have pushed further
in just giving the general overview
by putting things into a perspective
to support the variety of schools that we have
that are CSI within our county and within our region.
So I will let Steve take it away from here.
Thank you, Patty.
And as I said in our opening,
we have two levels of support.
So that foundational or tier one is available to all
that's free of charge, that's work that we do
that we see as our role as a county office.
We do offer and we saw the need right away within schools
similar to the support offered
through differentiated assistance
where oftentimes the tier one level of support
may not be sufficient for the types of needs
or the equity issues that may exist
within school systems or LEAs.
And what we did then is we reached out to partners
in the educational space that are engaged in this work.
One example here is our partnership with West Ed.
Through the San Francisco office and their improvement team,
we have joined forces and provide as an option
for CSI eligible schools
and their central office partners,
ongoing one year or 16 months series of deep learning
and all focused on developing
high quality implementation plans,
which is ultimately the SPSAs, the CPSAs,
but how those are aligned to the specific needs
that exist within the system
and the reason for which they were eligible for CSI support.
And that work is designed to build the capacity
to use improvement science tools
and ultimately move into deep implementation
of their evidence-based interventions
as it relates to their areas of needs
within their local context.
The model that we employ in this deeper learning work
is a model around improvement cohorts.
The focus initially is on strategic planning
and I'll get into more specific around that
on the next slide.
Our model consists of embedded professional learning
as well as coaching support for continuous improvement
and then the third prong here is how do you develop
the school site leadership's teams capacity
and the central office together, right?
And we heard in the previous presentation
and even in Lindsay's opening
that the notion around alignment
and the importance of how the school's planning
and the processes and their priorities
and their initiatives, how do those nest within the LCAP
and the district's overarching vision and equity focus?
And so we try very hard not to have within systems
multiple different plans that might be leading folks
in different directions.
So we really try to, throughout this deeper learning work
in all of our work, but in particular this work,
to align initiatives and priorities and braid them
so that they're in support of one another
and not becoming obstacles.
Next slide, please.
So the components of this deeper learning work
and ongoing continuous improvement has,
I'm gonna address five components here.
Number one, the structured professional learning series.
This is where we do deeper work with our WestEd partners
and other partners that we might engage
in the professional learning.
So we are teaching the principles of improvement science,
bringing in implementation science notions as well,
focusing on how to conduct root cause,
thinking about robust needs assessment,
how do we identify those resource inequities
that exist within the system.
And these are structured in our first cohort model
when we were not in a virtual space,
these would be all day sessions
where there'd be about a half day of content
and then within that day planning time
for the individual school teams
with their district partners.
Now we transition into doing it in a virtual space
and we're conducting these in shorter chunks of time,
more like two or two and a half hour sessions
with a little more frequency.
Following each professional learning opportunity,
there are what we call action periods.
This is where the school level teams
and their district partners are going back into the field
and potentially maybe doing conducting things
like empathy interviews or collecting additional data.
But it's all predicated on the work that was done
in the professional learning session
and the action planning that occurred.
And then this is where the school level work is happening,
right, those next steps,
whether it's around getting more information
or beginning to test out ideas,
professional development that might be happening
for the staff and so on.
During those action periods,
we don't leave it just up to the schools or the districts,
they're not on their own.
We have a coaching support cycle
where during the action periods,
we reach out on an every other week basis
and conduct a one hour coaching session
with the school team and their district sponsor
so that we're getting a sense of how it's working for them,
where are they encountering challenges,
where might they need some support or thought partnering
and obviously to share their successes too, right?
We're not presuming that things are not going well,
but we want to be there to help drive the work
and ensure that their needs are met
and if needed, additional support could be leveraged
on our behalf or on West Ed's behalf
depending upon what's needed in that local context.
Another component is the plan to study act cycle.
So we've mentioned the improvement work we heard
in the previous presentation
of the principles of improvement science.
So our schools do take on change ideas.
They vet these by trying them out
and testing different approaches,
determining what works and in many ways,
this mirrors the differentiated assistance process.
We just think about it scaled down to the school level.
Could even be within a three level team
or within a department, a content area,
again, depending what the need is
and how the school was eligible for the support
and the focus areas that they're digging into,
whether it's around specific student groups
or whatever it might be.
And all of that then is in service
of building out a strong implementation plan
so that over time, this plan that the work
that they engaged in doesn't become short term
and in the next year, they move on to something else.
We have a recognition that from a strategic planning
and from an improvement perspective,
that this needs to be deep, ongoing, sustainable work
and have to build capacity for the folks to do that work.
So our focus in the deeper learning
is truly around not just technical assistance,
but going deep and ensuring that what is taken on
gets implemented, implemented over time
and adjusted as needed so that the monitoring,
the evaluation of the effectiveness
and those other components come in
during that implementation phase.
And we, with our West End partners,
are supporting the schools and the districts
in building their expertise and their knowledge
and practice around ongoing monitoring and evaluation.
So with that, I think we have one more slide.
We don't have our district partners with us today,
but we do have a couple of testimonials.
This first one is from Brian Sheehy,
who's the project director
for King Chavez Neighborhood of Schools.
We work both with charter schools
and schools within our typical LEAs.
And I don't want to read this to you,
but Brian is basically expressing the impact of the work,
not only having content experts at the table,
such as those folks from West End,
but we plug them into additional resources
that may be needed based on their local context
and their area of focus.
And ensuring what I appreciate in this statement
is developing the engaging
and relevant professional development.
We cater to the needs of the local context.
So we're working around their areas
where they need support,
where the needs assessment has driven the work,
and ensuring that they own the work
and that we are there in support.
And so the building of those relationships,
as we heard earlier, is critical,
and we don't want them to feel
like we're doing this to them.
It is their work, and we're in support of their work.
And our next testimonial we're excited about,
we signed on with San Diego Unified,
so this is a quote from Rebecca Penn.
In terms of what they're hoping to get,
we just had our kind of an initial launch
with the district central office team last week
to start to outline the work.
But really, again, what you see here
is the notion around aligning school level work
with the larger district work
and the focus of equity and the LCAP,
strengthening needs assessment processes
at the school level,
developing collaborative structures
for testing out ideas and designing interventions,
and the other bullet there around system mapping.
As you can imagine, in a larger system
like San Diego Unified, there are a lot of moving parts
and a lot of moving pieces,
so the central office team is really looking forward
to unpacking that,
it's more thinking about the schools
that are eligible for the support
and how can they streamline and map things together
so that they don't feel like a buffet
of many different things that happen,
but that it is a well planned out
and well thought out strategic effort of improvement.
So I thank you for your time.
I know you've had a long day
and you're probably two or three hours behind,
but thank you for this opportunity to share,
and yeah, we're proud of our work
and happy to be in support of our students
in San Diego County.
Thank you.
Well, thank you, Laura, Tyler, Stephen, and Patricia.
So to wrap up this presentation portion of this item,
the CD recommends that the State Board of Education
take action to approve the CSI plans
for the 2020-21 school year,
including attachment one and the addendum of this item.
Terrific, thank you, and it's really nice to hear
about the ways in which this process is supportive
and feeling helpful and useful
to the schools that are a part of it.
At this point, we want to open up the phone line
for public comment queue,
and put the public comments slide up if we could.
Thank you.
Members of the public wishing to provide public comment
can do so by calling this number
and entering the access code shown here.
And while we're waiting for members of the public
to call in, I want to first ask Member Burr
and Vice President Strauss
if they have any initial comments.
Well, I'll start and then leave most of the comments
to Eileen, because this is so near and dear
her heart and her work.
I'll just say that I both really appreciate
Lindsay's comprehensive overview
of what this process looks like at the state level,
but especially appreciate hearing
from our County Offices of Education,
who, as you know, are our key partners
in implementing this work at the local level.
I think both Marin and San Diego provided
really good illustrations really of how in touch they are
with their schools and their communities
and how they leverage that and providing the assistance
that those LEAs and schools need.
So I'll stop with that and just say
I support the recommendation
and look forward to hearing from Eileen.
Great.
Oh, thank you.
So let me just say to Lindsay
and the entire team from Marin and San Diego,
what I appreciate about the presentation
is we're looking at policy to practice.
So what is our policy and how does it roll out
to the counties who support us, who said,
and then to the districts who receive the implementation.
And so what I think the presentation did
was help add some details to what the structure is
and particularly highlighting how important
is the context for the local school matters.
So particularly in the San Rafael situation
where it's an alternative school setting,
with the first example,
and what the difference is for the students
who end up in alternative ed
as a result of a system that structures.
So I so appreciated the understanding about context
and about the issue of the equity lens
and the equity audit,
particularly interviews with students,
because I think what we've learned
is if you listen to students and talk with them,
you really gain a deeper knowledge
about how the system is really impacting them
and how it impacts them as they engage
with our system as well.
I do think the coaching support that was highlighted
in the San Diego plan was really helpful.
I would just say as someone who's involved in working
and coaching with districts and schools,
I think we do lay out a foundation first
through improvement science, through continuous improvement.
But as you coach and differentiate for the local sites
and the leaders who are at those sites,
that's where you get the specific support
and strategic intervention.
And so again, I support the recommendations,
but particularly appreciate the entire team approach
for what does our system of support look like?
What's the role of the county office?
What's the role of the district?
And how does it impact the school,
both the leaders at the school
and the teachers at the school?
So again, I think we saw some really specifics
and I look forward to hearing the comments
from the public and from board members.
Thank you.
Terrific.
Are there any clarifying questions
on the specific facts that were presented?
We'll come back to the board for discussion
after public comment.
Seeing no hands on that,
let's go to public comment if we have some.
Okay, there are a few callers in the queue
for item number five.
I will open the phone line now.
Good afternoon, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Yes, good afternoon.
Elizabeth Guian with Public Advocates
and for the LCFS Equity Coalition.
We complained last year about this process.
We believe that federal law requires the board
to approve these plans with a much higher expectation
than the tiered box checking that is currently happening.
We would like to see a future agenda item
to really discuss how the system of support
is meeting this obligation to our needy of students.
The notion that schools are a traumatizer
is unfortunately very true for our struggling communities.
All one needs to do is try and participate
in a school site CPSA process
and then try to align it with the district's LCAP.
We appreciate the commitment shared by Lindsay
and her colleagues from the county offices
and we agree with the alignment of ESSA requirements
to the one LCAP planning process,
but teaching someone to fish looks very different
when the reality is between fishing in a stagnant pond
versus fishing in a healthy, free-flowing river
and the fishing guides are committed to meaningful improvement.
It appears that Marin County has only CSI schools.
Compare that to 136 in LA County.
Time.
We think that that...
Thank you, caller.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
My name is Lexi Lopez on behalf of Ed Voice.
First, we wanted to extend our congratulations
to our re-elected board president, Darlene Hammond,
and vice president Strauss.
As is expressed in the Alliance for Students' Letter,
our coalition strongly urges the board
to direct the department to pursue a more thorough review
of the CSI plans and to administratively strengthen
the guidance to the COEs to use in their approval process
for this portion of the LCAPs.
If necessary, the department and the board
should pursue a legislative budget change proposal
to redirect state set-aside funds
to ensure that this important oversight
and analysis actually takes place.
Furthermore, we request a further agenda item
to discuss how the system of support
is meeting the federal education obligation
to our neediest students.
Thank you for the opportunity to comment.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
Jessica Sacco on behalf of Children Now.
I'm affirming our alignment with the concerns
and requests outlined in the LCFF coalition letter
on this item.
I really appreciate the presentation today
that outlined the process at the state level
as well as the two guest presentations
from Marin and San Diego,
which helped shed a light on this process,
at least as it's taking place
in two counties of our 58 counties.
In the end, my comments are very similar
to the prior speaker.
We urge the board to pursue a more direct review
of the CSI plans and also to administratively strengthen
the guidance to county offices
to use in their approval process
for the CSI portion of the LCAP.
And in addition, we request a future agenda item
to discuss how the system to support
is meeting its federal obligations under ESSA
in order to serve our most needed students.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for item number five.
All right, given that there's no more public comment,
we will open for board discussions.
Please raise your hand in the participant menu
if you would like to make a comment or have a question.
All right, seeing none, I will see if there is a motion.
I would like to make a motion
to approve the department recommendation
to approve the CSI plans for 2021.
Do I have a second?
I second it.
All right, any further discussion?
All in favor of the motion, say it.
Oh, we need to do a roll call.
Brooks, can you do the roll call?
Of course.
Member Son.
Aye.
Vice President Strauss.
Member Rucker.
Aye.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Patil-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Navo.
Aye.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Glover-Woods.
Aye.
Member Fatah.
President Darlene Hammond.
Aye.
Member Burr.
That's unanimous.
All right, thank you.
And I just want to thank our staff at the board
and members of the county offices and schools who spoke,
but also the folks from the LCFF coalition
and others who offered public comment
and who will take under advisement the opportunity
to have a deeper discussion about these plans.
Thank you.
At this point, I think we should go ahead
and give ourselves a little break
because the next item is a long one.
So I have 1.57.
Let's give ourselves a 13 minute break
and come back at 2.10 and we'll see you then.
Get some coffee or whatever you need.
Don't forget to turn off your sound and video,
but don't leave the virtual.
Back.
We are gonna move on to agenda item number six,
which is the Comprehensive Literacy State Development Grant,
the State Literacy Plan Draft Review,
and the CDE recommends that the state board.
I'm very sorry. Yes.
We just need to reestablish a quorum.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Please reestablish a quorum.
Yes.
Member Sun.
Here.
Vice President Strauss.
Member Rucker.
Here.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Patil Brownson.
Here.
Member Navo.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Glover-Woods.
Member Fatah.
Here.
President Darlene Hammond.
Member Burr.
Here.
Everyone's present?
Quorum's established.
All right.
So we're gonna move on to agenda item number six,
in which the CDE recommends the state board review
the draft state literacy plan and provide feedback.
This is not an action item, it's an information item.
The draft state literacy plan is available
on the CDE webpage, and you have that link there.
This item will be presented by Barbara Murchison of the CDE.
Barbara, please begin.
All right.
Thanks, everyone.
Good afternoon, President Darlene Hammond,
Chief Deputy Gregson, board members.
I'm Barbara Murchison,
Director of the Educator Excellence and Equity Division
here at the CDE.
Today, it is my pleasure to present to you for feedback,
the draft of California's Comprehensive State Literacy Plan.
Before I get started,
I just feel like I need to recognize all of our colleagues
who are in classrooms right now,
because setting up this technology
to be able to do this with multiple laptops
and iPads and lights, it's a lot.
So kudos to them who have been figuring,
who have done this since last March.
And also I wanna apologize in advance for leaf blowers,
dog behaviors.
Who knows what's gonna happen during this presentation.
Thanks for your patience.
So as President Darlene Hammond noted,
we are not asking you to approve this plan today.
Today, we are seeking your feedback.
I'm gonna provide an overview of the plan
and share some information around why
and how we've developed it.
And we intend to bring this plan back to you for approval
at your next meeting in March.
So California applied
for the Federal Comprehensive Literacy State Development Grant
back in June, 2019,
and was awarded about 37 and a half million dollars
in September of 2019.
The primary goal of this federal grant program
is to improve literacy instruction for children and youth
age birth through grade 12.
As part of this program,
states are asked to develop, revise,
or update their comprehensive literacy plans.
The program also allows states
to provide targeted subgrants
to local educational agencies or LEAs
to implement evidence-based programs
to ensure high quality literacy instruction.
California's proposal was ratified by the board
back on consent back in July, 2019,
but that was a while ago.
So I'll review our three main objectives
in the proposal now.
First, we propose to build state capacity
to support evidence-based literacy instruction
by establishing dedicated staff positions within the CDE
to lead our coordinated effort to build state
and local capacity over the life of the project.
These staff have established and maintained structures
to support ongoing collaboration and information sharing
around many efforts to support student literacy.
First, as you can imagine,
there are many people at the CDE
beyond the educator excellence and equity division
who are working to support student literacy
in offices and divisions all across the department.
So we've established monthly literacy round tables
to bring all interested department staff together
to share updates and identify areas
of potential collaboration
around the various literacy initiatives we support.
We also meet monthly with our key partners
to share updates and ideas
around how we can advance student literacy achievement.
Our partners for the purposes of this grant
are the California Subject Matter Project,
the California County Superintendents
Educational Services Association,
the Region 15 Comprehensive Center at West Ed,
and First Five California.
So I wanna take a minute before I get too far ahead of myself
to thank all of those CDE colleagues
and our key partners who over the past year
have provided feedback on drafts of the plan
and helped us think through challenges,
celebrate successes, and really just get the word out
when the plan was available for public comment
so they can engage all of their members and stakeholders.
The CDE staff supporting the literacy grant work
are gonna have an even greater role
in coordinating the work of the subgrantees for this grant
once we move to that stage of implementation
later this year.
Second, we propose to develop and implement
an evidence-based comprehensive state literacy plan
that aligns and integrates state literacy initiatives,
content standards, and state guidance documents
to support teachers supporting children and students
from birth to grade 12.
And that plan will be the focus of our time together today.
Third, we propose to build local capacity
to establish, align, and implement
local literacy initiatives
that emphasize family and community involvement
to address the needs of California's
most vulnerable children.
95% of these literacy grant funds
will be subgranted to LEAs.
I'll talk a little bit more about those subgrants
and how the plan will guide them later in this presentation.
But before going into additional detail
about the plan itself,
I'd like to acknowledge the team
that helped the CDE develop
the Statewide Comprehensive Literacy Needs Assessment,
which served as the foundation to the literacy plan.
So even before this funding opportunity was announced
by the United States Department of Education,
the CDE was starting to think about
how we could get an assessment together
that would allow us to complete the plan
and submit a competitive application for this program.
And part of that is really taking stock
of how literacy instruction was happening in California.
So that needs assessment was developed by the CDE
in consultation with the American Institutes for Research
and the Region 15 Comprehensive Center.
And as part of the development process,
the CDE sought input from a group of stakeholders
with expertise in literacy
before we disseminated the assessment to LEAs
in December 2019.
With the help of our colleagues
at the Region 15 Comprehensive Center,
this group of individuals, our needs assessment team,
convened formally in February 2020 to analyze the data
and provide recommendations to the plan
based on the results of the needs assessment.
So the state literacy team,
we already had a robust set of data
around the status of literacy instruction
and how things were going with that around the state
before we even convened the state literacy team.
At that same time,
we were assembling a state literacy team.
So this group of knowledgeable
and exceptionally generous individuals
has played a critical role in our work
to develop this literacy plan
into the document that you have before you now.
In early January 2020,
it's about a year ago from now,
the CDE disseminated a statewide call for applications
for this state literacy team.
We received 130 applications
and they were scored by volunteers
from the CDE literacy roundtables.
The group used a very detailed rubric
designed to identify a team of individuals
from across all geographic areas of California
with a range of literacy expertise
from birth through grade 12.
This process helped to ensure a diverse team
with additional expertise
related to special student populations
in all representing a very broad range
of California's diverse student populations.
Ultimately, a group of 35 individuals
was selected to serve on this team.
I should note that membership spans
the California education system,
including teachers, school district
and county office leaders,
and multiple representatives
with deep literacy expertise from higher education.
Additionally, one member each
from the state board of education,
the commission on teacher credentialing
and the California collaborative for educational excellence
were included on the state policy on the team
so that the state policy perspective
is well represented there as well.
A complete list of team members
is available on the CDE State Literacy Plan Team webpage.
So yes, they're a very impressive bunch.
So here we are, we have this amazing state literacy team.
We have a first skeletal draft of a plan
that's ready for feedback.
We have lots of data
because we've got this state needs assessment
and we've put together all the CASP data
and the DRDP data and everything's ready to go.
We've got recommendations from the needs assessment team.
We have a robust set of evidence-based strategies
for the team to consider
and an agenda to bring everyone together
for what we know is gonna be a very busy two-day meeting
to work on the first draft of the plan
on March 23rd and 24th.
You see where this is going, right?
Travel arrangements are made.
The lunches are ordered.
The space is reserved.
So here is where I need to share my very deep gratitude
to all involved for their flexibility
for that first meeting.
Like everyone else in the education world,
around the world, CDE staff and our colleagues
at the Comprehensive Center had to turn on a dime
and rethink the entire meeting agenda
and how we could engage in deep conversations
around literacy with a relatively large group of people
in a virtual space.
So during the last 10 months or so,
we've all become pretty accustomed as of today
having relatively large meetings in virtual spaces.
But back in March 2020, that was a bit of a challenge.
That was really pushing the envelope.
I am pleased to say that despite
all of the challenges presented,
the meeting was extremely successful.
As you can see from the document,
the team engaged in an accelerated version
of the startup continuous improvement process
back in March,
discussing goals, reviewing the CASP data,
the DRDP data, the needs assessment data,
and evaluating evidence-based literacy strategies
to determine which ones might best be applied
to address the identified areas of need.
And here's a pandemic silver lining.
Initially, we'd intended to bring the plan
to the board for feedback in May 2020
and for approval in July 2020.
When that was not possible,
we negotiated with our colleagues
at the United States Department of Education
to revise our grant timeline.
And we provided an update around that shifted timeline
to you in an August 2020 memorandum.
And that gift of extra time provided us
with opportunities to gather
and incorporate substantive stakeholder feedback
and has resulted in a much stronger plan.
So there's a little silver lining.
Extended our timeline and we're able
to build a stronger plan with the extra time.
We took all of the team's input,
having had the timeline extended
and made considerable revisions to the draft.
We also worked with a small group
to draft the comprehensive and integrated literacy model
described at the start of the document.
And then in August, with our extra time,
we reconvened that literacy team for another two days
to gather feedback on the updated draft.
After the second meeting of the literacy team,
we made additional revisions based on their inputs
and then brought the plan
to the instructional quality commission
to get its feedback
and to open up a formal public comment period.
So again, these are things that we didn't build
into our first very accelerated timeline in our proposal
and being able to make this plan available
to the general public and have a formal public comment period
helps us to feel more comfortable
that we really have gotten good feedback from many more
than the people we had originally intended to share it with.
In November, 2020, we brought the public comment
and our recommended revisions to the plan
based on that comment to the IQC for approval.
The IQC approved our recommendations
and we updated the draft accordingly
and that version of the plan crafted over the course
of more than a year
and with input from hundreds of literacy experts
and other stakeholders from across the state
is what is before you today.
So I'd like to spend just a couple of minutes
just grounding us in the purpose of this document.
The purpose of the plan is stated in our proposal
and as we've worked through some of the issues
that have come up is really to align
and integrate state literacy initiatives, content standards
and state guidance documents to support teachers
of students from birth through grade 12.
So I should have said,
this is to align and integrate
existing state literacy initiatives.
The plan is not meant to establish new guidance
on literacy curriculum or instruction
because as you well know,
California already has formal, lengthy
and robust processes in place
to develop guidance on curriculum instruction.
And my understanding is that California's ELA ELD framework
will be updated relatively soon through that formal process.
The plan also does not contain any tools or templates.
These will be housed
in an online literacy resource repository
as they are identified or developed.
Okay, so we're creating a local literacy planning tool.
So this is definitely a state plan.
It is not an LEA plan.
We are in the process of creating
a local literacy planning tool
that will be aligned to this plan
so that LEAs can use that voluntarily.
This tool, once it's completed,
will be included in the repository.
The second purpose of the plan
is to support continuous improvement
of local literacy programs by bringing coherence
to the myriad of California documents,
initiatives and resources
to support comprehensive and integrated implementation
of high quality evidence-based literacy instruction.
The plan relies very heavily
on California's Common Core Standards
for English Language Arts and Literacy
and our groundbreaking 2014 ELA ELD curriculum framework
but it also organizes a variety
of other key documents and policies
such as the English Learn Roadmap
and the California Dyslexia Guidelines
into a comprehensive literacy framework.
And finally, the plan models
a continuous improvement process
aligned to the continuous improvement process
that districts identified for differentiated assistance
have been using to improve local outcomes.
Consistent with that continuous improvement model,
the plan reports and the state team examine
and made recommendations based upon
student literacy achievement data.
So with all of that in mind,
let's look at how the plan is organized
and how it's being used.
The plan is organized.
The state literacy team recommended
that we include an executive summary at the beginning
to provide a high level overview of what's in the plan.
The introduction includes background information
on the federal grant program,
the purpose and logic model,
a section on how to read the plan
and what each specific audience might find useful
and information on California's diverse student population.
Then we get into the body of the document,
the comprehensive and integrated literacy model
helps us to meet our purpose of aligning
and integrating state literacy resources and initiatives
in order to demonstrate how they're connected
and best utilized in a coherent way.
These resources are identified as defining
what best first instruction is,
or they're identified as supporting best first instruction.
I'm gonna talk about that a little bit more
in a couple of minutes.
The continuous improvement process section of the plan
goes through each step of the continuous improvement process
that the CDE and its statewide literacy partners
are using to assess statewide literacy needs
and develop plans to leverage the grant funds
to address those needs within three specific age grade bands,
birth to age five,
transitional kindergarten to grade five,
and grade six to 12.
I'll also provide a little more detail
about that section in a minute.
And then finally, the plan includes a work cited section
and a few appendices, including glossary, data tables,
and additional CASP results.
So now to provide a bit more detail,
I'd like to provide you with an overview
of the comprehensive and integrated literacy model.
As you are well aware,
California has many, many existing policies,
guidance documents, and structures
designed to improve literacy for all California students.
And while several investments and initiatives
have really focused on the implementation
of these documents,
the statewide needs assessment revealed
that many of our colleagues in the field
are challenged to understand how these resources
might complement one another.
How do they all work together
to really improve outcomes for kids?
The state plan gave us an opportunity
to align and integrate the resources
in order to demonstrate how they're connected
and can be used in a coherent way.
Since the focus of the federal grant
is improving instruction for students,
the Center of California's Comprehensive
and Integrated Literacy Model is best-first instruction,
which we believe is tier one
of the Multi-Tiered System of Support, or MTSS.
This is figure one in the draft plan,
which you can find on page 18 of the document,
it might look small where you're looking at it.
The California MTSS Model
is an integrated comprehensive framework
that focuses on content standards, core instruction,
differentiated learning, student-centered learning,
individualized student supports,
and the alignment of systems necessary
to support all students'
academic, behavioral, and social success.
California has invested about $45 million
into developing and implementing a California MTSS Model.
And thanks to the work of our colleagues
at the Orange County Department of Education
and Butte County Office of Education,
all 58 of our county offices
and more than 600 of our school districts
have received funding and training to implement this model.
So this approach should be very familiar
to most Californians.
So the figure shows the three tiers of MTSS
really highlighting tier one.
The goal of tier one is for all students
to receive high quality standards aligned instruction
using culturally and linguistically responsive teaching
that meets the full range of student needs.
You'll notice that the diagram
identifies several tier one state resources,
including all of the board adopted content standards,
including model school library standards,
all of the curriculum frameworks
and the early learning foundations,
and assessments and instructional resources.
Also in tier one are several key resources
developed by the CDE,
including the new Improving Education
for Multilingual and English Learner Students publication,
the Dyslexia Guidelines,
and the Practitioner's Guide
for Educating English Learners with Disabilities.
We're identifying all of these resources as tier one resources,
which means that all educators should be familiar
with the guidance found in these resources
because it applies to all students in all classrooms.
The plan then goes on to provide brief descriptions
of these state resources
and how they can be leveraged to meet literacy objectives.
Figure two builds upon figure one
and presents the entire comprehensive
and integrated literacy model.
You can find this model on page 34 of the draft document.
The model illustrates a system
or high quality literacy instruction
occurs within the context of inclusive
and equitable systems of schooling,
featuring high levels of engagement,
a focus on continuous improvement,
and application of the California MTSS framework.
The goal of the federal grant
is to improve literacy instruction.
So at the center of this model is figure one,
the MTSS and Best First Instruction Triangle.
And around this center are four important elements
necessary for supporting Best First Instruction.
So those are the quadrants,
celebration of diversity and an asset-based approach,
very important for California
and frankly, just very important for students,
teachers, and human beings.
Whole child, another very important orientation.
If we want learning to happen,
we need to take care of SEL, health, safety, nutrition.
Well-prepared and supported teachers and leaders.
You can see that in the third quadrant,
and then family and community engagement.
And I think the last 10 months
as we've moved through the pandemic response
have really highlighted the importance
of those four elements.
We have mapped key state level resources
to each of these elements
to help people understand how that fits together
and have also included the LCFF state priorities
throughout the elements to illustrate how these resources
can be leveraged by LEAs to meet the priorities
by the Local Control and Accountability Plan.
So I won't go into detail for the sake of time,
but we worked with a smallish group of folks
with deep expertise in each one of these elements
and MTSS to really think through
how might this all fit together?
Some of these resources span several quadrants.
So within the text of this section,
those connections are made.
It's very hard to sort things into buckets.
You know, there are always overlaps,
but we do try and highlight some of those connections
across the model in the narrative that follows,
further showing alignment and coherence.
The model presented in the plan
sets the direction for literacy programs statewide
by aligning and integrating state literacy initiatives.
It also sets the direction for the activities
outlined in the next section of the plan.
And at the local level,
we hope that the comprehensive and integrated literacy model
can support LEAs to consider the degree
to which literacy programs are leveraging
existing state guidance and resources
to help meet the specific needs of students.
So that's the first big part of the plan.
The next section of the plan details each step
of a continuous improvement process
that we use at the state level
in order to demonstrate how the CDE and its partners
assess literacy needs statewide and then develop plans
to leverage the grant funds to address those needs.
In this way, the plan models the process
that can serve as an example
for developing local literacy plan.
This section of the plan provides call-outs
in blue dotted line boxes with examples
for how LEAs can use the process to support literacy.
But I want to reiterate that the state plan before you
aims to serve as a model for how LEAs
might use a continuous improvement process.
Supporting districts to develop local literacy plans
is an objective deliverable of our federal grant,
but we do not intend for districts
to adapt this particular document
to create their own local literacy plans.
We are building out a tool that will have more detail
and more things that are relevant
to a district school level that LEAs will be able to use
to develop their own local literacy plans.
So step one is just setting direction and purpose.
We make it clear that the comprehensive
integrated literacy model sets the direction
for literacy programs statewide.
And you'll see excerpts from the early learning
and ELA ELD frameworks that highlight the literacy learning
that takes place in each of the age or grade bands.
Most importantly, this step establishes
that the goal of the plan is for our students
to meet grade level expectations set forth
in the common core state standards for ELA literacy,
and that the guidance in California's framework
be implemented well.
Step two is where we looked at the current outcomes
that the system is producing and try to determine causes.
Here you'll see current statewide literacy data
from the 2019 desired results developmental profile
for four-year-olds and the 2019 results
from the CASP ELA literacy assessment.
We also clarify how these results in other assessments
use different assessment cycles,
and that this is not all of the data that was
or should be considered in the process.
We need to look at complete dashboard data,
which includes English language proficiency growth
and student engagement and school climate measures.
The step also provides a review
of the comprehensive statewide literacy needs assessment
and describes the work of the state literacy team.
Step three captures much of the work
that we've been engaged in with the state literacy team,
who really worked hard to help us select
and prioritize strategies to address statewide literacy needs.
In this section of the plan,
one of these priorities are outlined for each age
or grade band with key state guidance
and resources highlighted to inform state level activities
that will be supported with grant funds
within the context of comprehensive
and integrated literacy instruction.
And I want to reiterate that the intent
is that we support comprehensive literacy instruction
that our subgrantees will work with districts and schools
to support comprehensive literacy instruction,
but we'll focus on one of these priorities,
though deeper in the priorities that are coming up.
The next few slides will summarize those.
So for birth through age five,
we landed on these two statewide literacy priorities
and 15% of the grant funds will fund
one county office of education
to support implementation of these priorities
within the context of comprehensive literacy instruction,
support early childhood education programs
to create literacy rich environments and experiences
and support the quality of early education programs
and their capacity to support early language
and literacy skills.
And they will also increase parenting support
by increasing parental knowledge, skills and confidence
through parenting curriculum and literacy activities
with special attention to access and equity for all.
For TK, transitional kindergarten through grade five,
the priorities that were identified,
build teacher capacity for tier one foundational skills
and reading comprehension,
including best first reading and writing instruction,
build school capacity for effective literacy
and English language instruction for ELs,
English learners, sorry, I don't like to say ELs,
including opportunities to develop by literacy
and primary language instruction wherever possible,
build school capacity to support students
struggling with reading, including but not limited
to students with disabilities and students with dyslexia
and increase sustainable high quality
professional learning systems,
including literacy coaching models.
And for students in grade six through grade 12,
the priorities established by the state literacy team
and in collaboration with the state literacy team
and CDE and various other folks,
build teacher capacity across disciplines
for literacy instruction,
increase asset-based teaching in schools,
including culturally and linguistically responsive
and sustaining pedagogies,
build school capacity for effective content,
academic content and literacy instruction
for English learners,
including opportunities to develop by literacy
and primary language instruction wherever possible
and build school capacity for effective literacy instruction
for students with disabilities.
Step three of the plan also lists and describes
the state level activities
to be funded through the grant program.
Subgrants to the local literacy lead agencies
will support the implementation and study
of evidence-based strategies
to address statewide literacy priorities
and support the literacy needs
of economically disadvantaged and high-need students.
We're proposing to award subgrants
to seven county offices of education
or consortia of county offices
to implement three-year small-scale pilots
with one or more local districts.
Consistent with federal requirements,
the birth to age five lead
will receive 15% of the funding.
The kindergarten to grade five
and transitional kindergarten to grade five leads,
there'll be three of them,
will receive 40% of the funding.
The grade six to grade 12 leads
will receive 40% of the funding,
and those percentages are just defined
in the grant program.
That's pretty exciting,
just to think about being able to fund
that zero to five grade band.
Typically, the opportunities that I've seen from ED,
I know our early learning and care folks
have all kinds of different opportunities,
but this is the first time, I think,
our division has been asked to look at
that really critical phase of literacy development.
So we anticipate that the request for application
for these subgrants will be released in spring of 2021,
shortly after the state literacy plan is approved.
I have staff starting to draft that already.
Additional state-level activities
include developing and providing
professional learning opportunities and resources
to support LEAs as they build capacity
and develop their local literacy plans.
Right now, the CDE is building
a literacy knowledge building series
in collaboration with members of the state literacy team
and other partners.
Yeah, I don't think anyone should go to the link
in this PowerPoint.
I don't think that's published yet.
I'm gonna bring it to share with you in March, though.
This series is a set of videos
with guidance on a variety of topics,
including, but not limited to,
these are the ones that are being built out right now,
but we will be working on this grant through 2024.
So I anticipate that this series
will be pretty impressive within the next year.
Right now, I find it impressive.
The topics that we're working on
are supporting students with dyslexia
and students who struggle to read,
intervention and coaching, very important,
particularly as we think about learning loss mitigation,
media literacy, literacy across the disciplines,
foundational skills and core literacy instruction,
culturally sustaining pedagogy,
using assessment to inform instruction,
early education strategies,
and family engagement strategies.
So remember before when I said
the state literacy team was exceptionally generous.
So the folks who are working with us
to build out this knowledge building series
is the state literacy team for the most part.
We've got some other partners as well.
So not only did they volunteer to assist us
with the development of the plan,
recall they thought they were gonna do
a two day meeting with us.
They've given us four full days of their time
and are continuing to volunteer
to help us build out this first set of resources.
So thank you so much, state literacy team.
You are amazing.
So in this knowledge building series,
we'll go a little deeper with the content in the plan
and make the content more practical
for teachers and leaders who are working
to improve literacy outcomes.
Again, the plan is kind of up at this level.
How do we enter great policy?
But we know the intent
is to really improve instruction in classrooms.
So these resources are being built
to help educators who are working very hard
to improve literacy outcomes, additional supports.
People will be able to access the information
when it is convenient for them
and can view these videos on their own,
but our intent is that the videos will be used
to support the work of professional learning communities
across the state as we all work
to improve student literacy achievement.
We are also building an online literacy resources repository
to house these resources, other existing literacy resources
and additional resources that will be developed
during the life of the grant.
And yes, that group of folks that I have just thanked,
the state literacy team,
they are currently working with CDE staff
to vet existing resources for inclusion in that repository.
So yes, they are amazing and great stuff is coming.
These projects are really starting to come together
and my hope is that I'll be able to give you
a bit of a tour on some of these new resources
when I next see you in March at your next meeting.
So back to the sections of the plan.
Step four is about how the CDE and its partners
will monitor and report on the work
over the course of the grant
with special attention to a variety of metrics.
The United States Department of Education
requires us to report on these metrics quarterly.
So we are keeping close track of them,
which is great to be able to have like
that systematic step four of implementing
and monitoring work and how it's going.
And step five, any good continuous improvement model.
We will revisit the plan over the course of the grant,
reflect on implementation and progress of the strategies,
determine any necessary course corrections
and consider sustaining and expanding successful models.
My deep down hope is that additional funding
for this program continues to become available
and as we learn from the first set of sub-grantees,
we will be able to fund additional sub-grantees
and expand our literacy efforts.
The CLSD grant program is an extension,
is the next iteration of the striving readers grant program,
which was going on for a while.
So the United States Department of Education
also prioritizes literacy instruction for our kids.
So I'm hopeful that this is just the start
of California's grant work.
So as you've heard throughout this presentation,
we have made an ongoing effort to ensure
that we have an abundance of stakeholder engagement
as we've developed the plan.
It's also very important to us to provide an opportunity
for the general public and advocacy organizations
to provide input on the plan.
So we were very thankful to be able to bring the document
to the IQC for that public comment period.
The public comment period also coincided
with several stakeholder group meetings,
which provided us an opportunity to seek additional feedback.
In the last few months of 2020,
we shared the draft plan
with the bilingual coordinators network,
the state and federal program directors,
and the advisory commission on special education
and encouraged them to both provide feedback
and to help us get the word out
so folks could participate in the public comment period.
We created a survey that allowed respondents
to submit comments via survey or email.
And for each one of those comments,
we asked for general information around
who was responding, comments on each of the sections
and asked for an overall evaluation of the plan.
In addition to overall edits,
the introduction comprehensive and integrated literacy model
and steps one to five
of the continuous improvement process sections of the plan
were revised based on all of that public comment.
Overall, we received a total of 347 unique comments
and we had a really good variety of respondents
from parents and guardians to teacher librarians
to administrators, community members
and teachers in the classroom.
In addition, we had many organizations representing hundreds
if not thousands of stakeholders
provide feedback on the draft plan.
Based on the comments received,
we highlighted several revisions to the plan
and presented them to the IQC at their November meeting
and upon their recommendation,
we incorporated these edits into the draft plan.
For example, pretty big oversight
is that we did not include
the California Model School Library standards
in the draft we first presented to the IQC,
which that was not good.
So fortunately, we had a lot of teacher librarians
who chimed in and said,
hey, how are you gonna have reading
without librarians and library standards?
And I'm like, oh yes, thank you, sorry.
So that was a big one,
incorporating the California Model School Library standards
and guidance regarding school libraries
and teacher librarians from the framework,
the ELAELD framework throughout the plan
because we really do know that the development
of a student's information literacy
and love for reading and achievement
in all content standards,
libraries and librarians are super important.
So again, apologies to the librarians for that oversight.
We also cited additional existing guidance
regarding biliteracy and primary language development,
including stronger language in the introduction
to make it clear that the plan aligns
with California's vision for language acquisition
that's promoted in the state's education
for a global economy initiative,
the California EL roadmap,
and the state seal of biliteracy.
So we really strengthen that language to make it clear
that that's the key focus of our work here in California.
And the original comprehensive
and integrated literacy model presented in the plan
lists the California,
listed the California Dyslexia Guidelines
and the California Practitioner's Guide
for Educating ELs with Disabilities.
As additional resources,
but based on the feedback we received,
we moved reference to them being additional resources
to communicate their equal importance
with the other listed tier one resources.
To make the document a little more user-friendly
and to provide clarity,
we included a glossary in the version.
The first draft that has a glossary
of frequently used terms and abbreviations,
which I think is just handy.
We included the Common Core in Espanol
and the Spanish language development standards
in this version to essential biliteracy program resources.
We also addressed the importance of collaboration
between early childhood education programs
and K-12 programs to provide a continuum
of literacy development.
And we included a broad definition of literacy
to address the abundance of information,
media and technology that's embedded into our daily lives.
Finally, we made more connections throughout the plan
among the content areas and literacy,
including references to the ELA, ELD frameworks,
snapshots and vignettes,
which illustrate how ELA, ELD
and content area instruction can be aligned.
So I just need to extend a huge thank you
to all of the individuals and organizations
who took some time.
It's been a busy year.
Anyone who made time during the last year
to provide feedback on this draft document,
a deep heartfelt thanks,
because it really has made this document stronger.
We appreciate your feedback.
So this is our current timeline
based on our year two,
we're in year two of our federal grant period.
Our intent is to hear feedback from you there.
There's January, 2021 right in the middle.
Our intent is to hear feedback from you
and public commenters today,
and then revise the draft plan to incorporate that feedback
and then bring the plan back to you for approval in March.
Shortly after that,
we hope to release the RFA for local literacy leads
and anticipate that the subgrants will be awarded
no later than September, 2021.
I would love to get the funding out sooner.
As you can imagine,
we were very excited to be awarded the grant back in 2019,
and we're even more excited
to be able to provide resources to LEAs
to support literacy instruction,
especially now as the state considers
learning loss mitigation strategies.
So again, as soon as we have the plan approved,
we want to get the funds out for the RFA,
make the RFA available as shortly after that as we can.
So here's some important links
for folks who wanna know more
about what's going on with this grant program.
There is a link
to the Comprehensive State Literacy Development webpage
and instructions for joining our listserv and an email.
clsdp at cde.ca.gov.
Someone is standing by to respond to any email inquiries.
So with all of that said, that was a lot.
Thank you for your patience.
The CDE recommends that the board review
the draft state literacy plan and provide feedback.
And of course,
I'd be happy to take any questions that you may have.
Thank you very much,
both for all the work that has gone on
over this last year and change
and for the very, very thorough presentation.
We want to display the public comment slide.
Thank you.
So that people can get into the queue.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so by calling the number on the slide
and entering the access code noted there.
While we are waiting for, did the slide just disappear?
Yes, that was my putting it back.
Okay, great.
Thank you.
While we're waiting for members of the public to call in,
I can ask Vice President Strauss
if she has any initial comments.
And then if the board members have any clarifying questions,
we'll take those before we go to public comment
and we'll come back for more discussion.
So Vice President Strauss,
do you want to offer any framing comments?
Let me just say to Barbara and her entire team
and the West Ed support,
this has been an amazing process.
And I would say I was at that late March,
first Zoom remote planning meeting.
It was a model for what to do in Zoom,
but the team that gave input, this literacy team,
it's an amazing team of educators
that was thoughtful and comprehensive in their approach.
The plans continue to get better
and more comprehensive and more integrated.
So first, let me just say,
the stakeholder input has made it better
and the CDE team led by Barbara has been really open
and collaborative with the stakeholders.
So we are developing what will be a guidance document
really of what literacy is about,
integrating student English learner resources,
students with dyslexia.
It's a wonderful document and it's really come a long way.
So a credit to the entire process.
I just want to highlight a couple of things.
It addresses grade bands, so birth to age five,
TK through five, and six to 12.
And having participated,
I was actually on the secondary group.
Each area really looked at the developmental needs
of students and particular aligned strategies.
So while we're delighted to get this grant
and to look at piloting projects,
both at a county office and local districts,
I'm really hoping this will help inform our work
in literacy going forward statewide,
because this is a model that the county office
have to write their grants to this plan.
But going forward, as we look at supporting students
with strong literacy development,
an integrated plan like this really is a model,
kind of makes me think of our early item this morning,
where we're looking at trying to integrate documents
to provide guidance of field.
And I just think this whole plan provides that as well.
And a highlight to our ELA ELD framework,
our English learner roadmap and the dyslexia guidelines,
I think these are integrated well into the process.
And I think that's actually really, really important.
And I just appreciate the comment Barb
on best first instruction.
That's what we're talking about,
that all students get best first instruction
using these tools.
We know a lot more now than we did before
on how to do best first instruction,
how to integrate this.
And so I think this plan really sets the stage.
So having been at the two literacy team meetings
and then at the IQC,
I've just watched this get developing better.
And I'm really looking forward to seeing the final plan
at our March meeting,
and then the rollout and actually implementation of it.
So thank you very much for the continued work.
Thank you.
All right.
Are there any clarifying questions
about the content of the presentation
before we go to public comment?
I think I see member Sun with a hand up.
Yes, thank you.
Yeah, I just have a question related to
how these grants might fit in
with our statewide system of support.
I know it's gonna be related,
but how do we tie it and how do we make the dotted line
to these county offices that will be receiving these grants
and how utilizing that in that system?
Thank you for that question
because that was built into the proposal
and remains a huge piece of what it is
we're trying to accomplish here.
So as those seven subgrantees work with the schools
and districts that they're funded to support,
our hope is that they'll be learning a lot,
like going deep, not just with literacy,
comprehensive literacy, that's a given,
but to be able to go deep around one of those seven priorities
and learn and create resources and learn lessons
that we can then bubble up
to the larger statewide system of support.
A different literacy effort
that California is implementing right now,
the Early Literacy Support Block Grants,
provides for an expert lead in literacy
who also works with us in our division very closely.
So we are part of the system of support.
We are working with the expert lead
and between the repositories and the resources
and the expert lead and our involvement
in the system of support,
our intent is to ensure that the learning
that's happening with those seven subgrantees
bubbles up and is integrated
into the larger system of support
that we'll be able to share more widely
far beyond those seven subgrantees.
So thank you for that question
because pulling all those pieces together,
as I noted early on,
the CDE staff who have taken on the coordinating role
have got a lot of coordinating to do,
but I'm feeling very confident in our ability
to share some really great stuff.
Thank you.
Thank you for clarifying that
and we'll go to public comment now.
Is there any public comment?
Yes, it looks like we have about 30 people
in the queue for public comment and this is for item six.
I will open up the phone line now.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, good afternoon.
I'm Jennifer Deal and I'm here
on behalf of Californians Together.
As a veteran educator of both primary and upper grades,
I'd like to draw your attention
to the TK-5 portion of the SLP.
As it's currently drafted,
this section focuses primarily
on the early literacy needs of TK-1 students.
However, we know students in grades two through five
have unique instructional needs
in order to access increasingly complex texts.
For example, when engaging with informational texts,
TK-1 students gather information from provided sources
to answer a question with guidance and support,
whereas 4-5 students must draw evidence from texts
to support analysis, reflection, and research.
My ask isn't controversial.
Yeah, it isn't small or inconsequential.
Please incorporate the needs of students
in second through fifth grade
into the TK-5 portion of the SLP.
Thank you so much for your work and time.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Gisela O'Brien,
Biliteracy and EL Education Specialist
at the Center for Equity for English Learners
and Affiliated Faculty
in the Department of Educational Leadership at the LMU.
I'm here to urge you to add ELD
to the statewide literacy priority areas
for TK through 12th grade.
We know that despite new policies
and take time for ELD,
both designated and integrated.
However, the findings from my research
and that of my colleague, William Saunders,
as well as our review of the literature on ELD indicate,
one, focused ELD instruction
makes consistent and significant differences.
Two, teachers that consistently instruct ELD
during a designated block of time
devote more time to help in early education
and to get as well as show higher gains in those areas.
Moreover, there is evidence
that suggests a strong relationship
between higher or efficient
and successful acquisition of early reading and writing.
Similarly, ELD instruction across the grades
that provides opportunity for small group output growth
and vocabulary instruction
is effective in accelerating acquisition.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
My name is Carla Herrera,
a Biliteracy Educator for over 45 years
and former IQC member.
I was vice chair of the ELA ELD SMC
in the room where it happened
during the framework development
of the five interconnected circles of implementation,
expanding our teaching strategies
to develop oral language and meaning making for students
to become literate and fluent,
including and especially English learners.
I'm here to caution and overemphasis
on phonics instruction
and recall lessons from the past
as we have repeated this discussion every 15 to 20 years.
The excitement of hearing children
sound out words falls flat
when asked about what they have just read
and they respond, I don't know, with a blank stare.
I urge you to ensure a more comprehensive focus
on literacy aligned with all five themes of the framework
and grants awarded to implement the SLP.
Instead of I don't know,
let me tell you about what I read
and I can write about it in two languages.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Do you have one minute?
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
I'm Lily Ruvalcaba, English Learner Tosa
with Mountain View School District
and Californians Together.
I'm here today to implore you
to call out the importance of developing
all four language domains
when it comes to literacy development for ELD.
Research shows that ELDs need more than foundational skills
as evidenced by research included
in the 2006 National Literacy Panel
for Language Minority Children and Youth Report
which concluded the following,
that while components of teaching reading skills
are important for all children,
they are not sufficient for ELDs
and when made the cornerstone
and sole focus of language arts instruction
results in a growing achievement gap.
Having worked with ELDs for 30 years
as an elementary teacher,
I've witnessed the benefits of developing
all four domains of language and literacy
within the context of the content.
ELDs must develop schema and content knowledge
through meaningful language experiences,
utilizing the four domains while they learn to decode
or they will not be effective readers.
Once again, ELDs need more than foundational skills
when it comes to literacy instruction
as they must learn a new language and grade level content
while simultaneously learning to read.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
I am Alisa Arrigoza representing Californians Together.
I am a teacher on special assignment
for the Mountain View School District in Ohlone, California
providing support to teachers head start through sixth grade.
I've been a bilingual educator for 30 years
and have the opportunity to work
on the state literacy plan team this year
in the birth to age five group.
We appreciate the following recommendations
that have been incorporated within the state literacy plan.
In the birth to five section,
you have the following revisions
that support dual language learners,
including language regarding bi-literacy
from state guidance and policies
was added to the introduction
and in the birth to age five section.
Information regarding the ELD desired results,
developmental profile, the DRDPs and guidance
for observation and documentation
of young dual language learners was added to this section
and the assessment systems section
of the comprehensive and integrated literacy model.
Language was added to the English learner roadmap section
to clarify its application
from early childhood to grade 12.
Teacher preparation for early childhood education
will be added to the comprehensive
and integrated literacy model.
Thank you for incorporating our recommendations
toward creating a more comprehensive document,
keeping our youngest learners in mind.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Do you have one minute?
Your time starts now.
I am Lori DePole
and I provide volunteer literacy tutoring
to foster youth.
I have significant concerns
about the state literacy plan.
CDE and its federal grant application
committed that it would one,
provide educators and school administrators
with a coherent literacy vision,
two, provide recommendations
and a plan for state and regional leads,
and three, highlight comprehensive information
regarding evidence-based strategies
for literacy instruction.
The current plan is drafted does not do this.
It is not a coherent literacy plan.
It is merely a high level summary
of existing policy frameworks and guidelines,
many of which do not currently align.
The plan literally cross references
over 5900 pages of such policies.
The plan does not address the needs identified
in the statewide needs survey.
We have a state literacy crisis
and this draft plan does not provide clear direction
as to how to incorporate the science of reading
into our state's classrooms
and work towards closing our significant literacy gap.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
My name is Sharice Guerra
and I'm here to testify on behalf of Californians Together
and I work for the Subrata Early Academic Language
field model.
We are concerned about the requirement
to administer universal screening
for dyslexia to all kindergarten students.
Screening for dyslexia is not the same
as screening for some party good literacy instruction.
A universal screen for dyslexia is to identify pathology
and should be based upon teachers identifying students
who might be struggling with literacy.
As a parent of children who were in a 90-10
Spanish dual language program, I have a major concern.
Some phonemes are different in English than Spanish.
If he took this screener, he may have been identified
as having dyslexia.
Not because he's struggling in reading
but because he hasn't been taught.
A universal screener could lead to over-identification,
especially for students who do not speak English.
For students that are making normal progress
and are not struggling to read,
whether in English or another language,
this assessment for dyslexia is not necessary.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
My name is Jorge Pacheco, Junior President
of both the California Latino School Boards Association
as well as the Oak Grove School District Board of Education
and the current elementary ethnic studies bilingual teacher.
Any literacy framework must explicitly center
culturally sustaining and relevant pedagogy
as a priority for all TK to 12 students,
not just grades six to 12.
With over 77% of our state student population being of color
and almost 20% being English language learners,
literacy instruction must center our state's great ethnic,
racial, and linguistic diversity.
And doing so in the state literacy plan
would be a vital place to start.
As a mixed-race Korean, Maya Salvadoran English learner
myself, I almost didn't graduate high school
and spent years in community college learning the literacy
that I was supposed to have been taught in my K-12 education.
What I needed as a kid was a pedagogy that would have kept
me engaged in education, reading about my own histories
and seeing myself as an intellectual
rather than a problem.
Unfortunately stories like mine are still all too common
and many English learners are still not making out
of the school to prison pipeline like how I barely did.
Help our kids succeed by explicitly centering culture
and sustaining and relevant pedagogy
into the state literacy plan for TK to five
so that all of our students succeed in our public schools.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good afternoon, my name is Karina Sapien.
I work for SEAL and I'm here to speak
on behalf of Californians Together.
I have been a public school educator for over 30 years,
including seven years as an elementary principal.
We assert that attention must be paid
to students' oral language proficiency
as students are expected to read.
As mentioned in the letter submitted
to the State Board of Education by Professor Goldenberg,
reading proficiency is a function of two sets of skills.
One, accurate and fluent work recognition
and two, adequate language proficiency
to comprehend text being read.
Without both of these skills working together,
just a narrow focus on one will lead
to widening gaps in achievement.
As principal, I saw firsthand how a narrow focus
on foundational skills produced great decoders
in the early grades, only to see our English learners
fall behind as they progressed through the grades.
Why?
Because intentional oral language practice
critical to building language proficiency
and reading comprehension was neglected.
We've been there before with no child left behind
and we all know that our English learners
were in fact left behind.
We urge you to include oral language
as an equally essential component of literacy instruction.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Hello, caller, are you there?
Okay, moving on to the next caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good afternoon, my name is Ruth Barajas
and I'm a former elementary school principal
and teacher and I'm calling with Californians Together.
We appreciate the reference to ELD
in the state literacy plan that has been augmented
and clarifies that designated and integrated ELD
is a legal requirement and therefore it's something
that all LEAs shall provide as opposed to should do.
Also, we are very happy to see that the section
on designated and integrated English language development
has also been augmented and makes clear
that it is incumbent on every California educator
to understand California's model
of comprehensive ELD instruction.
Thank you for all of this work.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good afternoon, I'm Marta Hernandez
with Californians Together
and we wish to thank Barbara Murchison and her team.
We appreciate the expanded focus on bi-literacy
including added references to dual language resources
including the new CVE publication
improving education for multilingual
and English learner students.
We also appreciate the clarification that literacy
also refers to bi-literacy throughout the plan.
There is an enhanced description of the importance
of the five key literacy cross-cutting theme
described earlier by Yali Yopp
and the explicit language that asserts
that foundational skills are necessary
but not sufficient for all students to develop literacy.
As described by Hallie earlier,
ELA and ELD are interconnected
and for English learners,
ELD is a necessary literacy component.
Literacy experts should have a more comprehensive
literacy focus and all five themes
and ELD, PK-12 need to be a component
of all grants awarded to implement
the California Comprehensive State Literacy Plan.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
This is Christy Hernandez representing the Los Angeles
branch of the IDA International Dyslexia Association.
The statewide needs survey shows
that school districts overwhelmingly want to understand
how to incorporate a structured literacy approach
and the California Dyslexia Guidelines
into their general education curriculum.
The draft state literacy plan doesn't provide guidance
on how to do so.
The only language referring to structured literacy
that appeared in the draft state literacy plan
is on page 89 where it provides a description
from the California education code
and then refers to California Dyslexia Guidelines
for more detailed information on dyslexia screening,
assessment, and instruction.
The needs assessment cited the IDA knowledge
and practice standards for teachers of reading
for the definition of structured literacy
and yet the state literacy plan
doesn't mention the IDA standards.
We ask that you consider the IDA standards
as you move forward.
We appreciate all the hard work you are doing.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, I'm Allison Berseno, associate professor
at San Jose State University.
Here on behalf of Californians Together,
thank you to the committee for your wonderful work.
While foundational skills are essential,
the TK-II fifth grade section of the framework
currently disproportionately focuses on foundational skills
in relationship to the other four themes
of the LA ELB framework,
which are meaning making, language development,
effective expression, and content knowledge.
New research by California's own P. David Pearson
and others demonstrates the importance
of these other four themes
in addition to foundational skills.
Just as foundational skills are a precursor to literacy,
so is language.
California's LA ELB framework is admired across the country
because it explicitly calls out that literacy
is built on a foundation of language.
The framework's over-reliance on foundational skills
could move the state backwards in our attempt
to ensure English learners have access
to 21st century education.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
I am Lucy Edwards from Napa County Office of Education,
representing CESA
and its Curriculum and Instruction Steering Committee.
CISC submitted a detailed letter of feedback
to the State Board of Education regarding this action item.
CISC wants to acknowledge the efforts by CDE
and various state agencies that went into the development
of the state literacy plan.
We believe the document is well-balanced
regarding attention to English learners
and students with disabilities.
There are ample resources included
for both these student groups.
We recommend more guidance be added
for supporting African-American students, though.
This student group has some of the lowest performances
across grade levels on the cap
and yet have been largely excluded from the plan's narrative.
In addition, as currently written,
CISC believes that the state literacy plan
raises the synopsis of the various state documents
related to literacy.
CISC is concerned that the document is not yet a model
of an executable plan for school districts to follow.
We have heard that a companion tool is being created
to help districts develop their own plans.
In the meantime, CISC recommends
that the state literacy plan be renamed
California State Literacy Initiatives,
a Synopsis of Guiding Documents,
to better reflect its current content.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
I am Toby Meyer, and I have a son with dyslexia.
My son would never have learned how to read
without using a structured literacy approach.
Structured literacy benefits all and is critical to some.
Our school districts are begging for more information
on how to incorporate structured literacy
into the Gen Ed curriculum.
Respondents to the statewide needs survey
overwhelmingly stated their concerns
about the lack of sustained quality professional learning
to support students with disabilities.
They noted that their current curriculum
does not align with the California Dyslexia Guidelines
and that the LEAs need more professional learning
on the guidelines and the ELA ELD framework.
Yet structured literacy is only mentioned once
in the entire state literacy plan,
and it refers readers back to the Dyslexia Guidelines.
If the guidelines, which have been out for several years,
have not provided the professional learning
that the school districts so desperately need,
merely cross-referencing them
is not going to address this need.
California's grant application stated
that it would highlight
comprehensive evidence-based strategies
for improving literacy outcomes.
The draft has written our kids down.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Aleta Fisher.
I am the advocacy chair
for the San Francisco Unified School District
Community Advisory Committee for Special Education.
I have to say, thank you so much for all the work
that's gone into everything that's happening here.
And in particular, I'm excited to see
the California Dyslexia Guidelines
and California Practitioner's Guide
for Educating ELLs with Disability referenced.
But as mentioned by many previous callers,
the reference isn't enough and doesn't go far enough.
I am excited to see that best first instruction, MTSS,
and UDL are all called out here.
But as a parent of four students with disabilities
and as a special education advocate,
I unfortunately very often find myself
in the unenviable situation
of having to explain terms like structured literacy,
UDL, MTSS to not only fellow parents,
but teachers educated.
We need to do better in integrating all this
so everyone understands what we're talking about here.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good afternoon, this is Sarah Lillis with Teach Plus.
We appreciate the hard work that the staff
and the state literacy team and IQC
and everyone else put into drawing together
the many pieces of this literacy plan.
Our teacher leaders appreciate the opportunity to review
and provide feedback during the process
and the edits that have been made.
We understand the purpose of this
as a plan to align an existing initiative
and it does a good job of that
and it's an important first step.
But as our teachers reviewed the plan
and reflected on their own experiences in the classroom,
they noted that it also helps highlight what's missing
and where there may be need for state level change
or investment to advance the vision of statewide literacy.
Moving forward, we hope that elevating statewide needs
be also be an explicit part
of the continuous improvement process
and impact of subsequent grants focus on that.
One quick example, we appreciate the priority
to build teacher capacity across disciplines
for literacy instruction.
But our teachers believe it's really important to do so
but noted that some existing standards like CTE
do not reflect that focus.
We also really appreciate the priorities
of building capacity for foundational skills
and that's really where it's rubber hits the road
and meets the road and we hope to be able to help figure out
what that looks like, thank you.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
My name is Megan Potente and I'm co-state director
for Decoding Dyslexia California.
DDCA has submitted specific written comments to the SBE
but I will now speak to our larger concern.
20 years of experience as an educator
has taught me the importance of a coherent plan.
School leaders deserve a literacy plan
that defines clear steps toward implementation
of evidence-based practices that will close opportunity gaps
for disadvantaged students.
This however is not the plan being put forth today
which is more of a pile up of existing state guidance.
The stated goal of the grant is to improve literacy outcomes
for students who have been traditionally underserved,
children living in poverty, English learners,
children with disabilities and foster youth
are supposed to be prioritized
if the plan lacks the focus needed to spur improvement.
Alignment and integration are cited as the goal
yet the plan is a disjointed compilation of excerpts
and references to approximately 30 different guidelines,
policy documents and framework.
Time.
We can do better, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Yes, good afternoon, Leticia Garcia
on behalf of the Riverside County
Superintendent of Schools.
We appreciate staff's work with stakeholders
and field experts to develop the draft plan
before you today.
I may now for two suggestions.
We ask that the final plan include additional information
regarding the effective use of the TK
to second grade reading assessments
in order to monitor and ensure students
are mastering standards in primary grades.
This is critical for early prevention and intervention.
We also ask that the final plan address all student groups
that have been traditionally underserved
per the data included on page 54.
This is important not only to ensure
for the success of all students,
but also to better align the plan
with the purpose of the grant.
Again, thank you for the opportunity to comment.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Lexi Lopez on behalf of EdVoice.
While we recognize the plan is intended to pull together
and reference multiple source documents,
standards, guidance, and frameworks,
EdVoice urges the plan be amended
to reference key findings from the science of reading.
A comprehensive state literacy plan
is precisely the document that should include
the unambiguous evidence from science
of what works in early reading.
In doing so, the state can fulfill its grant commitment
and more importantly, be sure California
is supporting teachers as best we know how
so that all students and student subgroups,
including English learners and students screened
as struggling, can achieve measurably better outcomes
over the period of the grant and beyond.
Specifically, when the plan references foundational skills
and evidence-based instructional strategies,
EdVoice urges the board to require the level of detail
in subdivision B4 of section 44259 of the education code.
We recommend amendments to the plan, the glossary,
and background documentation on the website.
The evidence is clear.
Children can be taught to read well
and we know California can do better
in supporting these teachers.
This will be a stronger plan with explicit reference
to the scientific evidence of skills.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
My name's Carol Carolson and I am the parent
of a child in special education.
She struggles significantly with reading and writing
and her team has no idea how to help her
and has little understanding of the foundational skills
and routinely minimizes them.
This comprehensive state literacy plan
does not provide clear guidance or direction
to teachers or IEP teams and they cannot act on it.
Schools need to develop much deeper understanding
about how to serve readers,
including universal screening, diagnostic testing,
and how to use it to inform instruction.
And this is for not only mono English students,
it's all students.
All students can suffer from these problems.
Most of the guidance documents referenced in the plan
minimize foundational skills and many educators
I have encountered are almost hostile about them.
For many students who struggle like my daughter,
these skills are very critical.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, Jessica Sacco on behalf of Children Now.
I'd like to start by thanking Barbara Murchison
and the state literacy team for all of their efforts
to pull together this plan.
It's clear a great deal of work went into this process.
Their interest and openness
to accepting stakeholder feedback
and their efforts to try and bring together
the broad variety of resources
that the state has produced over the last few years
to improve and promote literacy.
That being said, we still do have some concerns
around the focus on foundational skills
as outlined in the plan,
particularly the impact that that focus could have
on our English learners.
And we will hope you will consider the feedback
that you received today in regards to that matter.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
This is Lisa Moscow
and I'm calling on behalf of Speak Up.
In the comprehensive literary
state development grant application,
there's no highlighting of comprehensive guidance
based on the science of reading.
In the RECA content specifications,
which carefully detailed
foundational reading instruction skills for teachers.
It was specifically tatted in this application,
but zero references made to RECA
in the state literacy plan.
I urge the board to develop a coherent vision
that aligns resources and guidance
instead of cross referencing thousands of pages
of underlying guidelines and policies.
LEAs need clear guidance to inform their approaches
so they can choose the evidence based practices.
Most of all, we need underserved kids,
English learners, standard English learners,
foster youth and students with disabilities
to be able to access a comprehensive
science of reading based plan
that offers them access to literacy across the board.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Yes, this is Dr. Katherine Christo,
professor emeritus at California State University,
Sacramento, and I wish to address teacher preparation.
In its grant application,
CDE states that the commission on teacher credentialing
works to ensure that pre-service candidates
have the knowledge and skills
to provide reading instruction and literacy development.
The grant application specifically cited as a strength
and as reason for federal grant consideration
that teacher preparation programs
are required to align their coursework
with the reading instruction competence assessment
or RECA content specification.
However, the draft California State Literacy Plan
is silent as to RECA content specifications.
The RECA content specifications contain critical information
regarding evidence-based
foundational reading instruction standards
or teacher preparation program
and need to be at minimum cross-referenced
as a resource in teacher preparation in the CSLP.
Time.
Adherence to these content specifications
will help ensure that our teachers know critical information
regarding the science of reading.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, this is Robert Mullinger
and I'm a parent in the Mountain View Richmond School District.
The federal grant requires California
to advance literacy skills
through the use of evidence-based practices,
activities, and interventions,
including pre-literacy skills reading and writing
for children from birth through grade 12,
with an emphasis on disadvantaged children,
including children living in poverty, English learners,
and children with disabilities.
Yet, in the state literacy plans,
literacy priorities for grades six through 12,
dyslexia, which is the single largest learning disability
and affects up to 20% of California students,
is not mentioned,
nor are the California dyslexia guidelines referenced
under the supporting students with disabilities
in grades six through 12.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Gwenda Carvalho-Sell.
I am a parent of a struggling reader,
but one who has greatly benefited
from structured literacy methodology.
I believe they work because I've seen them work.
My daughter can read.
This comprehensive state literacy plan
does not provide clear guidance or direction
that her teachers would be able to follow to help her.
I have found that most teachers
do not have a solid understanding
of how to teach foundational reading skills,
even when students are identified for intervention
or resource services.
I know there is more to reading than decoding,
but if a child cannot decode,
they will continue to struggle with reading.
I thank everyone for their efforts on this project.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Ronit Glickman,
and I'm a public school teacher
with the Santa Rosa City Schools,
and I'm also the mother of a student with dyslexia,
and my daughter would not be able to read
without her tutor who is trained in the science of reading.
I spent my own money and my own time
to get additional professional development
and training in multisensory structured literacy.
It is powerful and it is empowering to know
that I can support all my students
as well as students with learning disabilities.
This current draft plan does not provide the guidance
aligned with the science of reading,
and it does not help our school leaders
implement evidence-based reading and writing instruction.
In a recent publication from the University of California,
San Francisco Dyslexia Center,
it said investing in early screening and teacher training
would provide an astonishing 800 to 2,000% return.
There needs to be a strong emphasis
on early universal screening for children
at risk of reading failure,
as well as provide structured literacy across all tiers.
Every teacher deserves to know the science of reading,
and every child is a teacher who knows it.
Thank you for your work and time.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation.
Alexis Zaragoza-Diaz,
representing the California Association
for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
The Foundational Reading Skills Approach
to Literacy Development limit and minimize
the full literacy and biliteracy development
for English learners.
The California Common Core Standards for ELA and ELD
calls for a curriculum that reflects
an integrated model of literacy,
not just foundational skills,
one in which the students can learn
foundational skills,
one in which the integrated communication processes
of reading, writing, speaking, listening,
and language development are closely connected
and support the development of one another.
We must go beyond foundational skills
for our English learners
by including all five literacy themes
as identified in the ELA, ELD framework
in order to provide English learner students
a rich, robust, and comprehensive learning approach
for true literacy and biliteracy success
from TK through 12th grade.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Nancy Rudding,
and I am a teacher trainer of structured literacy
throughout the state of California.
I have spent 40 years teaching
and trying to help teachers
gain access to the structure,
the science of reading.
The reality is that according to the 2019
nation's report card,
37% of fourth graders in the state of California
are reading at a level below basic.
This is not acceptable.
I do not feel the state literacy plan
addresses foundational skills for the state.
I am all in favor of good literature.
I am all in favor of oral language.
Everything has to be included.
I totally agree,
but we cannot turn our backs on the kids,
whether they're ELL kids, English language learners,
struggling readers,
or kids that come from a low language background.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Dr. Marlene Batisan.
I'm the Director of State and Legislative Affairs for CABE.
We're concerned about the requirement
to administer universal screening for dyslexia
to all kindergarten students.
There's already a trend of over-identifying
our English learner students as special education students,
and if we begin to assess students prior to an opportunity
to participate in instruction,
we will continue to expand on this trend.
Therefore, it should not be considered
a full battery of assessments
and should absolutely take place after instruction
has begun on the later part of the kindergarten year.
Additionally, screening must be strategic and efficient
and part of an instructional program
aimed at promoting literacy growth and development.
As part of that, teachers need to be on the lookout
for signs of a possible disability
and have input as to students who may need to be screened
versus students who are English learners.
Prior to making a decision on this,
much more discussion needs to occur
as to for which students
and for which age the screening is appropriate,
and definitely that it should not be given
until late kindergarten at earliest.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Jennifer Reynoso.
I'm a parent of a special education student
in Burbank, California.
I would like to give feedback on item number six,
the SLP draft fails to show meaningful support for students.
School needs evidence-based reading
and writing instructions, examples, the science of reading
that adheres to the California guidelines of dyslexia.
It is also critical that schools
have early identification screening,
universal screening in all schools.
Schools also need support implementing these guidelines
along with teacher and staff training.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Christy Dennis.
I am the parent of two students
in the Pasadena Unified School District.
They are both English language learners.
I first just want to respond to the comment
that just preceded the last one about screening for dyslexia.
Both of my children have dyslexia
and both of them are English language learners
and there is absolutely no reason
why a screening for dyslexia would in any way
negatively impact English language learners.
If only my children had been identified earlier,
so much heartache and education loss could have been avoided.
I look at the NAEP reading scores
for the state of California
and more than half of our students are basic
or below basic, so clearly what we have been doing
is not working and I just cannot understand
why our legislators don't have the courage
to try a different approach,
particularly when we have decades upon decades of research
about how to teach children to read.
It works for children across the spectrum
and it's very simple.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Rachel Hurt
and I'm a school board member
in a mid-sized unified school district
in the California East Bay.
The ELA frameworks and many of the guidance documents
compiled in this document seem to minimize
or bury the foundational skills
and the concerns expressed by some of the commenters
before me about foundational skills
and universal screening reveal how desperately
guidance and alignment is needed.
I really hate to see the state waste this opportunity
to finally create an overall comprehensive literacy plan
that addresses all of these factions
and puts the reading awards to bed.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Diana Weir, reading specialist and consultant.
The most fundamental responsibility of a school
is to teach children to read.
My concern is that without explicit details
of how to support educators,
our grant money will be spent
on misguided assessment and instruction
and the needs of our struggling readers,
second language learners,
and children of color and poverty will not be met.
I am asking the team to establish criteria norms
in three core areas,
teacher knowledge, universal assessments,
and effective instructional materials.
In the area of teacher knowledge,
use the standards provided
by the International Dyslexia Association
to evaluate and provide professional opportunities.
Secondly, establish reliable universal statewide assessments
that identify students at risk.
This consistency within our large state
is a necessity when providing systematic instruction
for transient children.
Thirdly, follow the lead of Colorado and Arkansas
in providing districts with a list
of approved reading programs
that have passed a rigorous review.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for item number six.
Thank you very much.
Let me make sure I'm not on mute.
Appreciate all of the public comment
and we're now ready to engage in discussion with the Board.
Are there comments or questions from Board members?
And remember, this is not an item for action,
it's an item for information.
Member Rucker.
Thank you.
First of all, I wanted to make sure I said
and acknowledged all of the people and stakeholders
who took the time to call in for today's public comment
in discussion of this item.
I recognize that when you only have one minute,
it's frustrating to feel whether or not
you're making an impact in giving your feedback
and your opinion.
You were heard, but I can tell you that we pay attention
and listen very closely to the concerns.
I agree that we have this draft document
has come a long way since we started the drafting
and the teams have worked very, very well together.
What I heard from the stakeholders
falls into multiple buckets.
I think it's probably a good idea to take a look at
what is the difference in creating a state level plan
and the work that was clearly laid out by department staff
in doing the implementation and additional planning
and work that would be done among the agencies
that would be funded to implement this literacy plan
in working with the LEAs they will work with.
I think in the feedback I heard,
there's a difference between some very explicit concerns
about how the plan should be implemented
and what the plan should direct or mandate that LEAs do.
And so that falls into a couple of different buckets.
Our goal is to make sure at this level,
I feel that the plan clearly outlines the intent,
the purpose, the functions, and most importantly,
the overall outcomes for the funded LEAs and entities
that will be working to implement the plan.
The level of specificity about reading science
and about instruction,
that becomes more of a more granular discussion
among those entities that will actually be doing
this literacy work.
And how much work we do to amend the plan further
really comes down to A,
how many masters do you want to serve?
And really how much more content
do you want to add that will make,
that will increase the complexity of the plan
without actually getting to the meat
of what it is we're trying to do
with create this literacy plan.
I do agree that there's a concern about who is named
or identified as the students in this plan.
That's the reason why my favorite fairy tale
is Sleeping Beauty.
While there is this great attention
or this great desire to name the all
and to identify every single person
and every single student that should be involved
and served by the plan,
I think the plan's goals clearly state
that you're going to serve as a priority
the students who are underperforming.
And while I personally was concerned
that students of color,
particularly African-American students
were not named as explicitly in the plan
as English learners,
I am clear that there is a clear expectation
that the LEAs that will participate in this project
must serve English learners.
So I think that there is a way to address the concerns
that have been raised by stakeholders
about how do you balance the desire
to see some very explicit specificity
and granularity about what the plan should do,
what teachers should be learning,
as well as meeting the purposes of the overall arc
of what this plan is to do to implement the grant.
And I think that the staff have heard some feedback
and ways to address it.
I would caution against doing a drill down
to create directives that already fall
under legislative mandate
or already fall under clear intent
of the implementation of the plan,
but to make sure that LEAs are in some ways
and explicitly accountable.
So my one piece of feedback is,
and what I was hoping to see in the plan is
not the specificity that may be getting called for here,
but a clear outline of how the LEAs that are funded
and participating will be held accountable.
That goes back to what Dr. Darling-Hammond said
at the beginning of the day.
We need to take a look at how we are implementing programs
from the state and into LEAs
in ways that hold LEAs accountable for outcomes.
It's not enough to say
we're gonna raise student achievement.
We really have to address disparities.
And this plan and this literacy grant
is a perfect example of a program
that's intended to address disparities.
But what I find is missing
and that may actually satisfy some of the concerns
being raised by stakeholders,
is how are you going to expect the participating LEAs
to be accountable for the outcomes and what they report?
It will not be enough to just simply report
whether student achievement was improved,
but whether or not they actually address the disparities
in the quality of instruction,
the quality of professional learning
afforded to the educators who will be doing this program,
and whether or not there was actually an improvement
in the disparities that have led to literacy issues
in the first place.
I think taking the time to pull out and back thread
and to address that issue and focus on disparities
as our board president said at the beginning of the day,
may be the way to address a lot of the buckets of concerns
we heard among the stakeholders.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I think next in the queue is member Glover Woods
and then member Patil Brownson.
Thank you very much.
First of all, I do want to say to Barbara
and the entire team that's been working on this plan,
thank you very much.
I recognize and realize what a monumental task it must be
to bring together all of these different documents
that we have that speak to literacy
and try to bring them together
in a comprehensive and understanding way.
And so I first want to let you know how much
that hard work is appreciated and recognized
just as a point of feedback and consideration
in relation to the priorities.
And I believe one of the callers that called in today
spoke to this as well.
In the state priorities for six through 12,
it speaks to very specifically the asset-based culturally
and linguistically responsive pedagogy.
I think it's a misstep that we don't have a statement
similar to that in the transitional kindergarten
through fifth grade as well.
That's a very important piece,
not just for students that are at the middle school
and high school level,
but also for students that are beginning their journey
into literacy at that transitional kindergarten
through fifth grade level.
So I really encourage as the draft is getting finalized
and will be coming back to us
that there be strong consideration
in including that priority in the document itself.
The other piece that I would just say in closing is,
and this outlines a little bit
to Board Member Rucker's comment.
When we look at the addressing of the disparities,
how might the grant application for the county offices
that are going to,
my understanding was that they will be applying
or some type of way there will be county offices identified
to spread this, if you will, throughout the state.
What might be some things that need to be there
as pieces of accountability for those grant recipients
and also the LEAs that are going to be a part of this
to address the disparities and be very explicit
in some of the areas that were expressed today
in the comments.
The grant application might be a very good place
to be able to address that
and ensure that accountability is held.
So I look forward to the next draft.
I strongly encourage everyone to look at the feedback
that we are continuing to receive when finalizing the draft,
but thank you so much for the hard work.
Thanks.
Next is Member Patio-Brownson and then Member Navo.
I also wanted to join the chorus of appreciation
for all the stakeholder solicitation and feedback
and also the stakeholders who participated
and shared their perspectives today.
I think particularly what is unique in this presentation
is it's actually one of the first times
that the whole birth to 18 continuum
has actually been funded
and sort of brought together coherently.
So I think that is both important
and hopefully a harbinger of things to come,
that it is both something that is integrated
in terms of integration of infant toddler foundations,
the preschool foundations,
in terms of what the curriculum looks like,
but also that it's reflected in the funding formula as well
with the 15% set aside for birth to five.
I think the component that is also going to be
equally important in this TK to five space
is just to recognize that we're gonna have
some pretty severe impacts to address
as a result of COVID and disenrollment.
The number in LAUSD, which is my home district,
is that there are 6,000 kindergarten students
who just didn't show up to school this year.
And the ELA disadvantage that those kids will come into
starting a whole new semester in August or September of 21
is going to be significant.
The early literacy acquisition that happens in preschool,
in kindergarten with all of the foundational learning
around decoding and early literacy tools
are things that are gonna have to happen at warp speed
in ways that we haven't actually been able
to focus on in the past.
And I'm hopeful that this grant will enable us
to do some of that work to catch up.
In particular, two aspects that I wanna call out
that were also raised during public comment.
One is about the need to figure out
how to better balance the foundational skills
versus the more integrated approach
in a way that is responsive
to the needs of dual language learners.
If you sort of track the demographic trends for zero to five
and know who your incoming K to 12 population
will be right now, it's 60% of California's
zero to five year olds are dual language learners
who come from homes where another language besides English
is the predominant language at home.
And so thinking about how that will influence
what we need to be ready for
as we're thinking about an overhaul of our literacy programs
is all the more important
to have that balancing calculation lifted up.
The second is around the language
of equitable systems of schooling
and the need to do local needs assessments.
The numbers are egregious for English English learners,
but I think it bears emphasis
that African-American students
are the single lowest performing ELA group
and we need to figure out how to do something differently.
It's a two to two and a half differential,
sorry, two to two and a third X differential
between black students and white students
and black students and Asian-American students.
And it's something that isn't unique
to the elementary grades.
It persists throughout the grades
where African-American students are coming in at 31%,
meeting or exceeding standards in third grade
and not progressing significantly,
which all I think suggests
that it does need to be called out in a different way.
And we do need to have different mechanisms
for accountability to make sure
that those numbers move in the future.
Thank you.
Member Navo?
Yeah, I'll be quick board president.
I got about a quarter tank left.
I'm getting really tired.
Getting a break right after this.
Come on, come on sir.
Well, I just want to, a couple of things.
First, Barbara, thank you.
I appreciate especially the mention
of the teacher librarians and library model standards,
as well as the hard work of your team.
I also heard a lot of comments about the dyslexia issue
and I know that California has done a lot of work
with the California Dyslexia Guidelines
and there's a lot of information
by the Journal of Pediatrics around screening for dyslexia.
A lot of good information that I think could be helpful
to some in the field.
My quick question is this,
it's going back to Glover Woods,
board member Glover Woods comment about the RFA process
as something to the extent that we can control this.
I would love to see a process in the RFA
that awards the grantees the disbursement
of this $37.5 million beyond just
that you are a great grant writer,
that you actually have a track record as a county office
for supporting your schools with literacy development
and you can show some evidence
that we've supported these schools and we've gotten results,
as opposed to an RFA process
where because I have a great grant writer,
I acquire the grant.
So just something to consider.
All right, thank you very much.
I think I've gotten, is there anybody that I did not see?
Looks like those are all the hands.
Lots of good advice.
I'll just add two quick thoughts
and then we're gonna break for 10 or 15 minutes
and come back and finish up.
One is that there is a lot of people referenced,
quote, the science of reading.
There is quite a lot of knowledge base
about the teaching of reading.
We have many districts
that have dramatically improved reading performance.
You know, member Navo is from one of those,
Sanger is relatively famous for that,
both generally and for English learners
and for students with special education needs.
San Diego, which is one of now the highest performing
urban districts in the country on the NAEP and so on.
So I think, and there's a research literature
about effective programs.
So it may be useful to put together some synthesis
and summary of that understanding
so that districts can refer to what may work for them
in their context, but may be informed by what is known.
Certainly we should be asking for that kind of evidence
when people are writing their grants.
The second thing I'll just point out is that
part of the problem is not necessarily always
the training that teachers receive.
It's the fact that many teachers don't receive training.
So we have been in a situation of severe shortage
for at least five years now.
And looking at the challenges for African-American students,
I did an analysis of where those students are.
African-American students in California are located,
most of them in only 25 districts
and in those districts, they're disproportionately
in the highest poverty schools and in those schools
is the highest proportion of teachers
without credentials, without training at all.
And in many of those districts and schools,
70 or 80% of the incoming teachers over recent years
have come in without preparation to teach.
And so if we want to solve this problem,
it's not only about upgrading the training
that some teachers get, but making it possible
for all teachers to get training
and putting the incentives and supports in place
where students are getting a revolving door of teachers
who haven't had the opportunity to get good training.
And that gets to a whole nother part of the policy framework
that we need to have to get to a place
where all students are in fact getting
the kind of instruction and reading literacy
that will benefit them.
So I want to just add my appreciation
for all of the work that's gone into the plan,
and I suggest that we hopefully make it easy
for folks to access the literature about what works
and what has worked in our own California districts,
as well as what works generally
and also solve the problem of our teacher shortages,
which the governor's budget does include
some useful investments in.
With that, Barbara, thank you very much.
We really appreciate you.
We hope you got a lot out of the input,
all of the additional input on the plan.
We'll take a 12-minute break till 4.15,
and I have to attend to an urgent matter,
so when we come back, Vice President Strauss
will hold the gavel for a bit,
and we'll see you at 4.15, thank you.
We can reestablish a quorum if you'd like.
Yes, okay, board members,
we're gonna do a roll call vote to reestablish the quorum,
so Brooks, would you please do the roll call vote?
Of course.
Member Sun.
Here.
Member Strauss.
Member Rucker.
Here.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Patil-Brownson.
Here.
Member Navo.
Member McQuillin.
Here.
Member Glover-Woods.
Member Fatah.
Here.
Member Burr.
All right, we have a quorum.
Thank you.
I'd like to take up our waiver consent calendar,
which includes waiver items W01 through W04,
so we'll now open the phone line for public comment queue.
The slide is up, so members of the public
wishing to provide comment on any of the items
may do so by calling now into 712-432-00,
oh, I guess it's the numbers different,
770-4906, access code 1166083 pound.
Are there any public comments on waiver items W01 through W04?
We do have one speaker signed up in the queue.
I will open the phone lines now.
This is for W1 through W4.
We encourage you to state your name
and affiliation for the record on the waiver items,
W01 to W04, and the district name to which you are speaking.
Thank you.
My name is Gary Bray.
I am a management consultant for the county superintendent.
This is in regard to the waiver for Belbridge School District.
Go ahead.
You have one minute.
Very good.
My name is Gary Bray.
I am a management consultant
for the Kern County Superintendent of Schools.
I've been appointed as fiscal advisor
to Belbridge School District.
This public comment is submitted in support
of Belbridge's waiver request.
Excuse me, excuse me, Mr. Bray?
If you don't mind calling back in just a moment,
we are taking up W1 through W4 right now,
and then afterwards we will be taking up W5.
Oh, that's W5.
Just hang on the line, please.
Thank you.
Okay, it looks like that concludes public comment
for W1 through W4.
Okay, thank you.
Since there's no other public comment,
I'll now ask for a motion on waivers W1 through W4.
Do I have a motion?
I will move.
Go ahead, Ting.
I'll second.
Okay, I move.
So we have a motion by Member Sung
and seconded by Member Navo.
Now we'll call the roll call vote.
So Brooks, would you please call the roll?
Member Sung.
Aye.
Vice President Strauss.
Yes.
Member Rucker.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Patil-Brownson.
Member Navo.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Fatah.
President Darlin-Hammond.
Member Burr.
Aye.
It passes.
Thank you.
Now we're going to take up a waiver O5,
which is a waiver request
by Bell Ridge Elementary School District
to waive portions of the California Ed Code sections
35780 and 35782,
which will allow the district to lapse.
I think this item will be recommended,
will be presented by Larry Shirey from CDE.
So Larry, welcome.
Nice to see you and you're welcome to begin.
Thank you.
I'm trying to, oh, I guess Alex,
you've already got the presentation up.
I'm trying to share my screen here.
I can't share, well, I know there's a bit of sharing.
We can see it now.
Oh no, now it's off.
Vice President Strauss,
I think we lost Larry, just hold on one moment.
I'm still here, it's just that I'm being popped around
because I can't share my screen.
I'm sorry.
Because I can't share my screen right now.
Alex, and you're able to share?
I can share Larry,
would you want me to share it for you?
Sure.
You know, I think I can't share it
because I've been told that someone else is sharing.
Okay, I will share it for you then.
And you just tell me when to toggle slides.
Sorry, go ahead at the beginning, the first slide.
Can you go to the title slide?
Can you hear me?
We can now, and we can see the slide.
But can we go to the first slide?
I'm not seeing the first one.
I'm not sure where we are.
The slide says Lapsations Statute.
That's not the one I have and that's.
That's.
The slide says Bell Ridge ESD Request.
Right.
I'm showing your title slide right now, Larry.
Okay, I don't see that.
So I'll just assume that.
Okay.
Okay, this is a waiver request
from the Bell Ridge Elementary School District
in Kern County.
It is asking you to waive the threshold
for lapsing the district.
Next slide, please.
And allow it to be annexed into an adjacent district.
Section, the education code requires
an elementary district to be lapsed
if ADA in grades A through eight,
in grades one through eight falls below six.
Bell Ridge Elementary has 35 students in it
and it's asking the State Board
to waive that six ADA requirements
so that it would be required to lapse
regardless of enrollment.
Next slide.
The reasons for the request are twofold.
One is that the district has had great difficulty
attracting residents from the community
to serve on the governing board.
Currently, all members of the district board
are appointed County Board of Education members
because a sufficient number of community members
have not filed for the governing board elections
or have not responded to requests
for appointment vacancies on the board.
I don't see many districts where the number of students
in the district is twice the number of registered voters,
which is the case here.
County Board members have been majority
on the three-member Bell Ridge Board
for at least the past decade.
There has only been one four-year period
where any member from the community
was on the district governing board.
Bell Ridge District has also been under financial stress
for a number of years.
The district has a negative certification.
The County Superintendent has appointed a financial advisor.
Negative certification means that the district
will not meet its financial obligations
for the current or two subsequent fiscal years.
We have at the CDE have been tracking the status
of the district because of its negative certification.
We concur with the County Superintendent's determination
that the district is facing fiscal insolvency.
Both the district and the County Superintendent
agree that expenditures at the district
cannot be reduced below current levels
without jeopardizing student learning and safety.
Next slide.
State Board approval of this waiver
will trigger Kern County actions
to lapse or dissolve Bell Ridge District
and annex it to an adjacent district.
You've dealt with these waivers before.
You've had 12 similar waivers over the past decade.
We haven't talked about them much
because prior to the waiver coming in,
they've been able to work out a local resolution
in terms of which district will be annexing
the lapsing district.
That's not the case here,
despite the County Superintendent working with the districts
for at least the past year
that I've been in contact with her.
They have opposition.
The McKittrick Elementary School District
is the most likely recipient of a lapsed Bell Ridge District.
They are opposed, and it's our understanding
that McKittrick will be addressing you today.
Given that, we thought that we should probably talk
just a little bit about the lapsation process,
and I'm going to provide some very brief
background information on the affected districts
and things that the County Committee
on School District Organization will be considering
or may be considering when they determine
where to annex the district
should you approve the waiver.
Again, I'm only providing this information for background.
What you're doing today is simply moving the county forward
to begin the lapsation process.
You do not have a role to play in determining
which district will annex the territory.
That's the County, the Education Code
gives that responsibility to the County Committee.
Next slide, please.
This table contains Bell Ridge District
and the four potential districts that would annex it
if it were to lapse.
A little bit of background information,
but the most important piece here
is the Union High School District
in which the districts are components.
Bell Ridge is a component of TAF.
McKittrick is also a component of TAF,
whereas the other three districts
are components of other high school districts.
What that means is if Bell Ridge lapses
into one of the three districts in the bottom of the table,
then there's also a boundary change
with the high school district and relocation of
or redesignation of residency for a few high school students,
something that the County Committee
might take into consideration.
Next slide, please.
The County Committee likely will also take into effect
educational program effects.
In this case, Bell Ridge has,
and one of the things they might look at
is the numbers of English language EL students
in the districts and the change in program
that might come into play if student composition
is changed in McKittrick.
As you can see, Bell Ridge is over 30% EL students.
If you call from the previous table,
the other three districts that aren't in this table here
are all well over 50% EL.
McKittrick has no EL students.
That's one thing that the County Committee
may take into account this educational program effect
when they decide where to annex the lapsed Bell Ridge district.
Another consideration may be the fact
that McKittrick is a district of choice.
About two thirds of its students are from out of district
attending school through the districts
district of choice program.
Next slide, please.
The most important thing that the County Committee
is gonna take a look at is the fiscal effect
of annexing Bell Ridge upon lapsation.
Bell Ridge and both Bell Ridge and McKittrick
are basic aid districts.
You can kind of see the difference in the revenue per ADA
in the far right column.
Basic aid districts tend to have higher numbers there.
Bell Ridge isn't listed,
but their revenue limit is over 15,000 per student.
The second column is the County Superintendent's
projected effect the first year of lapsation
in terms of looking at revenue minus expenditures
after annexation.
Again, as basic aid districts,
McKittrick is the only district here that would benefit
from the property tax revenue from Bell Ridge.
The other three districts are LCFF funded.
Next slide, please.
Again, the County Committee is going to be looking
at all of these issues, fiscal, educational program,
and other administrative issues
that could be affected by annexation
when it makes its determination
where to annex the lapsed territory
of the Bell Ridge School District.
And annexation includes not just the territory,
but all the fund balances and obligations,
students, property, and staff.
Again, that's the County Committee's responsibility
to do that, and it's not a role
that the state has any say into.
Next slide, please.
One of the key players, obviously,
is the County Superintendent's goals.
County Superintendent has fiscal oversight responsibility
for all the districts in her county.
Mary Barlow, the current County Superintendent,
recognizes that there may be some negative fiscal effects
on any district that's annexing Bell Ridge,
so she's taken some pretty extraordinary steps
to try to make the annexation process
a little more positive.
Bell Ridge, before this school year,
had six employees, not counting the Principal Superintendent
who will be retiring at the end of this year.
As part of budget-cutting moves,
the district laid off three of these,
half of her employees for the current school year.
The County Superintendent, in turn, hired those employees
and has assigned them back to the Bell Ridge School District.
What that means is that Bell Ridge
is not having that cost,
and therefore, they're not draining their reserves,
their funds as fast as they might be,
and therefore, there'll be more money available
for the district that annexes the Bell Ridge,
should it be lapsed.
The County Superintendent also had a offer on the table
to reimburse whatever district annexes Bell Ridge
for the remaining three employees.
I don't believe that offer still is on the table,
but the County Superintendent has given assurances
that she will take care of the three remaining employees,
either through a new agreement, similar agreement,
or the County Superintendent
may hire the employees herself.
What that does then is that the district
that annexes Bell Ridge will be relieved
of probably the biggest cost of taking on Bell Ridge District.
That's the employee cost compensation.
Next slide, please.
So in summary, we've got a local determination
that Bell Ridge Elementary School District
is not a viable entity for the two reasons
that I've already gone through.
CDE agrees with that local determination.
The Bell Ridge District is requesting
that the State Board approve a waiver
that the County actions to lapse the district can begin.
Lapsation and the subsequent annexation of Bell Ridge
are County responsibilities.
State Board approval of the waiver
does not include direction regarding these responsibilities.
Department's recommendation
is that the State Board of Education
approve the Bell Ridge ESD's request for waiver.
I can respond to any technical questions
or clarifying questions now
and certainly after public comment,
I'll be available for any other questions.
Thank you.
I'll continue with this item and just ask,
we're gonna put the slide up for public comment
for members of the public wishing to provide comment
and while we're waiting for the members of the public
to call in, I'd ask member Rucker
if you have any initial comments
and then we'll ask board members
if you wanna ask a clarifying question.
Sure and I wanna thank the staff.
Larry Shirey is very, very technically advanced
on dealing with these lapsation issues
and he is correct.
We have dealt with lapsations in the past
and it usually hasn't percolated up
to this level of attention
but there is a great deal of controversy
at the local level around many of the concerns
that he's laid out.
So I want to tell my colleagues on the board
that the State Board has a very narrow role
in this process and in this issue
and it simply is to approve
or consider approving the waiver request
from the Bell Ridge District.
If the board approves the Bell Ridge
Elementary School District waiver request,
the county committee will consider
the superintendent's county fiscal analysis
along with other relevant information
to make decisions that will go forward on the process
regarding which districts will annex Bell Ridge.
I wanna emphasize what Larry explained.
The board's approval of the waiver does not,
the waiver request does not include
a determination by this board
of which district will annex the lapsed territory
of Bell Ridge.
The waiver approval would require the county committee
to conduct, to do the lapsation
and order that the district's territory be annexed
to one or more adjourning districts
as it seems to the county committee
to be in the best interest of adjourning districts
and the residents of the lapsed district.
I took on and really looked at
and studied Ed Code section 357-80
to make sure I understood and was very clear.
Our only role in dealing with this waiver
is to approve or consider approving the waiver request.
I do recommend we approve it
because it gives the actions for the county superintendent
to recognize the annexation
and as a result to do the work to take a look at
and move forward on the considerable amount
of time and resources and efforts she's already done
to inform the process that's taking place
at the county level.
Thank you, member Rucker for your comments.
Do we have any board clarifying questions?
Just looking to see if I see any hands raised.
Anybody?
So I don't see any hands raised right now.
So are there any public comments?
Yes, we have four people signed up in the queue.
I will open the phone lines up.
This is for waiver W5.
Well, we encourage you to please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Remember to turn down the volume of your computer
if you're following the live feed
and remember speakers, you are limited to one minute each.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Gary Bray.
I am a management consultant
for Kern County Superintendent of Schools.
I have been appointed as fiscal advisor
to Bell Ridge School District.
This public comment is submitted in support
of Bell Ridge's waiver request.
Bell Ridge School District currently serves 25 students,
but fewer than a third of the district's total enrollment
resides within its boundaries.
The district has been facing declining enrollment,
fiscal insolvency and a continuing inability
to establish a local governance team.
The district is committed to working collaboratively
with any annexing district and the county committee
to achieve as smooth a transition as possible
for both Bell Ridge and any annexing district.
The school community understands that lapsation
is necessary and is prepared and in agreement with lapsing
at the end of this school year.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute and your time starts now.
Good afternoon, members of the board.
My name is Mary Barlow
and I am the Kern County Superintendent of Schools.
I want to add my voice in full support
of Larry Shiree's analysis and recommendation
of the waiver request submitted
by the Bell Ridge School District.
If the waiver is granted, my office will work closely
with the Kern County Committee
on School District Organization
to determine which of the contiguous elementary districts
will be the best choice to assume the territory
and educational responsibilities of Bell Ridge.
And we stand ready to assist the annexing districts
with planning and communication
to address student and staff concerns.
But most importantly, we'll work to ensure
that the students of Bell Ridge
receive an equitable educational opportunity.
And we look forward to finding a local solution
that best meets the needs of students of Kern County.
I also stand ready to answer any questions
that the SBE may have related to our work
to date in this process.
Thank you for your consideration of this waiver request.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute and your time starts now.
My name is Barry Koerner.
Superintendent McKittrick Elementary School District.
For generations, Bell Ridge and McKittrick schools
have considered themselves to be a common community.
For several months, the staff
of the Kern County Superintendent of Schools,
Bell Ridge and McKittrick have discussed
the Bell Ridge's potential lapsation.
However, lack of clarity regarding the long-term fiscal
impact of merging the two districts spurred McKittrick
to initiate a neutral third-party budget review
conducted by School Services of California.
This revealed that the lapsation would add
a significant financial burden to McKittrick
and accelerate deficit spending.
We hope that this board and the county committee
will consider the negative impact
on the district's students, staff, and communities.
We remain committed to collaborating with all stakeholders
to determine the best path of lapsation
for Bell Ridge back into McKittrick if possible.
The Bell Ridge and McKittrick students are in our hearts
and we ask for honest and direct consideration of finances
including Bell Ridge's significant unfunded OPED liability.
This will ensure all possible outcomes of lapsation
are equally evaluated.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute and your time starts now.
Hi, good afternoon.
My name is Erin Stagg.
I am legal counsel for Bell Ridge Elementary School
District and was requested to provide public comment
in support of the waiver by Superintendent Reynolds
and the board president.
As the board has heard and Mr. Shirey presented,
the district faces significant budget concerns
and has a least decade long history
of difficulty seating and governance team.
The waiver request was submitted because lapsation
would allow the district to move quickly and efficiently
to get families settled in a new district.
The stakeholder groups, they were included
in the conversations regarding a proposed lapsation
and the school community supports lapsation at this time.
I do want to concur that Bell Ridge and McKittrick
have been working closely together
and have continued to work collaboratively
to answer some of the questions that McKittrick has had
and Bell Ridge remains committed to working collaboratively
with any annexing district and the county committee
should this waiver be approved.
We thank the board for your time, for your comments
and respectfully request that the waiver be approved.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for waiver W-5.
So now we're open for board discussions of board members.
Please remember to raise your hand
to the participant panel of Zoom
if you have a question or a comment.
Do we have any comments from board members or question?
I see none.
So let me ask, is there a motion?
I will move the staff recommendation
to approve the waiver
from the Bell Ridge Elementary School District.
Do we have a second?
I'll second.
Member Navo second, thank you.
Any further board member discussion?
Okay, so Brooks, would you take a roll call vote
on this motion to approve the CDE recommendation?
Of course, member Sun.
Aye.
Vice President Strauss.
Yes.
Member Rucker.
Aye.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Patil Brownson.
Yes.
Member Navo.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Glover Woods.
Member Patel.
Yes.
President Darling-Hammond.
Member Burr.
Yes.
It's approved unanimously.
Terrific.
So I will go ahead then with the next consent agenda,
which is regular items seven through 14.
We're going to do this in two votes,
item seven and then items eight through 14
so that we can take a cut of recusals.
First, we'll take up item seven, the CTEIG allocations.
Cynthia and Eileen, please recuse yourselves
by turning off your cameras and microphones
and magically disappearing.
We will now open the phone line for public comment
on consent item seven.
And the public comment slide is up.
If you want to provide comment on item seven,
call the number listed on the slide
and enter the access code noted there.
Are there any public comments on regular consent item seven?
No, there's none.
All right.
If there are no further public comments,
I will ask for a motion on consent for item seven.
Do I have a motion?
I will move consent item seven.
Thank you very much.
Member Sun in a second.
I will second.
Thank you very much, Member Rucker.
We will now hold a roll call vote.
Brooks, please call the roll.
Member Sun.
Aye.
Member Rucker.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Patil-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Navo.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Fatah.
President Darling-Hammond.
Yes.
Member Burr.
Aye.
It's approved.
All right.
Thank you.
So, Patricia Dacasse,
can you please let Cynthia and Eileen know
that they can return to the meeting?
And Member Sun, will you please recuse yourself
by turning off your camera and your microphone?
And let's see when Cynthia and Eileen have returned.
I see Eileen.
Oh, we're good.
Okay.
I will now take up consent items eight through 14.
And please open the phone line for public comment
on regular consent items eight through 14.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment,
they do so by calling the number listed on the slide
and entering the access code that is noted there.
Are there any public comments
on regular consent items eight through 14?
No, there's not.
All right.
Given that there's no public comment,
I'll ask for a motion for consent on items eight through 14.
I move the consent items eight through 14.
Thank you.
Do I have a second?
Second.
Thank you very much.
I will now hold a roll call vote.
Brooks, can you call the roll?
Vice President Strauss.
Yes.
Member Rucker.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Patil Brownson.
Member Navo.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Glover Woods.
Yes.
Member Fatah.
President Darlin Hammond.
Yes.
Member Burr.
Aye.
It's approved.
All right.
Can we please ask Patricia
to let member Son return to the meeting?
And as soon as she has, we will continue.
All right.
I see that we have all of our members,
including member Son, member Strauss,
and member Glover Woods.
So we are reopening item one
to take action on the preliminary report
of actions draft November 2020 meeting minutes
to take up the SBE screening committee recommendations
for appointments to the ACCS
and report on our liaison assignments.
So the first is the state board draft preliminary report
of actions minutes for the November 5th, 6th, 2020 meeting.
While we're waiting for any members of the public
to call in, we have a motion from a board member
to approve the minutes from November 5th and 6th.
I'll move approval of the minutes.
All right.
Do I have a second?
I'll second.
Thank you very much.
Are there any public comments?
There is nobody in the queue
for public comments for item 15.
All right.
Any further discussion?
Board members, please raise your hand
in the participant panel of Zoom if you have a question.
I see one from member Rucker, is your hand up?
No.
Okay.
So Brooks will please call the roll.
Member Sun.
Aye.
Vice President Strauss.
Yes.
Member Rucker.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Patil Brownson.
Member Navo.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Glover Woods.
Yes.
Member Fata.
President Darling-Hamilton.
Yes.
Member Burr.
Aye.
It's approved unanimously.
All right.
I'm now going to ask Vice President Strauss
as Chair of the State Board Screening Committee
to present the committee's recommendations
for service on the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools.
And while we are waiting for any members of the public
to call in, I have a motion from a board member
to approve the screening committee recommendations
for appointments to the ACCS.
So let me just say thank you to Member Sung
and Member Glover Woods for an amazing service
as screening committee members this year.
We had a lot to do.
You guys were great team members.
And we were supported by State Board and CDE staff
through all of our processes.
So to the whole team.
So we met to screen for a member to ACCS
for representing charter schools.
So the screening committee is recommending Matt Taylor,
currently is Superintendent of River Charter Schools.
And this will be for a two-year term from January, 2021
to end of December, 2022.
We are also recommending a new Chair of ACCS.
We are recommending Mike Walsh,
who is a trustee for Butte County Office of Education.
And he represents the governing boards of school districts.
And we're recommending him as our new Chair.
Thank you.
And do we have any public comment?
No, there's nobody signed up for public comment.
All right, do we have a motion on the recommendations?
I'll move.
Thank you, do we have a second?
I'll second.
Thank you very much.
Is there any further discussion?
All right, I don't see any hands raised.
So Brooks, you may call the roll.
Number Son.
Aye.
Vice President Strauss.
Yes.
Number Rucker.
Aye.
Number Rodriguez.
Yes.
Number Patil Brownson.
Number Navo.
Yes.
Number McQuillan.
Number Glover Woods.
Yes.
Number Fatah.
President Darling-Hammond.
Yes.
Number Burr.
Aye.
Carries unanimously.
All right.
So we're gonna go to the board member liaison reports
and I want to ask board members to report out succinctly
on any liaison activities that are not related
to any items on our January agenda.
And because we're doing everything
in reverse alphabetical order today,
I'm gonna start with member Son.
I think he must be liking getting used
to being the first in line.
Yeah, I have to pay attention.
I know.
So yeah, so thank you very much.
The California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee
is meeting later this month on the 29th of January.
And we just continue our work in the implementation
of the Perkins Plan and lots of conversations
around a state plan for career technical education
and in the measurements for how we look
at quality career technical education programs in the state.
Great, that was very succinct, well modeled.
Vice President Strauss.
High standard.
So I'm a member of the advisory board
for the Center for Advancement of Instruction
and Quantitative Reasoning.
It's a CSU, based at CSU to collaborate
with school districts to look at a fourth year of math
that would help students be ready for math in college.
And I just have to say, they're very thoughtful
about the quantitative reasoning.
They have a collaboration with a lot of leaders
and continue to look at pilot projects
that are actually preparing students
after algebra two or integrated three for a fourth year,
not necessarily calculus, pre-calculus
to keep kids ready for college.
We'll hear more about this, I'm sure,
in the math framework discussion
about how to prepare students,
but I just wanna thank them for continuing
to collaborate with districts
to try to give students the support in mathematics.
And the IQC met on November 18th and 19th
on ethnic studies.
Member Glover Woods and member Rucker were with us
for two days on this process.
And the draft is now,
ethnic studies model curriculum is out
for 45 day public comment period, it's almost over.
There were 57,000 public comments during the process
and it resulted in more than 240 edits.
So very thoughtful public comment
and worked by the instructional quality commission.
And I believe my colleagues may have a little bit more
to say about that process.
That'll be coming to us in March.
The California Collaborative for District Reform,
which is a group of districts and state leaders
and researchers who meet three times a year,
met December 2nd and 3rd on the issue of race,
equity and COVID-19 navigating the crisis
and building for the future, highly relevant.
I have to say we heard student voice as a panel
to help inform our practice.
And I can't say enough about how important it is
that we listen to what students are telling us
about their experiences during remote learning.
It was impactful and really helped to,
we had a panel for parents and community on priorities
and then also district leaders just talking
about the urgency and listening.
So I think we all talked about what member Darling-Hammond
started today's conversation at the board about,
which is we have to improve the outcomes in our system
and we can't go back the way we were
before we left to remote learning.
So anyway, to the districts that are continuing to advise
and impact this work was really impactful.
See, and then we are a member of that NASB,
the National Association of State Boards of Education.
And they had a presentation by the CDC last week.
And just let me just say that there are a bunch
of resources, NASB has guidelines
on thinking about civics education,
a lot that we've been involved with through,
remember Patio Bronson as our liaison
and also our civic engagement work.
But they did, the CDC did share some valuable resources.
I just wanna highlight to look at their website
if you're interested on tools for a healthy new year,
how to clean and disinfect schools,
how to monitor and evaluate tools and resources,
interview and focus guide resources,
updates for quarantine.
So again, huge amount of resources at CDC.
I know our staff is involved with them regularly,
if not every day, but I just think
for school district leaders important
and staff to know that that's an important resource as well.
And then our concurrence commission is my last comment,
as our subject matter project was supposed to meet,
is going to meet later this month to talk about an update
on where the subject matter projects are working.
As you heard, they're informing the project
that we started with earlier in the day
and they are important partners in our work.
So that'll be coming up later this month.
Thank you very much.
Great.
Member Fatah.
I'm sorry, I got out of order.
Member Ruckers next in the reverse alphabetical order.
Okay, thank you.
First of all, I'd like to begin by thanking
Board Member Sun for reporting on the work
that's being undertaken
by the California Workforce Joint Advisory Pathway.
I'm sure I got that acronym all wrong,
but you know which one I'm talking about,
Board Member Sun.
The work that I do wanna point out
that one of the most important functions
that the staff and this panel have undertaken
is to do an evaluation of the metrics
that we have adopted to evaluate the state plan.
And I think that the learning pain
and the growing pain that they have dealt with
in trying to do this work
is something that could be helpful to us
in the matters that we spoke about
concerning the state literacy plan.
Because we really are tasking ourselves to ask,
are the metrics we've chosen
to giving us information about the function of the program
in the way we intended.
I wanna thank Board Member Strauss
for her reporting about the work of the IQC.
The IQC has undertaken a lot of very controversial
and important work,
and we'll continue supporting them through that work.
And I also wanna thank Dr. Jo Bowler
for her overview about the work that's been going on
with the mathematics framework,
because that satisfies my entire presentation
or discussion about what I was gonna share
about what's been going on with the math framework.
I'm very excited to be able to present that framework
eventually to my colleagues on the board.
Finally, I would like to close by saying,
I'm also a part of a study group
that's being sponsored by NASB,
the National Association of State Boards of Education,
concerning educating the whole child.
They have really turned their attention
to the impact of COVID in school closures
and our alternative learning environment.
They have a wealth of resources that have been provided
to states and state boards of education to guide this work.
And I believe a lot of what they have done
has informed the conversations that we saw presented
to us today during the discussions
about the distance learning framework.
But I also would like to encourage my colleagues
who also take a look at the other resources
that they are providing.
It's been an interesting work group panel
and interesting work group activity.
My next meeting is coming up in February.
All right, member Rodriguez.
Yes, hello everyone.
I'll try to make this quick.
So as you saw in the consent item,
the arts instructional materials adoption is moving along.
February, we'll know how many publishers
plan to participate.
Reviewer trainings will take place in April.
We're looking forward to having new instructional materials
for arts since 2006.
CTC met on December 3rd and 4th
and there was actually a special meeting the day before,
strategic planning workshop session,
which involved examining a lot of the goals
for 2020 and looking at how to develop
the strategic plan for 2021.
Some of the trends were around anti-bias and racial justice,
COVID-19 impact, preparation for virtual learning settings
and technology use.
And so there was a lot of constructive feedback
and it's important to note that the CTC has,
it's purview established and a lot of the comments
were actually not related to the responsibilities of the CTC.
Those were addressed, but definitely very favorable.
The stakeholders really appreciated the direction.
So moving on to the regular meeting,
as schools remained closed,
one of the concerns is that candidates,
teacher candidates and educator prep programs
who began their clinical practice this year
in a distance learning model,
might not have the opportunity
to do the supervised clinical practice
in a face-to-face setting.
There exists some concern that they may not develop
certain skills that are key to good teaching
like the strong classroom management skills
or positive student engagement.
However, we did hear from some of our stakeholders
who said that they're engaging,
they're being very resourceful and forward thinking
in the ways that they are working with the students.
So these were some of the comments,
but it turns out that the student teachers actually said,
no, we're being very creative
in the way we're working with this.
The critical role of induction,
providing teachers with support and coaching,
including a focus on teaching in the classroom.
It's imperative to clarify the roles
between site administrators, especially once we go back,
mentors, preliminary programs,
how we can ensure the success for the new teachers
and with the onboarding processes.
So this is gonna have an impact on the employers
because they're going to need to tailor
some of their onboarding for the new educators
who haven't had that in-person training, right?
So that creates like another dilemma
for the onsite administrators.
They're gonna have some challenges
once we go back to in-person instruction.
I'm speeding through this, it's a lot more,
but I'm like being very succinct.
The commission has engaged in a multi-year effort
to address the changes in which students with disabilities
are served in California schools.
This resulted in the reorganization
of seven special ed credentials into five essentials.
And the commission approved three pathways
to earning updated credentials.
Coursework through commission approved
preliminary special ed program,
professional development approved
by the local planning area or educational agencies
and demonstration of prior knowledge
via observational data,
a portfolio submission, video demonstration.
Educators will be allowed to utilize all three methods,
but no educator will be required
to apply for a bridge credential.
With existing special ed credentials,
they'll be able to continue to,
they're authorized to teach any content
that their credential currently authorizes.
And let's see here,
I wanted to get to the teacher residency grant programs.
The result from the initial evaluation of the first year
for the residency program showed many partnerships
are beginning to make progress
toward increasing the number of teachers in shortage areas,
special ed, STEM, and bilingual,
as well as the proportion of teachers of color.
And lastly, this goes to one of the reports
that we heard at the beginning of the meeting,
parent and family engagement and pre-service preparation.
The CTC was updated on the collaborative work
that has taken place between public advocates,
SDSU and CTC staff and the parent organization network
on the multi-state effort related to family engagement
for teacher and administrator candidates.
And so they provided a great report
and it has, the initiative has two key outcomes,
institutions of higher ed, state agencies,
and key stakeholder groups will address family,
school, and community engagement
in meaningful and effective ways.
And educators and administrators
will effectively put in place teaching practices,
organizational infrastructure, and policies
that create meaningful opportunities for families
to engage their children's in education.
Thank you.
Terrific, thank you.
Member Patio Bronson.
Okay, so I have three items.
One is that on December 1st,
the master plan for early learning and care was released,
which is an exciting blueprint for the next 10 years
to address how zero to five year olds
should properly develop, be supported in their development
and should be school ready
as they enter into the K to 12 system.
Of relevance, particularly for this board,
there is a recommendation around
growing the transitional kindergarten program,
which is already administered and overseen by LEAs,
as well as the idea of having at least two years
of preschool for low income three and four year olds.
There's also a component where for the first time,
the early learning programs would be applying
the model of LCFF of targeting
based on low income students foster youth
and English language learners,
which is a great bit of coherence
to bring between the two systems.
And special thanks to board president Darling Hammond
for all of the wisdom and insight and also cat herding
that she undertook to make this all happen.
And it's really, it's the first time that California
has actually brought these two system leaders together
and actually articulated path for California
to think about how to get ahead of so many of the challenges
so that there's less remediation
and more of a focus on prevention in the early years.
In addition, there was a tour of San Diego Unified's
transitional kindergarten program,
which has piloted a number of innovations,
public private partnerships,
focus around transition and articulation
between preschool TK and the K to three
early literacy pipeline,
which was attended by several members of the legislature,
as well as agency heads within the department of ed,
as well as the department of social services
where the younger children programs are overseen.
And then lastly, I wanna say a special thank you
to all of the government and civics teachers
across the state who have on the fly
had to absorb quite a lot
and talk to 6 million school children across the state
about what unfolded in our capital.
So I offer special thanks to all of the teachers
who are talking through what the electoral college means
of why it's relevant to actually honor the vote,
the difference between peaceful first amendment,
protest and violence,
and actually bringing these conversations
into the classroom in a way that our students
can actually grapple with what is history unfolding,
but also very teachable moments.
Thank you for here.
Member Navo.
I had a number of highlights, I'm gonna highlight one.
Obviously, the CCE continues to work in collaboration
with the city and county offices and geo leads
in building and supporting the field
with a number of issues
that our communities and students are facing.
One highlight in particular is the leading forward series
that launches on January 25th.
It features free on-demand keynotes and courses and tools,
and it's primarily focused on resources
that are designed to meet the learning loss mitigation needs
and underserved students and communities.
And it focuses on five areas
that I think will be helpful to the field,
systems leadership, thriving socio and economically,
advancing equity formative assessments
and responsive teaching and learning.
A lot of information that is being done in collaboration
can be found on the CCE website.
I would encourage people to access that
to get the information that they need.
But that particular highlight is one
that is fairly important
and will be very helpful to the field.
Thank you.
Member McQuillan.
All right, not a whole lot to report.
I'm looking forward to the revised date
on the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee.
On the 29th, I look forward to that.
Some of the recent round table discussions
that our state superintendent has had
has sparked the interest to have other round table discussions
here in the North State on ethnic studies
and Native American studies.
So I'll be participating in a couple of those
coming up in the near future.
And it's sparking a lot of good dialogue
of how to assist our students,
our Native American students
and underrepresented students
in here in extreme Northern California.
So I'm looking forward to that.
And that's all I have, thank you.
That's great.
I hope we'll be seeing more and more of that
as the Ethnic Studies Model Curriculum comes to us in March
as the resources roll out
for supporting that kind of professional learning.
Member Glover-Woods.
Thank you, and I'll kind of build off of that
regarding the Ethnic Studies Model Curriculum
just to kind of piggyback on
Vice President Strauss' comments.
The comment period for this last draft
that's currently there is open right now.
It will end on January 21st.
And as I'm sure many of you guys know,
we'll anticipate the CDE recommendations
coming to the Board in March.
So we're quite excited about that.
And as it relates to world languages,
we just approved the reviewers.
So just to let you know some of the work
that's gonna take place over the spring.
In February, we'll have an idea of how many publishers
are wanting to participate in the adoption process.
And then in April, the reviewer trainings will take place
and the deliberations will take place in July.
Of course, everything will be held virtually,
but we're excited that we will have some materials
for world language coming up fairly soon.
Lastly, I would like to share that I did have an opportunity
to participate in the Education Commission
of the State's Early STEM Policy Academy.
I was with Dr. Stephanie Grayson from CDE,
then Stuart from Children Now,
and some other great colleagues across the state
to talk about what STEM instruction
can and should look like for our younger learners.
And it was quite a robust conversation with other states,
as well as internally with California.
And I will stop my comments right there.
Thank you.
Member Fatah.
Thank you, President Darling-Khan.
And I'd just like to say that my liaison kind of tasks
have been really centered around following up
from the presentations that we heard back in November
from students at the Student Advisory Board on Education,
hosted by the California Association of Student Councils.
So CASCS, Governmental Affairs and Policy Director,
and I have been kind of in conversation almost daily
about how to get some of those proposals to legislators
and in the hands of legislators
before their bill packages are due in February.
So one of the ones that we've been focusing on particularly
has been regarding student board members,
student board member rights,
and the potential creation of a Student Advisory Commission
to the state board.
And also another proposal
that we're kind of really pushing forth with is one
that kind of builds off the state school of civic engagement
that we passed earlier last year
to create a student civic learning book.
And so next week I'm actually meeting
with board members Navo and Executive Director Allen
to discuss that.
And I guess my final thing is that I recently joined
the Cradle to Career Data Systems
Community Engagement Subcommittee.
And so that has its first meeting next week
and I'm really excited about it.
Great.
I am next in the list
and most of the things I've been working on
have been discussed in this meeting,
but I will just piggyback on the comments
that Member Patio-Bronson made about the master plan
and early learning that will set up, I think,
a process that will bring much more to this board
around the ways in which we think about universal pre-K
and the ways in which those elements of the program unfold
in our state.
So that's something to look forward to.
And I will pass the baton to Member Burr.
Thank you.
So two of my assignments
are accountability and charter schools.
You heard the accountability items this morning.
A board member Ting and I,
or Son and I have been spending a lot of time
on charter school regulations,
which as you know will be deferred to a later date,
but stay tuned.
Thank you.
You leave us in suspense.
Well, we're gonna move on to agenda item 15.
We need the public comment slide to go up again,
which is the moment for general public comment.
I'm looking for that slide
and it's looking like it's coming, here it goes.
Public comment is invited on any matter
that was not included on the printed agenda.
And we will open the phone line for the public comment queue.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so by calling the number on this slide
and entering the access code.
Are there any public comments?
We do not have anybody signed up for public comment
for item 15.
Okay.
I hereby end today's session at 5.16 PM
and look forward to seeing you again at 8.30 tomorrow morning.
Have a good evening, everyone.
Thank you all.